WILL BEGIN IN SIXTY SECONDS.
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY ADD TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WHO MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
ACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
AND I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
PARTICIPATING IN PERSON TODAY.
WELCOME MEMBERS TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND ALL IN OUNCES
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 844-867-6163 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE ONE ZERO ONE SIX
FIVE FOUR FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ZERO SORRY ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AGAIN
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY AHMAD
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN POSITION
OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER.
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
AND MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEA YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN THIS. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM AS WELL
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE. TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND AS
CLOSE MANNER. AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
A NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE'VE GOT A BIG HEARING
TODAY WE NEED TO FINISH BY NOON
MEMBERS SO THE CHAMBERS CAN BE
CLEANED AND PREPARED FOR THE
AFTERNOON HEARING. THE TO
FACILITATE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE LIMIT- TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT
OF TIME FOR WITNESS
PRESENTATIONS. EACH SIDE WILL
BE GIVEN UP TO FIFTEEN MINUTES
BUT PLEASE DON'T FEEL LIKE YOU
HAVE TO USE ALL THE TEAM. WILL%
BE HERE TO KEEP TIME AND AFTER
THAT WE'LL TAKE WHATEVER TIME
IS NECESSARY FOR MEMBERS TO
DISCUSS THE BILLS. NOW LET'S
GET STARTED WITH THE BUSINESS
OF THE COMMITTEE BY
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A MEMBERS PLEASE OF A REMINDER
TO PLEASE SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE. GONZALEZ HERE
BECAUSE HERE BATES. THANK YOU
WITHOUT MY OWN ASK HERE BATES
HERE ALLEN. PARTULA BARTLETT
HERE RECORD HERE CLICK HERE
CORTESE YOUR PATAGIA DOLLY HERE
DAILY HERE DOT. MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ HELLO MELINDA'S HERE
MAN THEIR MEN HERE NEWMAN HERE
NEWMAN HERE RUBIO. SKINNER.
NUMBER HERE NUMBER OF CARE BY
CASKEY. WILK. TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN WE HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU MISTER SHE CONSULTANT
OUT TO QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED I'D FIRST LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT SB FOUR EIGHTY
SIX BY SENATOR MELENDEZ HAS
BEEN PUT OVER TO THE NEXT
HEARING AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR AND SB SEVEN THREE FIVE
BY SENATOR RUBIO HAS BEEN PUT
OVER AS A TO YOUR BILL. WE ALSO
HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR THERE
ARE BILLS ON CONSENT THEY ARE
THE FOLLOWING SB FIVE TWELVE.
SB TWO FOURTEEN S. C. R. TWELVE
SB SIX FORTY. SB THREE THIRTY
THREE SB TWENTY ONE SB SIX
THIRTY FIVE. SB TWENTY SEVEN S.
C. R. FIFTEEN S. C. R. FOURTEEN
ESSERE SEVEN. SB SEVEN NINETY
S. C. R. TWENTY FOUR SB THREE
SIXTY SIX. AND SB THREE NINETY
NINE DO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU
BYE SENATOR NEWMAN. THAT COULD
CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I'M CONSENT
CALENDAR. IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS TWO PARTS THE
FIRST WILL BE A ROLL CALL ON
THE HIGHWAY NAMING RESOLUTIONS
THESE ARE S. C. R. TWELVE S. C.
R. FIFTEEN S. C. R. FOURTEEN S.
C. R. SEVEN AND S. C. R. TWENTY
FOUR. ADULT HERE YES HI GOOD
ALL THE TIME BATES AYE BATES HI
HELEN. BUT YOU LETTER HI BUT
LET AYE BAKER RIGHT TO CRY
CORTESE HI GOOD DAY CI DOLLY BY
KELLY HI DOT. DOT HI WHERE.
MULLIN I MELENDEZ I MEANT ALL
RIGHT MIN AYE NEWMAN HI NEWMAN
AYE RUBIO. SKINNER NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER GUY BY CAL SKI. WILK. TO
NOW THE ROLL CALL ON THE
REMAINING CONSENT CALENDAR
THESE ARE SB FIVE TWELVE. S. B.
TWO ONE FOUR SB SIX FOUR ZERO
SB THREE THREE THREE. S. B.
TWENTY ONE SB SIX THIRTY FIVE
SB TWO EIGHTY SEVEN. SB SEVEN
NINETY SB THREE SIX SIX AND SB.
THREE NINE NINE. CONSULT FIVE
DOLLARS AYE BATES HI BATES HI
ALLEN. SUCH A LETTER HI
BARTLETT HIGH RECORD. BY THE DR
CORTESE I CORTESE AYE DALI BY
DELHI HIGH DOT. DODD I MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ HI LINDA MAN MEN
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER NUMBER FIVE NUMBER GUY
WHY CASKEY WILK. OKAY WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHIP
CONSULTANTS- ALRIGHT SO FIRST
WE'RE GONNA START AND FILE
ORDER HERE I KNOW SENATOR
EGGMAN IS ON HER WAY SO IN THE
MEANTIME I AM GOING TO START
BECAUSE I'M THE NEXT- A SENATOR
IN LINE. FOR SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
I'M GONNA PASS THE BATON OVER
TO OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ AND-
DO I NEED TO LOOK AT. BUT. SO
PLEASE A PRESENT SB SIX SEVENTY
ONE SENATOR GONZALEZ THANK YOU
SEE- VICE CHAIR BATES A GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
WHICH IS A CRITICAL MEASURE IN
PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE OF
CLEAN FREIGHT ACROSS CALIFORNIA
RATE IS THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY MOVING
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF GOODS
THROUGH THE STATE EACH YEAR AND
EMPLOYING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS IN
TRANSPORTATION AND WAREHOUSING
INDUSTRIES AT THE SAME TIME
THREE QUARTERS ARE MAJOR SOURCE
OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS OF
HARMFUL AIR POLLUTANTS IS AIR
POLLUTANTS INCLUDE PARTICULATE
MATTER NITROGEN NITROGEN
OXIDES. WHICH CAUSE CANCER
ASTHMA AND AGGRAVATE OTHER
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES. LUCIEN
FROM FREEWAYS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR MANY OF
WHICH YOU LIVE IN MY DISTRICT.
IT IS A LONG TIME. THAT WE
ADDRESS THIS INEQUITY AND PLAN
A BETTER FUTURE FOR FREIGHT.
INCLUDING PLANNING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
RESILIENT AND READY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR STATEWIDE DURING
MISSION VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT
GOALS. SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
TACKLES THE ISSUE BY REQUESTING
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. TO COLLABORATE WITH
OTHER RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES.
INCLUDING THE AIR AND RESOURCES
BOARD AND THE PC. TO
HOLISTICALLY DEVELOPED
STRATEGIES TO CONVERT EXISTING
FREIGHT CORRIDORS INTO CLEAN
BREAK CORRIDORS THAT ARE READY
TO SUPPORT THEIR MISSION. AND
ALTERNATIVE FUEL VEHICLES. THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT
RECOMMENDATIONS BE DEVELOPED IN
A CLEAN FREE QUARTER EFFICIENCY
ASSESSMENT THAT WILL THEN BE
FOLDED INTO THE STATE AGENCY
FUNDING PROGRAMS AND GUIDELINES
RELATED TO FREIGHT. THIS WILL
HELP INSURE A SYSTEMIC SHIFT IN
HOW WE PRIORITIZE
SUSTAINABILITY IN FREIGHT. AND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE MEREDITH ALEXANDER THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FROM CAL START
AS WELL AS MICHAEL TURNER THE
DEPTH DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR L. A. METRO THANK
YOU- BETTER BY STERN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE SB
SIX SEVENTY ONE. FULLER PRIME
WITNESSES POLICE BEGAN.
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE THEM ON
THE LINE. WE HAVE THE MODERATE
DO NOT SHOW MEREDITH ALEXANDER
ON THE PHONE NO. WHO IS A
SECOND WITNESS SENATOR GOAL OF
CONSOLIDATING CATCH THE NAME
MICHAEL TURNER WITH- L. A.
METRO. MISTER TURNER ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. MISTER MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE TELEPHONE
LINES THAT WHICH IS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS
BUILDING IN PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. THEN WE WILL MOVE TO THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE-
TELEPHONE LINES AT WHICH IS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB. SIX
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION THE BILL
YOU MAY ALSO PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ON YOUR PHONE KNOWING
THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO
NO LANDING GEAR AT THIS TIME.
THEN IT W WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- AND SEE IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FULL
ACCOUNTANCY IS A SENATOR
ARCHULETA PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM YOUR CULTURE I I'D LIKE
TO- COMPLEMENT THE AUTHOR- AS
WE KNOW THE CORRIDORS- COMING
OUT OF YOUR DISTRICT- SENATOR
LONG BEACH AND AS A CONTINUE ON
THAT FREEWAY- DIMENSION TRAFFIC
AND SO ON AND IT OBVIOUSLY GETS
INTO MY DISTRICT AND SO ON. SO
I APPLAUD WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
I THINK IT'S SO- BONDED AND I'D
LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER CAR. YES SENATOR
SKINNER. ARE MOVING THE BILL.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED SENATOR
GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE UP I THINK A SENATOR
NEWMAN HAS A QUESTION OR
COMMENT ARTICLE SENATOR NEWMAN
I THANK YOU MANAGED TO CHEER I
JUST WANTED TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE SENATE OR TO
LET IT DIE I TO. WEAR MY
DISTRICT IS ALSO MATERIALLY
IMPACTED BY ALL THIS TRAFFIC-
DIED I ADMIRE THE BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY S. B. AS A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL. AND SENATOR A
BATES IF- I THINK THE TWO
WITNESSES ARE ON- THE LINE I
JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT
THEY'RE NOT JUST SO. WE'RE NOT
SKIPPING OVER THEM. THEN LET'S
GO BACK TO THE MODERATOR AND
CALL THOSE WHO ARE ON THE TELE.
CONFERENCING LINE. AND AGAIN
I'M LOOKING FOR MEREDITH
ALEXANDER AND MICHAEL. WHAT WAS
THE NAME TURNER. TURNER. HELLO
LINE FIFTY FOUR LINE FIFTY FOUR
COULD YOU STATE YOUR NAME
PLEASE. HELLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME BRIAN GANDHI AND I AM A
BULLETIN RESIDENTS. TOM CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. HELLO GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANKS FOR. TAKING MY
PUBLIC COMMENT AND I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL I LIVE
ONE BLOCK FROM THE BNSF MAIN
LINE- THREE MAIN LINE- WHAT
ABOUT THEIR DREAMS IN
COLLISION. AND I THINK THE BILL
WOULD BENEFIT FROM MENTION OF
LOCOMOTIVES I LOOK THROUGH THE
WHOLE LIKE AN ELEPHANT IN THE
BILL. THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE
ABOUT RAIL AT ALL. AND- FREE.
CRITICALLY ALTHOUGH METROLINK
ANOTHER PASSENGER RAIL YARD
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE POLLUTION
COMING FROM LOCOMOTIVES AND I
THINK THE STATE SHOULD
ENCOURAGE ZERO EMISSION
LOCOMOTIVES AND- RAIL
ELECTRIFICATION. WHICH IS
COMMON ALL OVER THE WORLD FOR
THE VERY HEAVY FREIGHT TRAINS
IN SOME PLACES JUST NOT IN
NORTH AMERICA. AND CLOSE TO A
THIRD OF THE BORDER VALLEY LONG
BEACH- FREE MAYBE AROUND 25% OF
HOLD OUT BY RAIL. AND I THINK
THAT MODES SHOULD INCREASE THE
OF THE SHARE OF THE RAIL BUDGET
INCREASE TO GET TRUCKS OFF THE
FREEWAY WITH INCLUDING SHORT
HAUL RAIL THE INLAND EMPIRE.
HAD THAT ONE THIRD. OF
POLLUTION AND- PEOPLE
CONSUMPTION PERFORATE. AND
MILE- MONITORING VERSUS THE
TRUCK IN PLUS REDUCE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION AND- CALL WEAR AND
TEAR ON THE ROADS. SYSTEMS SO-
PLEASE ENCOURAGE- MEMBERSHIP
THE- TRUCK TO RAIL AND
ELECTRIFICATION OF RAIL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
MISTER MODERATE MICHAEL HAS
JOINED THE PHONE LINE DOWN.
PLEASE CALL ON HIM THEM.
MICHAEL TURNER SHOULD I PROCEED.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MICHAEL TURNER AND I AM
THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AT DELHI
METRO IN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
I WOULD LIKE TO CONVEY OUR FULL
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
BUT LIKE TO THINK SURE GONZALEZ
FOR CARING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
ADDRESSES ONE OF THE KEY
TRANSPORTATIONS AND OUR REGION
WHICH IS EMISSIONS FROM THE
GOODS MOVEMENT SECTOR WE ALL
FULLY UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF GOODS MOVEMENT TO OUR
ECONOMY AND TO OUR REGION. WE
ALSO SEE THE IMPACT OF THAT
SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY IN TERMS
OF CONGESTION ON OUR FREEWAYS
WHAT ISN'T SO VISIBLE IN THE
AIR QUALITY IMPACTS OF GOODS
MOVEMENT ON KEY CORRIDORS IN
OUR STATE SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
PROVIDE STRONG TOOLS TO ASSESS
THE IMPACT OF THREE DIMENSIONS
ON IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AND
PROVIDES A PATHWAY TO ADDRESS
OF THE MISSIONS ARE EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES.
ARTISANAL ANGELES CROSSING
HISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- RENDON ABOUT
FREEWAYS WERE PLANNED AND BUILT
IN LOS ANGELES. THAT IS ALSO
BUT THE LEGACY OF LASTING
POLLUTION IN THOSE SAME
COMMUNITIES. SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
PROVIDES A FORMALIZED WAY IN
WHICH TO ASSESS THESE IMPACTS
BY TAKING ADVANTAGE OF EXISTING
PROCESSES. IT THEN PROVIDES A
PATHWAY TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
BY LEVERAGING EXISTING
RESOURCES. THIS BILL
DEMONSTRATES THAT WHILE THAT WE
CAN'T FIX THINGS FIRST BUT WE
CAN FIX THINGS RIGHT AT THE
SAME TIME THANK YOU THE
CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU. MR MODERATOR TO HAVE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE- THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
WOULD YOU CHECK LINES AGAIN.
ALEXANDER ONLINE PLEASE GO TO.
I AM NOW ON THE LINE CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEXANDER
WITH HOW THE COLLEGE I COULDN'T
THROUGH I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF.
SIX SEVENTY ONE- THANK YOU
SENATOR AND FOR HER LEADERS ON
CLEAN FREIGHT AND
TRANSPORTATION. HOW PART IN
INTERNATIONAL MEMBER BASED
NONPROFIT WITH OVER. TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MEMBER
COMPANIES. AND THE TURN.
FREIGHT AND- ARE PROUD MEMBERS
INCLUDE THE ECHO AND TO CREDIT
MEANING. OLOGY COMPANIES. OR
AND LONG BEACH AND- OAKLAND I'M
WE THINK BREAK CORRIDORS WHAT
WE KNOW THAT THERE MAY SOURCE
OF AIR DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SENATE
DRAFT BURDEN AS WELL AS THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
FREIGHT IT'S CRITICAL TO
ADVANCED HOLISTIC COLLABORATIVE
CLEAN GREAT PLANNING AND TO
IDENTIFY FUNDING HALFWAY. I SIX
SEVEN ONE WITH. THE INTERNET
PLANNING- AND IN THE INCLUSION
OF HEARING MISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE THINK
WOULD BE A REALLY POSITIVE
THAT- THAT THEIR MISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING POWER
ELECTRIC CHARGING AND HYDROGEN
THE COURT TRIAL. IN COURT THANK
GOODNESS MEANT THE QUICKNESS.
WE REALLY THINK THAT THE
INTERAGENCY PROCESS FOR A LOT
OF HER MORE ROBOTS IN CREATIVE
STRATEGIES AND WHAT. EACH
AGENCY MIGHT HAVE DONE ALONE.
AMBLE CARB IS UPDATING FOR
STRATEGY AND IF COPING PLAN.
AND IF THE FOR INDEPENDENTLY.
COORDINATION THE FREEDOM THERE
COULD BE A REAL MESS
OPPORTUNITIES. SO WE REALLY
THINK ALSO A CLEAR FUNDING.
BERKELEY FREE PRESS IS
IMPORTANT TO ME REAL CHANGE. I
KNOW THAT THE LAST YEAR THAT
YOU CORD AND HE HER. THAT
PROVIDE ME OUR GUIDE NOW
MISSION IN FOR PROJECT CAN BE
ELIGIBLE FUNDING I THINK THIS
IS REALLY A POSITIVE THAT.
SHOULD BE ON THE WIDESPREAD
DEPLOYMENT AND TRANSPORTATION
CONCHOLOGY- AND IT IS IMPORTANT
TO CODIFY GUIDELINES AND
CLARIFY THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
IN AGREEMENT WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
FUNDING FOR TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
YOUR MISSION INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING- I'M- NOT FINDING
WHAT ELIGIBLE FOR THE FIRST
TIME LAST YEAR BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE DIDN'T. SEE
ANY PROJECT MOVES FORWARD. SO
INCLUDING I THINK SEVENTY
MILLION BOTH THE INNER AGENCY
AND- PLANNING MATHIS TO. CLEAN
GREAT. AND WILL SUPPORT AGENCY
IN IN IDENTIFYING FUNDING
PATHWAY FOR CLEAN FREE. AND
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MISTER MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHERS ON THE LINE
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF YOU LIKE TO STATE
YOUR POSITION OF SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. WE DO HAVE LINE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
MEDICARE MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JUDY MALINOWSKI BOMB
AND ATTACKS AT THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COALITION AND
SUPPORT SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN ORDER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
GIVEN SINCE WE PASSED OVER THE
TESTIFIED YEARS EARLIER LET US
CHECK TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DIDN'T MISS ANYONE WHO MIGHT
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU COULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD THAT'S A
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THANK YOU
KNOW LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. THEN WE WILL
GO BACK TO COMMITTEE COMMENTS
AND I BELIEVE SENATOR RUBIO
WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE A COMMENT
OR ASK A QUESTION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. YES I WANTED TO
GET OUT THERE FOR BRINGING THIS
FLORIDA- IT'S BEEN STATED SO I
WON'T BELABOR THE POINT BUT WE
KNOW THAT FREIGHT CORRIDORS
ARE. A MAJOR SOURCE OF
POLLUTION IN PARTICULAR IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. MY
DISTRICT SITS BETWEEN AT TEN TO
TEN SIX OH FIVE. AND IT DOESN'T
GET WORSE THAN THAT SO I WOULD
BE SUPPORTING A SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND ASK TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR THANK YOU. K. MISSING
ANYONE ELSE. I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER MIKES UP SO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST WHEN
I THINK THE SENATORS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A
CONCERN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENTS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. THURMOND
IS AWESOME. FIVE DOLLARS I
BATES AYE BATES AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I PLEDGE LETTER HI
BAKER BY BAKER HI POTATO ALL
RIGHT. HI DOLLY VOTING AND
VOTING. DOT DOT HI MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ. MAN HI MAN HI NEWMAN
ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HI RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE SKINNER I
NUMBER HI NUMBER I BY CAL SKI.
WILK. ELEVEN ZERO. ELEVEN ZERO
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AS WELL THANK
YOU MISTER SHE CONSULTANT THANK
YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR OKAY NOW
THAT WE'VE CONCLUDED WITH MY
BILL WORK ON TO THE NXT- EIGHT
BILLS THE FIRST STEP IS SENATOR
EGGMAN WELCOME SENATOR EGGMAN
YOUR HERE TO PRESENT- ON SB
FIVE FORTY EIGHT ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND BEEN TALKING ABOUT THAT
RAIL AND SO CONTINUE WITH THAT
THIS BILL IS A SIMPLE FOLLOW UP
FROM LEGISLATION I AUTHORED A
FEW YEARS AGO WHICH ESTABLISH
THE TRI VALLEY SAN JOAQUIN
REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY AND
TASKED WITH IDENTIFYING AND
DELIVERING A PROJECT TO LINK
THE H. TRAIN AND THE BART
THEREBY IMPROVING THE TRANSIT
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN MY
DISTRICT AND- THE BAY AREA-
THIS ANYONE WHO TRAVELS AT
CORRIDORS MEASURES TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CARS AND TRUCKS
BACKED UP ON THAT CORRIDOR
EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND WE'RE
TRYING TO DO OUR PART TO SAVE
THE AT THE AIR AS. WELL AS
SIMPLE FIVE PEOPLE'S LIVES.
PLANNING FOR THAT VALUE PROJECT
IS NOW WELL WAY HAD. WE NEED
CLARIFY AMENDMENTS TO BE ABLE
TO FURTHER IMPLEMENT. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT THE STATUE
ENABLES THE AUTHORITY TO
OPERATE THE TRAIN. THE BILL TO
LEASE LANGUAGE IN THE EXISTING
LAW THAT SAYS THE CONNECTION
MUST TAKE PLACE IN THE TRI
VALLEY AREA WITH THE MOST
EFFICIENT CONNECTION POINT NOW.
IS AT LEAST READ. AND LASTLY
THE BILL ESTABLISHES THE
AUTHORITY AS A RAIL TRANSIT
DISTRICT FOR PURPOSES OF
EXEMPTING. THE PROJECT FROM-
LOCAL BUILDING AND ZONING
ORDINANCES. THIS IS A PROJECT
OF TREMENDOUS SIX YEAH AN
IMPORTANT IN MY DISTRICT IN THE
BAY AREA AS WELL AS THROUGH THE
STATE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY VIA TELECONFERENCE OR
MICHAEL TREE WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ON THE
PROJECT AND DOWN ELEVEN. HIS
WITH THE REGIONAL THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN REGIONAL RAIL
COMMISSION. THANK YOU AND
SENATOR WE'RE GONNA GIVE
PRIMARY WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH- AND AS YOU MENTIONED
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
START WITH MR LEVITT. CORETTA
HAD. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
MISTER. THANK GOOD MORNING. YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN LOVE IT
I'M MANAGER ORIGINAL DISHES
ACCOUNT HERE REACHED REAL
COMMISSION. ALKEON RESULT IS
THE OWNER. OF THE ALTAMONT
CORRIDOR EXPRESS WHICH WE CALL
THE EIGHT COMMUTER RAIL SERVICE
WHICH HAS BEEN PROVIDING
PASTORAL SERVICE TRINITY COUNTY
VALLEY ALAMEDA COUNTY AND THE
TOP AREA FOR MORE THAN TWO
DECADES. OKAY ROGER COMMISSION
IS ONE OF THE MANY MEMBER
AGENCIES WORKING TOGETHER TO
DELIVER THE BALLOT LINK
PROJECT. AT THE BOARD LEVEL MY
AGENCY IS THE POLICY MAKER
SERVING ON THE BILINGUE FOR. AT
THE EXECUTIVE LEVEL MY AGENCIES
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SERVICE ON
THE BALLOT LINK EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE WHICH PROVIDE CLOSE
GUIDANCE ON THE DEVELOPING OF
THE PROJECT. OUR STAFF HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE BALLOT
LINK STAFF. TO PLAN FOR
COMPLEMENTARY AND INTEGRATIVE
BARRELING AND EXPANDED A
SERVICE IN THE ALTAMONT
CORRIDOR. OKAY RICH GIRL IS
PLEASED TO BE NAMED AS THE
PURSE OPERATOR FOR VALLEY LIKE.
AND BOTH OF OUR BOARDS
UNANIMOUSLY APPROVEDAN INITIAL
AND- YOU FOR THIS PURPOSE. WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
CLARIFYING THAT THE BALLY BOARD
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO OPERATE
THE VALUE LINK TRAIN SYSTEM.
WHICH GIVES THEM THE ABILITY TO
DESIGNATE AN OPERATOR. FINALLY
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT MY
AGENCY HAS SUBMITTED A LETTER
TO THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE SUPPORTING THAT. FIVE
FORTY EIGHT AND WE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVITT'S OF
THE NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE MISTER MICHAEL TREE FROM
THE TRI VALLEY SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY.
YES GOOD MORNING- YOU HEAR ME
OK YES WE CAN. PERFECT HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHAEL TREE AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE TRI
VALLEY SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY AND
CERTAINLY HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FORTY EIGHT- AS MENTIONED
BY- SENATOR EGGMAN- AB SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT WHICH WAS AUTHORED.
BY THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
TRADED DAY RAIL AUTHORITY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF PLANNING. AND
DELIVERING A TRANSPORTATION
ALTERNATIVE FOR THE NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND COMMUTERS IN
THE NORTHERN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
WHO ARE TRAVELING TO THE BAY
AREA. ON ON WHAT IS OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS A REALLY
DIFFICULT AND LENGTHY COMMUTE-
SINCE ITS CREATION AT THE END
OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
FIFTEEN MEMBER BOARD- HAS
WORKED DILIGENTLY THEY'VE
COMPLETED THE STATE MANDATED
FEASIBILITY REPORT WHICH
IDENTIFIED THE VALLEY LINK
PASSENGER RAIL PROJECT AS A
PREFERRED PROJECT. AND THEY
WILL SOON- COMPLETE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK ON THE
BALLOT LINK PROJECT AND IS AS
WELL AS THE- 15% DESIGN SO
THEY- PROJECT IS MOVING ALONG
EFFICIENTLY AND- VERY QUICKLY-
IN PART DUE TO THE ENTIRE
PROJECT BEING LOCATED IN
CURRENTLY EXISTING
TRANSPORTATION RIGHTS OF WAY-
THE VALLEY LINE CRAP. CAFFREY
IS PROJECTED TO CARRY THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND RIGHT TODAY IN
TWENTY FORTY AND TO DATE WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED NEARLY EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PROBABLY PROJECT WHICH IS ABOUT
A THIRD OF THE FUNDING. NEEDED
FOR COMPLETION OF THE PROJECT-
I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION- JUST
BRIEFLY- THAT IN THE- LANGUAGE
OF THE EXISTING LAW THERE IS-
WORDING FOR THE AUTHORITY TO
DELIVER TRANSIT CAN ACTIVITY
WHICH APPEARS TO INCLUDE
OPERATING THAT CAN ACTIVITY.
AND THE AUTHORITY- WANTS TO
CLARIFY THAT IT HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO OPERATE IN
CORRESPONDINGLY DESIGNATE AN
OPERATOR FOR THE VALLEY LINK
SERVICE ONCE IT'S BUILT. AND
SO- AS MENTIONED BY DAN LEVITT
TAP. IN IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY THE BOARD APPROVED A
RESOLUTION DESIGNATING A SAYS
THE PRESUMPTIVE OPERATOR OF THE
VALLEY LINK SYSTEM ONCE IT'S
SET CONSTRUCTED. AND SO- RATHER
THAN- OPERATE TO ABOUT
INDEPENDENTLY- BASED THE
AUTHORITIES ACTUALLY TAKING
VERY CLEAR STEPS TO DESIGNATE
PACES THE OPERATOR WHICH BRINGS
A LOT OF BENEFITS TO THE
PROJECT BOTH DURING.
DEVELOPMENT AND DURING
OPERATIONS SO WITH THAT SAID
ALL CLOSE MY COMMENTS AND TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
TREE OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE IT ON TO SUPPORTERS OF
LET'S BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE
IN THE GALLERY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES- N. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
C. NINE- NOW WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ANY WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FORTY EIGHT WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU. IF YOU WISH
TO SHARE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE. AGAIN MR SURE
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE FOUR EIGHT.
S. ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. OKAY THANK YOU MR MODERATOR-
OKAY CAN WE JUST CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN JUST BEFORE WE MOVE
ON SB FIVE FORTY EIGHT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORTING ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. NO NO LINES OKAY
THANK YOU JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE SO NOW WE WILL SEE IN THE
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM OPPOSITION YOU HAVE
ONE LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
MISTER DAVID SEAN BROWN- WE
WILL START WITH HIM. FROM THE
TRAIN WRITERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA MISTER SHAWN BROWN
AND MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
GET HIM ON THE LINE PLEASE. BOB
READY TO PROCEED MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU- I'M DAVID SHOWN
BROWN. WITH THE TRAIN RIDERS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA-
PRESIDENT. BILL WAS SPONSORED
BY AN AGENCY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED TO BUILD
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN EIGHT
AND BARK IT CAME UP WITH A
GRANDIOSE PLANS THAT GOES FAR
BEYOND WHAT WAS ASKED OF IT.
THIS BILL SEEKS YOUR
RETROACTIVE APPROVAL FOR A
GREATLY EXPANDED MISSION THEY
WANT TO ESSENTIALLY SUPPLANT AS
TO BECOME AN ENTIRELY NEW
TRANSIT OPERATING ENTITY.
PLEASE DON'T LET THEM. SENATOR
SHOULD BE AWARE OF THE FACT
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
ACCURATELY DISPLAY CURRENT LAW
WHICH CALLS FOR A CONNECTION
BETWEEN AS AND BARK IN THE TRI
VALLEY REGION OF CALIFORNIA
THIS AMENDMENT IS CENTRAL YOUR
APPROVING THEIR MISSION CREEP.
THE VERY LAST THING THE BAY
AREA NEEDS IS YET ANOTHER
TRANSIT OPERATING AGENCY WE
OPPOSE GIVING THE AUTHORITY A
MANDATE FOR OPERATING. THE
LEGISLATURE CLEARLY INTENDED
FOR THIS AGENCY TO SUNSET AFTER
IT DELIVERED ITS PROJECT
BECAUSE IT DID NOT INCLUDE THE
POWER TO OPERATE WHEN IT
CREATED THE BOARD AND- PLEASE
TAKE THE BILL ANALYSIS AT ITS
WORD. THAT THE AGENCY WILL
CONTRACT WITH EIGHTEEN OPTION
AND RUN CLIENT ANYBODY RENT
THEM NEW POWERS. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOU SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION SO NOW WE'RE GOING
TO GO ON I BELIEVE THAT'S THE
ONLY- PERSON IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS
SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
CHAMBER TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBERS
OPPOSING THIS BILL FOR SB FIVE
FORTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE. ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WE
SEE NONE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE. THANK YOU WE WISH
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ME PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
FIVE FOUR EIGHT. AND THERE ARE
A FEW LINES IN Q. WOULD BE JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE. HELLO FIRST
ONLINE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS JAMES SCHMIDT. TAKING
IN BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
TRANSPORTATION WORKING GROUP IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND
THE MISSION CREEP REPRESENTED
IN THE BALLOT LINK PROPOSAL.
THE SAME LUDICROUS TO BE
ASSUMING THAT WE WOULD NEED TO
RUN TWO RAIL LINES SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY TO THE BAY AREA. THANK
THAT EVERYBODY CAN HAVE ABILITY
MY APOLOGIES IF WE CAN HAVE
EVERYONE AND I'VE FAILED TO
MENTION THIS AND I'LL LET YOU
FINISH THE FIVE EVERYONE IF
THEY CAN PROVIDE AND IN
OPPOSITION THEIR NAME-
AFFILIATION AND POSITION FROM
OPPOSITION. CORRECT ANSWER.
WHAT WILL GO TO THE NEXT LINE A
MISALIGNMENT FORTY SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS MARCUS CRAWLEY.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
IN THIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSES S. B. FIVE FORTY EIGHT
BECAUSE THIS DECEPTIVE THANK
YOU PURPOSE OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR WE'RE JUST TAKING NAME.
OUR ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE
AFFILIATED WITH AND YOUR
POSITION SO THANK YOU SIR NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
EVERYONE WHO HAD SPOKEN IN
OPPOSITION. AND SO NOW- WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO FACT TO SENATOR
EGGMAN IF SHE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE OR I'M SORRY POLICIES IF
THERE WERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS FIRST AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO CLOSING. I SEE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
SENATOR EGGMAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE PLEASE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR I THINK THE
BILL AGAIN IS A IS VERY SIMPLE
LAYS OUT OF WHAT WE'VE DONE
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO TO KEEP
THE TRAINS RUNNING ON TIME AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN.
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AND A REMINDER
MEMBERS TO PLEASE SPEAK INTO
MICROPHONES OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. AND CAN WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THAT PLEASE. MISS OKAY
SENATOR DODD THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD MOTIONS WITH. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS GONZALEZ FIVE
DOLLARS AYE BATES AYE BATES AYE
ALLEN. WHAT A LETTER HI LETTER
HI BAKER. PORTES FIVE CORTESE I
DOLLY BY DOLLY AYE DODD ALL
RIGHT THE HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
MAN I MEN HI NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN I WILL HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI SKINNER I NUMBER I
NUMBER I LIKE HOW. WILK HI WILK.
TWELVE ZERO OKAY TWELVE THE
WILL PUT THE BALL BILL ON THINK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT OUR NEXT
BILL WE HAVE UP IS BY SENATOR
WESSEL I BELIEVE HE IS COMING
ON AND- WELCOME SENATOR WEST SO
YOU ARE HERE TO PRESENT SB.
FIVE EIGHTY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL. HI VERY PROUD
PRESENT FIVE EIGHTY A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO. MITIGATE THE STATE'S
ON RECYCLED PLASTIC SURPLUS. BY
ASKING THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION TO CONDUCT THE
STUDY ASSESSING THE VISIBLE
FEASIBILITY. COST EFFECTIVENESS
AND LIFE CYCLE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS INCLUDING RECYCLED
PLASTICS THE NATIONAL
PRODUCTION FOR ROAD
CONSTRUCTION AND REPAIR
PROJECTS. IN TWENTY ELEVEN WE
AT THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISH A
STATE WIDE GOAL OF 75% RESPONSE
RECYCLING BY TWENTY TWENTY. BUT
NOW WE ARE VERY VERY FAR FROM
THAT GOAL. ACCORDING TO CAL
RECYCLE DISPOSAL TONNAGES HAVE
BEEN INCREASING YEAR AFTER YEAR
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA'S
DISPOSED. OF FORTY SIX POINT
THREE MILLION TONS. THE SIX
YEARLY INCREASE IN A ROW L. E.
P. A. REPORTED THAT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ONLY THREE MILLION
TONS OR EIGHT POINT SEVEN
PERCENT. OF THE OVERALL AMOUNT
OF PLASTICS WERE RECYCLED.
MEANWHILE THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
PLASTICS COMBUSTED IN MUNICIPAL
SOLID WASTE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WAS FIVE POINT SIX MILLION TONS.
ALMOST THE SAME AMOUNT. THIS
WAS A SIXTEEN POINT THREE
INCREASE ALL MSW COMBUSTED.
WITH ENERGY RECOVERY THAT YEAR
FURTHERMORE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
IT WAS ALSO REPORTED THAT
LANDFILLS RECEIVED TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION TONS OF PLASTIC THIS
WAS EIGHTEEN POINT 5% OF ALL
MSW LANDFILL. IN ORDER TO MEET
THE GOALS WE SET FOR OURSELVES
WE MUST FIND INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS ONE OF OUR
STATE'S MOST PRESSING
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES RESEARCH
FROM AROUND THE WORLD HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPING NEW USES FOR
RECYCLED PLASTICS. AND IN THE
LAST DECADE WE HAVE SEEN THE
BENEFIT OF USING RECYCLED
PLASTIC AS AN ASPHALT ADDITIVE.
IN TWENTY TWELVE VANCOUVER
CANADA REPORTED THAT THEY WOULD
BE RE INCORPORATING THE USE OF
BLUE BLOCKS BLUE BOX PLASTIC
WASTE AS AN ASPHALT WAX
ADDITIVE FOR ROAD REPAIR IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN ROTTERDAM
NETHERLANDS ANNOUNCED THEIR
PLAN TO FACTORY PRODUCED
RECYCLE PLASTICS SEGMENTS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ROAD
CONSTRUCTION. MORE RECENTLY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY PARTNERED
WITH THE PLASTIC ROAD DEVELOPER
TO ENGINEER THE FIRST KNOWN
ROAD IN THE UNITED STATES.
USING RECYCLED PLASTIC ASPHALT
MIX. AS MOST OF YOU KNOW USING
RECYCLED MATERIALS AS AN
ADDITIVE FOR US FULL PRODUCTION
ISN'T A NEW CONCEPT TO US HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. SINCE ITS
INTRODUCTION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE CALIFORNIA HAS
SUCCESSFULLY DEVELOPED. A
COMPREHENSIVE TIRE RECYCLING
AND MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. AND
USES THOSE RECYCLED TIRES TO
CREATE RUBBERIZED ASPHALT
CONCRETE. AS A LEADER IN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES
CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO TRANSFORM THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY ONCE
AGAIN BY INTRODUCING NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD
REVOLUTIONIZE THE WAY WE LOOK
AT RECYCLED PLASTIC THIS BILL.
WE ARE SEEING IN THIS BILL WE
ARE SEEKING TO EXPAND ON
CURRENT STATES EFFORTS IN ORDER
TO REDUCE THE COST OF ROAD
CONSTRUCTION. AN INCREASE THE
STRENGTH AND DURABILITY OF OUR
ROADS. ALL THE WHILE FINDING
ALTERNATIVE USES FOR WASTE
PLASTIC OTHERWISE DESTINED FOR
LANDFILL. THE IDEA OF THIS BILL
SEARCHES ORIGINATED BY A GROUP
OF ENGAGE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
IN MY DISTRICT VERY PROUD OF
THEM AND I THINK THEY HAVE A
WONDERFUL IDEA AND I THOUGHT
THAT I CHAMPION THIS CAUSE IN
ORDER TO HELP THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE. RECYCLE PLASTIC IMPROVE
THE DURABILITY OF OUR ROADS AND
SAVE TAXPAYERS MONEY AT THE
SAME TIME WE'VE HEARD THE
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION
WILL BE WORKING WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THAT SB FIVE EIGHTY P.
ISN'T PERCEIVED AS A LONG TERM
SOLUTION BUT RATHER A NECESSARY
STEP TO REACHING STATES
RECYCLING GOALS. AND I HAVE
SOME WITNESSES. ARE OUR FIRST
WITNESSES PRICE SCARED HE'S THE
PRESIDENT OF THE BENITO HIGH
PROGRESSIVE CLUB. FOLLOWED BY
REBEKAH SPARKS HE'S A CHIEF
OPERATIONS OFFICER. FOR
MACGRUBER. THANK YOU SENATOR
WEST SO- MODERATOR WILL START
WITH MISTER GARRETT PLEASE.
HELLO THIS IS BRYCE I AM VERY
SCARED I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE PROGRESSIVE CLUB. AND I
WOULD LIKE- COLLECTED THANK YOU
ALL FOR HEARING SB FIVE EIGHTY
TODAY I THINK SENATOR HUESO FOR
HIS CONTINUED TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE- I'M THE FOUNDING
PRESIDENT OF THE BILL NEEDED
EXTRA HIGH SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRESSIVE CLUB AND I AM HERE
TO EXPRESS OUR ORGANIZATION
STRONG SUPPORT AND SPONSORSHIP
FOR SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY.
LAST YEAR THE BENITO VISTA
PROGRESSIVE CLUB ALONG WITH
THAT BUT HE DID THIS TO HIGH
SCHOOL GREEN TEAM GOT A CHANCE
TO MEET WITH SENATOR HUESO TO
EXPRESS OUR VISION TO FURTHER
PUSH CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
RESILIENCY GOALS. AS WE MET
WITH THE SENATOR- WE WERE
TASKED WITH ANSWERING ONE OF
THE MOST CHALLENGING QUESTIONS
OUR GENERATION FACES TODAY. HOW
CAN WE MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CLEAN UP OUR
OCEANS ALL WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
IMPROVING CONDITIONS FOR ALL
PEOPLE. OUR ANSWER IS TO
INNOVATE CALIFORNIA'S ROAD
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY USING
RECYCLED PLASTICS. WE BEGAN OUR
RESEARCH WE FOUND THAT
RESEARCHERS BASED OUT OF THE U.
K. I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
TECHNOLOGY THAT USES RECYCLED
PLASTIC AS AN ADDITIVE FOR
ASPHALT PRODUCTION IN ROADS.
AND AFTER SEEING IN THIS
RESEARCH WE THOUGHT WHY IS IN
CALIFORNIA. NOT DOING THIS
ALREADY. CALIFORNIA BEING FIFTH
LARGEST TO IN THE WORLD HAS THE
DUTY TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE AND TO
INSPIRE OTHERS TO MAKE POSITIVE
CHANGE. SB FIVE EIGHTY IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO SPARK THAT
CHANGE BY TURNING OUR PLASTIC
WASTE INTO A RESOURCE. WITH THE
HELP OF SENATOR HUESO IS OFFICE
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TURN THIS
SIMPLE IDEA INTO A POLICY THAT
WILL IMPACT MIND AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS. AND I INVITE YOU
TO ASK YOURSELF THIS IF A GROUP
OF HIGH SCHOOL AND THE KIDS ARE
ABLE TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING
AS TRANSFORMATIVE AS THIS. AND
WHAT COULD PROFESSIONALS IN THE
FIELD YOURSELVES AND THE
ENTIRETY OF OUR STATE
ACCOMPLISH. I AM BUT YOU TO
FIND THE ANSWER ALONG SIDE ME
BY PASSING SENATE BILL FIVE
EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
PRICE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS-
NEXT MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO MR
BECCA SPARKS. NUMBER TWO YOU
CAN EXPECT. AUSTIN POLICE TO
RESORT. MISFORTUNE LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH BEEN ABLE TO TURN THIS WHY
DO. MISS PARKER YOU IN THE.
PLEASE START ORGANISED PARKS
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CAN EVERYBODY HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN'T. YES THANK YOU CHAIRWOMAN
GONZALEZ AND DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE EIGHTY. MY NAME IS
REBECCA PARK AND I AM THE CHIEF
OPERATIONS OFFICER AT A CREEPER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE PLASTIC
WHAT COMPANY. I THINK THAT THE
PEOPLE IN OUR ECONOMY AND MY
YES IT IS MANY DETRIMENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS THE SAME
ATTRIBUTES MAKE IT A GREAT
PERFORMANCE ENHANCER IN ATHOL.
OUR CHECKING OF DEMONSTRATED
THAT PLASTIC ASPHALT REDUCES
THE FORMATION AND WRITING
FAILURES AS WELL AS INCREASES
FRACTURE TOUGHNESS IN SHORT
PLASTIC ASPHALT WILL LAST
LONGER THAN CONVENTIONAL
ASPHALT. THE PLASTIC WE USE HAS
BEEN SELECTED AFTER YEARS OF
RESEARCH AND DEVELPMENT. IT IS
A POLYMER MODIFIER THE ONES
THAT IS INCORPORATED INTO
CONVENTIONAL ASPHALT. IT IS A
THREE MONTH EXTENSION OF THE
BATMAN ALREADY PRESENT IN THE
MIX. I THINK APPLE OUTPERFORMED
CONVENTIONAL ASPHALT NOT ONLY
IN THE LAB BUT IN THE FIELD.
INDEPENDENT TESTING CONFIRMING
IT DOES NOT HAVE NEGATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT. DOES NOT
CHANGE THE RECYCLABILITY OF
ASPHALT WHEN IT IS AT THE END
OF THE SERVICE LIFE. HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY ADDED TO
CONVENTIONAL ASPHALT CONTENT
RETAINING UP 240% RAP. AND HAD
HEROES CHANGES TO THE
INSTALLATION PROCESS. ANY
PAVING COMPANY CAN INSTALL
CLASSIC ASPHALT IN EXACTLY THE
SAME MANNER THEY WOULD INSTALL
CONVENTIONAL ASPHALT. I WOULD
LAST WE TAKE LIKE TO TAKE THE
TOP. TO AND- I FIVE EIGHTY IT'S
BEEN ASK THAT WE STUDY. IN
ASPHALT IT IS NOT ASKING TO
CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT THE
PATIENTS AT THE PRESENT TIME.
WE HAD A GREBER BELIEVE IN
SCIENCE AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA- THAT
TO ITS CONSTITUENTS TO
INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY WHAT THINK
REMEMBER THAT ARE ALREADY
SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN TO BE
TRUE. I THINK APPLE IS GOOD FOR
OUR ENVIRONMENT YOU CAN DO TO
PROVIDE REFERENCE. ON YOUR LAST
WROTE. I'M SORRY WHAT WAS THAT
I'M SORRY IF YOU CAN JUST WRAP
UP YOUR TESTIMONY HERE AT TWO
MINUTES AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOUR AND HAS YOUR WRITING
CAN'T. ONE BIT LAST- A PROVIDE
FOR STRONGER LONGER LASTING
ROADS. IT'D COST COMPARED. TO
CONVENTIONAL ASPHALT. THANK YOU
THIRDS FINITE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND EVERY TIME A BIT. OFF THAT.
4% OF THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
PLASTIC WASTE FOOTPRINT. I ASK
YOU TO PLEASE MOVE FORWARD WITH
SB FIVE EIGHTY. AND HELP
CALIFORNIA BE A LEADER IN
FIGHTING THE WAY CLASSIC
EPIDEMIC. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GONZALEZ THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'VE GOT THE TWO
WITNESSES THAT HAVE SPOKEN IN
SUPPORT SO WE'RE GOING TO. GO
TO ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE EIGHTY IN THE CHAMBER
SEE NONE. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHTY AND
ROOM ONE TWELVE C. NONE- NO
MODERATOR TO GO BACK TO YOU TO
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE EIGHTY ON THE LINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU WE LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL SB FIVE
EIGHTY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. PHOTO FIRST COME MY
NUMBER FORTY SIX FOUR SIX IN
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN BIRTH POSTED OFF ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN FACTOR WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO NEXT TO
LINE TWENTY NINE TO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TO LEAD
MELANAU SKI BALL ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT AND SB FIVE EIGHTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
WITH THAT COMES FROM LINE.
SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. HELLO ACTOR
WILL BE AT THE PLASTICS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
THEY'RE NOT FOR THE LINE TO IN
Q. OKAY THANK YOU SINCE WE'VE
CONCLUDED WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS TO HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION- AND THERE IT LOOKS
LIKE THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
FOR WITNESSES- KEEP WITNESSES
AT THIS TIME- SO AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ROOM. TO
THE CHAMBERS FIRST TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE ADAC NINE
ROOM ONE TWELVE. WE SEE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE MODERATOR GOING BACK
TO YOU TO SEE IF YOU CAN PROMPT
ANY INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE EIGHTY PLEASE. THANK YOU.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF. AB
FIVE AIDING THE PRESS ONE OF
THEM ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
OPPOSITION OF FIVE EIGHTY ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YOU
HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. BE JUST A
MOMENT FOR THEY HAVE THEIR LINE
NUMBER.
DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT BECAUSE WE DO KNOW THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL COME FROM.
NINE EIGHTY. MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NORRLAND
BREAK REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASPHALT PAVEMENT
ASSOCIATION A TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OUR CONSTRUCTION
BUILDERS WE MUST ARM
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE CURRENT STATE OF THE
KNOWLEDGE ON RIDLEY AND BELIEVE
CALTRANS APPROPRIATE AGENCY FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF EXECUTION
ONE THIRTY IN THE BILL
COMPLETED WE'VE HEARD THE BELL
UNLESS IT IS AMENDED TO DELETE
A REFERENCE TO PAYMENT THE
CATION AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH AUTHORS OFTEN. ON
A RESOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT. NO OTHER
LINES INTO THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE CONCLUDED
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS I
SEE SENATOR NEWMAN. HERBICIDE
CENTER WHICH I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON THIS BILL AND I
WANT TO COMPLIMENT PRICE- AND
THE ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
BENITO VISTA HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRESSIVE CLUB AND THE GREEN
CLUB. GREEN TEAM. THIS IS
ACTUALLY REALLY INSPIRING AND
SO KUDOS TO YOU FOR ENGAGING
THESE VERY SMART YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND IT WOULD SEEM WE ARE THE
BEGINNINGS OF A REALLY
INTERESTING APPROACH TO A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM. WRAPS IT THANK
YOU- THAT THIS IS YOU'VE MADE
MY DAY THAT AND I RESPECTFULLY
SB DATA CO AUTHORED SOME POINT
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE. GREAT THANK
YOU SAN NEWMAN SENT MEN. CENTER
WHAT- ALLEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
HUESO FOR INTERVIEWS IN THIS
BILL IT'S A VERY INNOVATIVE
IDEA- I JUST HAD A COUPLE
CONCERNS I WANTED TO ASK YOU
ABOUT- YOU KNOW I'M NOT A
SCIENTIST OBVIOUSLY BUT I AS A-
WE START TO LEARN ABOUT THE
POTENTIALLY. DETRIMENTAL
IMPACTS OF MICROPLASTICS ON OUR
HEALTH- YEAH ACT MAYBE I'M
MISSING SOMETHING BUT DID DID
THIS PARTICULAR BILL CALL FOR
ANY PUBLIC HEALTH EVALUATION OR
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AS PART
OF THE SCOPE OF THE STUDY OF
CALTRANS. OKAY WELL THE PURPOSE
OF THE STUDY IS TO- GET A HOLD
OF ALL THAT INFORMATION IN A
CONVERSATION WITH SENATOR ALAN-
WE TALKED ABOUT INCORPORATING
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL IN
THE STUDY TO MAKE SURE. THAT
THAT THAT IS LOOKED AT AS WELL
AND I. I SUPPORT THAT VERY VERY
MUCH I THINK THAT'S- A VERY
IMPORTANT ASPECT. OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY- BEAR IN MIND THAT-
OF COURSE THIS AND THIS
ELEMENT. COMPLETELY
INCORPORATES INTO THE ASPHALT
SO. IF YOU IF YOU CONSIDER THE
POT PETROLEUM IS AN INGREDIENT
LIST BASICALLY STRENGTHENS
PROBLEMS SO. IT REALLY IT
DISSOLVES INTO THE ASPHALT
THAT'S WHY I FEEL IT'S A VERY
SAFE. ADDITIVE TO- TO **** THAT
WOULD NOT POSE A HAZARD SO I
FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE. ABOUT
INCORPORATING THAT INTO THAT I
MEAN FIRST OF ALL WE DON'T WANT
TO ADD. TO THE DETRIMENT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT WITH THIS IS A
WHOLE EFFORT TO. CLEAN THE
ENVIRONMENT IMPROVE THE
ENVIRONMENT KEEP PLASTICS OUT
OF THE ENVIRONMENT IF YOU
CONSIDER HOW MUCH WE'RE
FAILING. IN OUR IN OUR CURRENT
EFFORTS TO KEEP PLASTICS OF THE
ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. AND IF
THIS ELEMENT. CAN HELP US THAT.
AND WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO
REPLACE ONE CONTAMINANT WITH
ANOTHER WITH THIS BILL. WE'RE
LOOKING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM AND
I REALLY AM LOOKING FOR IS A
TRULY. INFORMATIVE SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES SO I WILL BE WORKING
WITH SENATOR ALAN CHIN IN
CORPORATE ATTACHED AS PROOF
BILL MOVES FORWARD. TO MAKE
SURE WE CAPTURE THAT IN THE
STUDY AS WELL. THANK YOU THAT
ACTUALLY SWITCHES OVER MY
CONCERNS AND IF IT IS A SAFE
YOU SAID I YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THIS WOULD BE. A GOOD WAY TO
USE SOME OF THE- CLASSICS THAT
WERE I CURRENTLY WE'RE NOT
RECYCLING AND ALSO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT ASPECT OF THIS-
BUT I DO THINK JUST EMPHASIZE
IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO
ACTUALLY EXPLICITLY INCLUDE
THAT- ASPECT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
BEYOND BECAUSE HAVING EXPERTS.
GO AN INDETERMINATE WHETHER
THERE'S A RISK OF RUNOFF FROM
THE ASPHALT OR NOT- WHETHER IT
POSES ANY THREATS TO. OUR
HEALTH I THINK THAT MAKES ME
MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE WILLING TO
MANDATE TO INCORPORATE THOSE
FACTORS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- THANK YOU SENATOR. MEN
SENATOR ALAN. ONE TO TAKE MY
CAR SENATOR AND I'M TO THANK
YOU. MISS CENTER WESO FOR YOUR
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US ON THIS I YEAH AYE. I
THINK. I HEARD YOUR- THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL AND DOES
CERTAIN. AND YOU KNOW I WANT TO
GIVE YOU FOR TRYING TO COME UP
WITH A OF. A CREATIVE SOLUTION
FOR- FOR FREE AND USES OF.
PLASTICS AND- I THINK THAT THE
TWO THIRDS TO KIKKAN. THAT ARE
OUT THERE- YOU KNOW ONE OF THEM
IS. TIED THAT MICROPLASTICS ARE
REAL PROBLEM AND WE CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING THAT
WILL. CONTRIBUTE TO A FOR LIVE
AT EVER INCREASING AMOUNT OF
MICROPLASTICS OUT IN THE- IN
THE IN A WATER STREAM. AND SO
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
THE OCEANPROTECTION COUNCIL
WHICH WOULD WOULD LOOK AT. AND
I ALSO THINK THEY WOULD THEY
WOULD YOU KNOW THE OTHER ISSUE
I JUST WANNA I WANNA REYES. IS
MAKING SURE THAT THIS REALLY
DOES MEET YOUR GOALS OF TRYING
TO.ENCOURAGE RECYCLING. AND
AND- YEAH GOOD DOWNSTREAM USES-
THE WE DON'T WANT TO DO
SOMETHING THAT WILL ACT RESUME
AND I PRESUME I WOULD. YEAH I
PRESUME YOU WOULD AGREE TO
THIS- CENTER WESO. I THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO DO SOMETHING THAT
WILL ACTUALLY. MAKE IT LESS
LIKELY FOR- FOR HOW HE WAS.
PLASTICS TO BE TURNED INTO.
SOMETHING AND THAT THERE WOULD
BE A HIGHER AND BETTER USE.
THAN A ROAD SO. YOU KNOW I'D
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU MOVING
FORWARD I THINK I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO INCLUDE THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL IN
THIS ANALYSIS I THINK IT'S A
CRITICAL. ADDITIONAL
PERSPECTIVE- ALONG WITH
CALTRANS. AND TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AT PLAY
HERE I ALSO RECOGNIZE IT'S A
STUDY IN THIS IS JUST AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO. TO LOOK
AT THIS ISSUE AND TRY TO FIGURE
OUT IF THERE'S A GOOD PATH
MOVING FORWARD THAT WILL. BOTH
HELP US WITH REGARDS TO ROADS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ALSO. WITH
REGARDS TO. REDUCING PLASTICS
POLLUTION IN WITH THAT- SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
WITH THAT AND IN THAT SPIRIT IN
WITHOUT AGREEMENT I'M I'M SO
HAPPY TO. SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. THANK. YOU SENATOR ALAN
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND ONE OF CREATE
THE CAR. OF MY ARE. TWO
PREVIOUS COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE.
IN BUT ALSO APPRECIATE SENATOR
HUESO IS- RAISING OF THIS ISSUE
THAT. WE DO HAVE. A WAY TOO
MANY PLASTICS AND- WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO RECYCLE THEM. FOR MANY
MANY REASONS I WON'T GET INTO
NOW. SO WE DO NEED TO. ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND OF COURSE THE
REDUCTION IN THE USE OF
PLASTICS WOULD BE THE FIRST AND
FOREMOST- HOWEVER THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY OTHER BILLS THAT WE
HAVE TO CONSIDER BUT WHAT I
WANT TO RAISE IS SIMILAR TO MY
COLLEAGUES THE CONCERN AROUND
MICROPLASTICS. AND WHILE I DO
NOT OPPOSE THE USE OF PLASTICS
AND ROADS AND WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL THE STUDY THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL RIGHT NOW HAS CALTRANS
LOOKING AT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS OF THE USE AND WHAT MY
CONCERN IS BY THAT DEFINITION
ALONE THEY MAY NOT INCLUDE IN
THEIR STUDY. WHAT POSSIBLE-
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS MAY BE THE
REASON I RAISE IT IS. WE KNOW
NOW THAT WILL JUST WITHOUT EVEN
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT NGUYEN TIRES
RUN ON ROADS THE FRICTION
BETWEEN THE TIRE AND THE ROADS
BREAKS UP THE ROAD. BUT WHAT WE
KNOW NOW IS THAT THEY LOOK GOOD
PERCENT OF PARTICULATE MATTER.
IN CALIFORNIA IS IN OUR AREA
THAT AFFECTS OUR WHICH IS PART
OF THE- COMPONENT OF SMOG. SO
IN PARTICULAR MATTER IS ONE OF
THE DANGEROUS HEALTHWISE
COMPONENTS OF SMART THAT A GOOD
PORTION OF THAT PARTICULAR
MATTER COMES FROM JUST TIRES
RUNNING ON ROADWAYS BREAKING UP
BOTH THE TIRES IN THE ROADWAY.
OUR MICROPLASTICS ALREADY ARE
FEATURED IN ALL OF THIS THE
THERE WERE GRAD STUDENTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA THE
PUBLISHED A STUDY JUST LAST
AUGUST AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY.
WHERE THEY SAMPLED A LARGE
ARRAY AND VERY PEOPLE IT PASSED
AWAY OF- HUMAN ORGANS. AND THEY
FOUND THEY DETECTED
MICROPLASTICS IN EVERY ORGAN
FOR EVERY. HUMAN THAT DAY.
START THERE WAS 1100% SO
MICROPLASTICS NOW ARE QUITE
UBIQUITOUS WE DO NOT UNDERSTAND
THE LONG TERM HEALTH IMPACTS OF
THEM AND IF THE USE OF THEM
USED PLASTICS IN ROADWAYS WORD
BECAUSE MORE MICROPLASTICS TO
BECOME AIRBORNE THAT COULD BE A
SERIOUS ISSUE. SO WHAT I WOULD
APPRECIATE IS HAPPENING. WITHIN
THE STUDY THAT THEY ALSO LOOK
AT WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT POSSIBLE
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS THERE MIGHT
BE. BECAUSE IT CERTAINLY YOU
CAN LOOK AT WHETHER THEY'RE
VIABLE FOR. THE YOU KNOW
STRUCTURE AND STRENGTH OF
ROADWAY BUT I THINK IT ALSO
SHOULD LOOK AT THAT ASPECT. AND
HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR WITH AGREE
WITH- ADDING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
SENATOR- WHAT'S THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT IN YOUR
CLOTHES. YES FOR NOW OKAY
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I ALSO WANT TO
COMMIT THE AUTHOR NOT ONLY FOR.
BEING INNOVATIVE BUT TAKING THE
STUDENTS ADVICE I WAS ALSO
STRUCK BY THE FACT THAT TINA IS
A FORMER EDUCATOR I'M ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE WHEN WE GET OUR YOUTH
INVOLVED SELF. SILVA THANK YOU
FOR TO THE STUDENTS WHO REALLY
TAKE THIS INITIATIVE AND- INTO
THE GREAT CENTER FROM SAN DIEGO
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I DO
HAVE. SOME CONCERNS JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE BUT I THINK THAT
THROUGH THE DISCUSSION IT
SATISFIED SOME OF THE CONCERNS-
YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE THE FACT
THAT WE DO HAVE THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL INVOLVED
ALONG WITH CALTRANS. I JUST
THINK THIS IS A GOOD WAY TO
STUDY SOMETHING AND SEE IF THIS
HAS ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS LONG
TERM. I THINK THAT THROUGH THE
STATE HE WILL FIND OUT IF IT'S
FEASIBLE OR NOT AND THEN MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND ALSO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO SENATOR
BAKER. THANK YOU MANAGER.
ASSEMBLY LOVES INNOVATIVE IDEAS
I COMMEND STUDENTS AND-
APPRECIATE THE- THE TEND TO
STUDY AND DO YOU PLAN TO
SUPPORT THIS I JUST DID ONE
ECHO SOME OF THE CONCERNS MY
COLLEAGUES AROUND MICROPLASTICS
IS SOMETHING I'VE RECENTLY
BECOME AWARE OF AND FOCUSED ON
AS WELL AS THE ISSUE OF YOU
KNOW THE EFFECTS THE FACTS ON
PLASTIC RECYCLING GENERALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE HIGHLY
RECYCLABLE PLASTICS YOU END UP.
IN THERE- IN IN THEIR BEST USE-
BUT WITH THE YOU KNOW HEALTH
CONCERNS NOTED HERE TODAY I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER I SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AND SENATOR WESSEL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL- WE ALL SHARED. SIMILAR
CONCERNS I KNOW YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK- WITH- THAT THE
SENATORS WHO RAISES CONCERNS
AND OF COURSE WITH THE
APPROPRIATE ORGANIZATION SO GO
RIGHT AHEAD AND CLOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
ACTIVE PARTICIPATION IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS BILL.
INCLUDING STAFF AT- YOU KNOW AS
I'M SURROUNDED HERE BY PLASTIC.
AND MANY OF YOU ARE SURROUNDED
BY PLASTIC. IN THIS MEETING
IT'S REALLY HARD TO. ENGAGE ANY
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY WITHOUT A
COMING- INTO FIRSTHAND. A
CONTACT WITH PLASTIC IN ALMOST
EVERY PART OF OUR LIVES PLASTIC
IS REALLY BECOME. JUST A LOW
COST. INGREDIENT IN IN IN THE-
BILL FORMING. FURNITURE AND-
WINDOWS THE CONSTRUCTION-
MATERIALS BOTTLES. PLASTIC
WARE. I MEAN IT'S JUST SO MUCH
PART OF OUR- LIVES EVERY DAY
THAT IT JUST IS GETTING IS SEEN
SINCE SEEING THE GROUP GROW
MORE AS OPPOSED REDUCE. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO PRACTICALLY DO YOU DEAL WITH
PRACTICALLY. CANCEL THIS BILL I
THINK IS A IS A VERY PRACTICAL
APPROACH TO REMOVE THIS
MATERIAL FROM THE ENVIRONMENT
FROM OUR LANDFILLS. A GROUP OF
YOU KNOW WHAT A CONTINUING
PROBLEM CALIFORNIA'S BECAUSE
THE GROWING NEED FOR LANDFILLS
WE NEED TO REDUCE THE NEED FOR
CATALAN FEELS WE NEED TO
RECYCLE MORE BUT WE NEED A
PLACE TO PUT PLASTIC IS
RECYCLED MATERIAL. AND AS THE
WORLD DEVELOPMENTS USED
TECHNOLOGIES IN DIFFERENT AREAS
CALIFORNIA STILL STRUGGLING
WITH MORE WORK WHERE TO PUT OUR
CLASSROOM MATERIALS. BUT I. I
BELIEVE THAT- IN IN CONDUCTING
A TUDY IT AND NEEDS TO BE
TRULY SCIENTIFIC IS IT NEEDS TO
BE TRULY INFORMATIVE. AND I
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO MAKE SURE
THE STUDY IS. INFORMATIVE IT
IS- HELPFUL IN DETERMINING
WHETHER THE USE OF THIS PLASTIC
MATERIAL ON OUR ROADWAYS IS
GOING TO BE. THE BEST WAY TO
HANDLE WHAT IS CRAP CURRENTLY
OF A GROWING- SURPLUS OF SOURCE
OF MATERIAL THAT'S CAUSING LOTS
AND LOTS OF PROBLEMS WORLDWIDE
SO CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO LIKE
TAKE TAKE A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
FINDING NEW WAYS TO PUT PLASTIC
MATERIALS IN ALL ASPECTS OF OUR
LIVES THIS BILL HAS LANGUAGE OF
SAYS AS AS WE BEGIN THE
RECYCLED MATERIAL THAT WE DON'T
REALLY GET INTO THIS- YOU KNOW
NECESSARILY CREATING A DEMAND
THAT WILL. REALLY REQUIRE THE
PRODUCTION OF PLASTIC MATERIAL
WE DON'T WANT TO GET TO THAT
LEVEL EITHER WERE WERE
PRODUCING PLASTIC MATERIAL
INTENTIONALLY. TO FEEL. THE
ROAD PRODUCTION AND NOT ON THE
CONTRARY IT IS REALLY BEING
USED AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
DUMPING THIS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND- TO
PROLIFERATE FOR PROLIFERATING
WASTE AN APARTMENT SIZE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU SENATOR WEST
OF DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB
FIVE EIGHTY. SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN IS ENTERTAIN
THAT THE MOTION- MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE DALLAS
FIVE. DOLLARS AYE BATES HI
BATES HI ELLEN. HI ELLEN HI
WHAT YOU LETTER HI WHICH LED A
HIGH. BYE BAKER HI KATIE.
CURTIS HIGH DOLLAR FIVE DOLLY
DOT HI DODD AYE MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ MAN BY MAN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI NUMBER
FIVE NUMBER I LIKE ASKING. WILK
HI WELCOME HIGH. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN EYES
ZERO KNOWS WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SENATOR WESSEL.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU ARE
RIGHT WE'RE GOING ON TO THE
TRANSPORTATION BILL OF THE DAY.
WHICH IS- SB TWO ONE TWO SEVEN.
BY SENATOR JONES WELCOME
SENATOR JONES. WE'VE HEARD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I DON'T
KNOW IF I'VE EVER HAD THE BILL
OF THE DAY BEFORE SO I
APPRECIATE THAT- THAT CREATES
QUITE A- STANDARD TO REACH.
THANK YOU A MANAGER FIRST OF
ALL I THINK YOU. ARE YOUR STAFF
AND LOOK I THINK EVERY MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT WE'VE
HAD VERY POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH- I'M VERY EXCITED TO
PRESENT THIS BILL AGAIN. SOME
OF YOU MAY REMEMBER IT FROM
LAST YEAR BUT SENATE BILL TWO
TWENTY SEVEN CREATES A VERY
NARROW. TAILORED REGISTRATION
PROGRAM FOR COMPETITION OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLES. MOSTLY
MOTORCYCLES. THIS BILL IS A RE
INTRODUCTION OF MY BILL FROM
LAST YEAR S. B. TEN TWENTY FOUR
WHICH ACTUALLY PASSEDTHE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION. AND OFF
THE SENATE FLOOR LAST YEAR ON
CONSENT. BILL PASSED OFF THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AT MIDNIGHT ON
THE LAST EVENING. AND
UNFORTUNATELY DID NOT HAVE TIME
TO GET BACK TO THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE FOR FINAL VOTE. OR
WE WOULD'VE BEEN DONE WITH
THIS- LAST YEAR. I'M RUNNING
THIS ILL BECAUSE OF ITS GREAT
IMPORTANCE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND TO THE ENTIRE STATE
CURRENTLY COMPETITION OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLES ARE REGISTERED
TO CARDS REGISTER PROGRAM. TWO
YEARS AGO KARBI CITED THE END
IS REGISTER PROGRAM AS OF THIS
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
WITHOUT A NEW PROGRAM- WHICH BE
COMPETITIONS AND THE PRACTICE
WRITING WILL BE PUT TO AN END
ON CALIFORNIA LANDS.
ADDITIONALLY LOCAL ECONOMIES
THAT RELY ON THE SUPPORT WOULD
BE DECIMATED. BY A MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR REVENUE LOSS. IN
ORDER TO SAVE A BELOVED SPORT
WITH A LONG HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL CREATES
REPLACEMENT REGISTRATION
PROGRAM. UNDER THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT. MY OFFICE HAS BEEN
OVER A YEAR WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING H. B.
COMPETITION ARCHITECT OR HIS
ASIAN. OHB MANUFACTURERS AND
SEVERAL STATE AGENCIES WHICH
ALL OF YOU CAN- TESTIFY TO. HOW
MUCH WORK THAT IS BUT- WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO WORK WITH ALL OF
THE AGENCIES AND GET A MOVING
IN A IN A POSITIVE DIRECTION ON
THIS. AND ALTHOUGH- WE'VE I AM
AWARE THAT THERE IS SOME-
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONSWITH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND MITIGATE
THEIR CONCERNS TO THE BEST
ABILITY THAT WE CAN- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING MEEINGS
WITH THOSE THE FACT THAT THIS
BILL IS AND SO NARROWLY
TAILORED. IT WILL ACTUALLY
ELIMINATE AN ESTIMATED 93% OF
NEW COMPETITION VEHICLES NINETY
THREE PERCENT. BASICALLY THE
NUMBERS A CARD GIVES US THE
REDUCTION IN REGISTERED
VEHICLES WILL DROP FROM SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED A YEAR. TO ONLY
FIVE HUNDRED A YEAR. AND SO-
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
POSITIVE CHANGE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
MADAM CHAIR WITH THAT I HAVE TO
WITNESSES ON THE LINE READY TO
GIVE EXPERT TESTIMONY. AND I
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE A CALLERS-
CALLING IN AS WELL IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR JONES- AND I THINK
WE HAVE ONE LEAD WITNESS WHO IS
ACTUALLY HERE IN A CHAMBERS AS
WELL I BELIEVE THAT MIGHT BE
JIM LOMBARDO SENIOR. OKAY GREAT
MISTER LOMBARDO PLEASE COME
FORWARD CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
DEALERS ASSOCIATION YOU'LL BE
GIVEN TWO MINUTES- SPEAKING
SUPPORT. OKAY. DO WITH. LET'S
TRY THIS AGAIN FOR MR LOMBARD
L. OKAY YOU SHOULD BE GOOD
MISTER BETTER PLEASE PROCEED.
I
DON'T THINK WE CAN HEAR HIM
STILL. I FIND THAT I COULD
FOLLOW THERE YOU GO. NOW THE
REAR THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIRMAN
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JAMES EMBARKED ON THE
AFT CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
DEALERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING SOME FOUR HUNDRED
MOTORCYCLE DEALERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. VERY SMALL
BUSINESSES WHERE MOM AND POP
OWNED INDIVIDUALLY OWNED
THERE'S A SMALL THAT YOU
PROBABLY DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE IN YOUR DISTRICT THAT
THEY ARE IN YOUR DISTRICT- WE
WERE HIT VERY STRONGLY BY THE
COBIT. OKAY SO MANY OF OUR
DEALERSHIPS FOR CLOSE UP TO SIX
MONTHS WITH NO BUSINESS. THAN
WE WERE LIMITED TO. TO PASS A
TEN CUSTOMERS PER. VISIT AND SO
WE HAVE A SERIOUS IMPACT ON US-
I REMEMBER GOING TO LAS VEGAS.
AND STOPPING WHEN TIME AND
BUFFALO BILLS THERE AND STATE
LINE AND THERE WERE SOME. OF GO
KARTS OUT THERE IN THE PARKING
LOT GOING AROUND I SAID WHAT
ARE THESE FOR. NAY SAID THESE
PEOPLE ARE PRACTICING TO BECOME
FORMULA ONE DRIVERS BAPTISTS
PRACTICING PRACTICING GO UP THE
LADDER. SO THEY CAN COMPETE THE
LONG BEACH GRAND PRIX FURTHER
THE GOODNESS SAKE. OUR WRITERS
HAVE THAT SAME KNEE. THEY JUST
DON'T AREN'T ABLE TO JUST ENTER
EVENTS. TODAY BY MULTIPLE
MOTORCYCLES. THE AVERAGE
MOTORCYCLES FOR OFF ROAD IS
TWELVE TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND YOU
BY BACKUP TIRES EQUIPMENT AND
EVERYTHING ELSE WHEN YOU'RE
TRAVELING SO IF YOU. HAVE A
BREAK DOWN YOU HAVE A SPARE
BIKE YOU CAN REPAIR THESE
VEHICLES. WE ESTIMATE THAT. AT
A LOSS OF TWENTY FIVE FOUR
SEVEN NINE DOLLARS TO THE
MEMBERS. DEALERS IN THE SALES.
SO I WOULD HOPE THAT. FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
HURT SO BAD. THAT YOU COULD
PASS THIS BILL WE CAN WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND I'M IN ROUTE
TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE HOPEFULLY
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR LOMBARDO FOR
BEING HERE- THE NEXT WITNESS
LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT. OF S.
B. TWO TWO SEVEN. IS TERRY
MCHALE COALITION FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
GET- TERRY MCHALE ON THE LINE
PLEASE. THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS
TERRY MAKAYLA THE COALITION OF
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE RIDERSHIP.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS FOR FIFTY
YEARS TRYING TO FIND A BALANCE
BETWEEN RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS. IT NARROWING FOCUS
THE BILL WAS NOT GREAT YOU KNOW
LATERALLY OR IN A BACKING. THE
OPPORTUNITY STAFFERS WORKING
CONSCIENTIOUSLY TO STAKEHOLDERS
THAT INCLUDE REGULATORS WRITERS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS ON CRITICS.
THE BILL THE NOT X. ONLY TO BE
BEYOND WHAT IT IS TODAY THIS
BILL SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES THE
NUMBER OF CARDS NON COMPLIANT-
AGE THE VEHICLE- ALLOWS PARKS.
THE DIVISION OF OHB CARB. AND
BE AND BE. A BETTER PLAN
REGULATE CHARGE FEES AND
MANAGE- HD ESPECIALLY
COMPETITIVE HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATION. THIS BILL
RESPECTFULLY AND RESPONSIBLY
ALLOWANCE POETRY COMPETITION
CONTINUES AND IT'S RESPECTFUL
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
THAT ARE RAISED. IF THIS BILL
MAKES IT OUT OF COMMITTEE OKAY
CERTAINLY HELP WITH THAT IN A
DOUBLE THE FIRST ON THE SENATE
AND WILL LIKELY BE DOUBLE
REFERRED ON THE ASSEMBLY. THE
OFFICER'S OFFICE AND THOSE OF
US WHO SUPPORTED. I PLEDGE TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS. TO CONTINUE TO
FASHION PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THE LEGISLATURE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN BE PROUD.
RESPECTFULLY FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MCHALE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO SEVEN-
NOW WE'RE GOING TO LOOK FOR ANY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL HERE IN CHAMBERS C. NINE-
ANY TESTIMONY IN ONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN SUPPORT. WE SEE NONE.
THE MISTER MODERATOR WILL GO
BACK TO YOU IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY BIT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY FOR S. B.
TWO TWO SEVEN IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU TO SHARE YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN MEANS
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD TO
SUPPORT SB. TWO TWO SEVEN. WE
HAVE ONE LINING QUEUE IN JUST A
MOMENT POINTS. FINE FORTY FOUR
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
HARRISON THE WESTERN STATES
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE AMERICAN
MOTORCYCLIST ASSOCIATION
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
ON BEHALF OF OUR THIRTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA MEMBERS.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
IN ORDER LINE THANK YOU IT IS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILLSWITCH OVER AND
DO THE SAME PROCESS FOR ANY
OPPOSITION- IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME- BUT WILL GO TO THE
CHAMBERS TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION FOR S. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN AND CHAMBERS C. NINE. ANY
OPPOSITION IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WE SEE NONE. MISTER MODERATOR
BACK TO YOU FOR ANY OF PEOPLE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO TWO SEVEN
PLEASE. THANK YOU YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL AGAIN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SP TWO TWO SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A FEW
LINES PENDING ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
OUR FIRST COMMENT IS FROM NINE
SEVEN EIGHT. SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
KAREN COMMITTEE MEMBERS AARON
RODRIGUEZ LOOKING IN OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE WITH YOUR
NAME- AFFILIATION AND YOUR
FORMAL STANCE ON THE BILL.
SEVENTY SIX POINT SEVEN SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS AT THE DANA BROWN
IN THE APPS CARE QUITE
CALIFORNIA AND I WAS TOLD I WAS
WOULD BE ABLE TO THAT AND BE A
LEAD OPPOSITION MAINTENANCE
SERVICE- MACKESY BUT MY COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. WE DID NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION FORMALIZED HERE
SO I WILL LET YOU SAVE JUST ONE
MINUTE OF WHAT YOU CAN IN THAT
ONE MINUTE PLEASE THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
STAYING ABROAD ON BEHALF OF
THEIR CLUB CALIFORNIA AND ARE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND SUPPORTERS. STATEWIDE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. YOUR TWO
SEVEN- WHICH WOULD
UNNECESSARILY ALLOW FOR THE
CONTINUED USE OF HIGHLY
POLLUTING OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLES
ON PUBLIC LANDS COMPROMISING
CALIFORNIA AIR QUALITY. PUBLIC
HEALTH SCHOOLS THE BILL
UNNECESSARILY OVERRIDE. AN
EXISTING CARD POLICY. YOU WILL
LIMIT THE- HIGHLY POLLUTING- I
WOULD BE A GOLD. THEIR OFFICE
TIMES ONE AND A HALF TO TWO ANDA HALF TIME MORE. THE CARD
ENDED- THE RED STICKER PROGRAM
DAY ESTIMATED. THAT THERE BE A
REDUCTION UP SIX TIMES. PER DAY.
AND BY TWENTY FOUR. AND WITH
CLEAR DIRECTION FOR YOUR GREAT
MORE HELP PROTECT REGULATE
EXTREMELY LIKELY THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN A BAN HELP PROTECTIVE
REGULATION THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS LET AND IT NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS FOR THE VERY
POLITE AND- FIFTEEN NON
COMPLIANT L. H. B. AND THAT DID
NOT COMPLAIN. AND THAT THANK
YOU EMISSION COMPLIANT- WHICH
READ THE BAILABLE PER PURCHASE
AND THE STATE SHOULD NOT
DISCOURAGE THE L. OR
DEVELOPMENT OF CLEANER CLEANER
VEHICLES ALLOWING FOR THE
CONTINUED YEARS. OF NON
COMPLIANCE. NO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU AND WE'RE MOVE
ON TO THE COMMON IN UP. OF TWO
TWO SEVEN. MINDER FOUR THREE
FOUR YOUR LINE OPEN. WARNING
GONZALEZ AND MEMBERS BILL
MCGOVERN WITH COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR REGRETFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN THE RED STICKER PROGRAM
BECAME A MUCH BIGGER LOOPHOLE.
AND IT REALLY WAS ENVISIONED TO
BE AND SO CARVE THROUGH A
REGULATORY PROCESS THAT WAS
OPEN TO ALL THE INTERESTED%
PARTIES. BECAUSE THAT WILL CALL
DOOR NARROWED IT WHILE STILL
ALLOWING FOR COMPETITION
MOTORCYCLES TO BE USE SO ARE WE
DON'T SEE ANY REASON TO DISTURB
THAT BALANCE AND THIS BILL
WOULD OPEN UP AN UNNECESSARY
NEW REGULATORY PROCESS- SO WE
ASK YOU TO HOLD THE BILL IN
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MCGOVERN AND AGAIN WOULD
JUST REMIND FOLKS AND- WE
DIDN'T GET ANY FORMAL LEAD
OPPOSITION BUT JUST REMIND
EVERYONE ON THE LINE THAT WE
JUST NEED YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR FARM
OPPOSITION TO SB. TWO TWO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. LINE FORTY TWO FORTY
LINES OPEN. I CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE STEVEN JIMENEZ
WITH AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NO FOR THE
LINES IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU SO
WE'VE EXHAUSTED OUR SUPPORT IN
AN OPPOSITION WITNESSES- WILL
BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. OKAY WE
SEE NONE IS THERE A MOTION. IN
SUPPORT OF SB. TWO TWO SEVEN.
MOTION TO MOVE IT OKAY SENATOR
ARCHULETA MOVES- AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR- JONES FOR COMING TO ME
AND SPEAKINGWITH ME DIRECTLY I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW THE
DISCUSSION OF COURSE I JUST
WANT TO MENTION THAT I WILL BE
OPPOSING THE BILL TODAY JUST.
GIVEN THE- THE STANCE THAT I
HAVE ON YOU KNOW GHG EMISSIONS
AND IN ASKING OUR SMALL FLEET
TRUCK DRIVERS AND YOU KNOW TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND THEN
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOME WORK HERE
THOUGH AND I AND I RESPECT YOUR
YOUR- KEY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DISCUSSING THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE AN ONGOING ISSUE WE NEED
TO ABSOLUTELY DO SOMETHING AS
IT PERTAINS TO RECREATION AND
ENVIRONMENT AND WOULD LOVE TO
BE PART OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS
BUT NONE THE LESS I KNOW EVERY
MEMBER HAS A DIFFERENT STANCE
ON THIS SO. WE'LL WE'LL SEE
WHERE THIS TAKES ABOUT I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR DISCUSSIONS
WITH ME ABOUT THIS BILL. AND
SENATOR SKINNER HAS A QUESTION
AS WELL. THANK YOU CARE I JUST
WANT TO MAKE THE COMMENT THAT.
GIVEN THAT WE STILL HAVE. MANY
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA THAT
EXCEEDS HEALTHY AIR QUALITY AND
ARE THEM HAVE THE MOST POLLUTED
AIR. WHICH OF COURSE WE KNOW
HAS GREAT IMPACTS ON PUBLIC
HEALTH- IT IN BASICALLY THE-
THE MOST POLLUTED AIR OF ANY
STATE IN YOU SWEAT A LITTLE
LOUDER MISS SENATORS CANNOT YET
IS MY NOW MY MARKS ON A GUESS
IT WASN'T ON BEFORE- THE POINT
I WAS MAKING IS THAT I WILL NOT
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
BECAUSE WE PUT REQUIREMENTS ON
EVERY SECTOR OF INDUSTRY.
AROUND AIR QUALITY AND
EMISSIONS FROM THE VEHICLES AND-
WE AND WE DO SO BECAUSE OF THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF THAT
POLLUTION IN CALIFORNIA STILL
REMAINS THE STATE WITH.
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THE WORST
AIR QUALITY AND THUS THE MOST
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS OF
POLLUTION FROM VEHICLE
EMISSIONS. SO TO OVERRIDE OUR
AIR QUALITY REGULATIONS ON JUST
THIS SECTOR WHEN WE KNOW THAT
WE ARE STILL HOLDING OTHER
VEHICLES TO OUR STANDARDS I
DON'T THINK IT'S REALLY A FAIR
PROCESS SO I APPRECIATE THAT
THERE WERE- OBVIOUSLY CAN BE
STILL. CAN DISCUSSION AND
DIALOGUE TO HOW TO ADDRESS THIS
BUT I THINK- IT'S UNFAIR TO
GIVE AN EXCEPTION TO THIS
CATEGORY WHEN WE HAVEN'T DONE
SO WITH SO MANY OTHER VEHICLES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS SENATOR DOT. YEAH I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM- AT BERKELEY. I
CAN TO TAKE A DIFFERENT LOOK AT
THIS. GIVEN THAT THIS GROUP
OVER TIME IN THE LAST SIX YEARS
I'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE.
WE HAVE REALLY CUT BACK ON
THEIR ABILITY. TO MOVE AROUND
TO- IT OUT THROUGHOUT THE-
AREAS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR GOOD REASON.
RIGHT TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT. HE HAD- I THINK AT
THE END OF THE DAY- WITH WHAT
THE AUTHOR IS SAID IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBER- DROPPING SO
PRECIPITOUSLY IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBERS OF USES IT AND THE FACT
THAT THESE ARE MOSTLY IN REAL
RURAL AREAS NOT REALLY YOUR
NEGATIVE AIR QUALITY AREAS. I
JUST I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
AT THE AT LEAST AT THIS POINT
TIME YEAH THAT'S THE MINIMUS
AND I REALLY THINK THAT WE
OUGHT TO MOVE THIS FORWARD AND-
YOU'LL FOLLOW THE PROGRESS AND-
WE CAN ALWAYS- WE CAN ALWAYS
BENEFIT IF YOU KNOW IF WE NEED
TO BUT I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- IS A RIGHTEOUS
BILL I SUPPORTED THE LAST YEAR
ALL SUPPORTED AGAIN. THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD SENATOR BAKER.
ASSEMBLY EGGMAN RESPECT
CONCERNS MY FRIENDS
ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT THEM
MOVED BY THE FACT THE AUTHOR
SAYS THIS WILL REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF NON COMPLIANT
VEHICLES BY 93% DOWN TO FROM
SEVEN FIVE HUNDRED FIVE HUNDRED
PER YEAR. AND APPRECIATE HIS
EFFORTS LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS BY WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER THERE ARE NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS SENATOR JONES
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
WE'VE
REACHED OUT TO SIERRA CLUB AND
THE OTHER- LETTERS OF
OPPOSITION TRYING TO- HAVE
MEETINGS WITH THEM TO DISCUSS
THEIR CONCERNS MADAM CHAIR
AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF
BEING OPEN TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. I WILL CONTINUE
TO REACH OUT TO HIM AND- WHEN
THEY'RE READY TO SET A MEETING
AND HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS-
I'M WERE READY- WILL DO IT. THE
AS HAS BEEN STATED S. B. TOTAL
TO TWENTY SEVEN WILL CREATE A
MUCH NEEDED REPLACEMENT
REGISTRATION PROGRAM. TO ALLOW
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
COMPETITIONS TO CONTINUE FOR
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS. AS
STATED THE BILL IS NARROWLY
TAILORED TO ENSURE ONLY
LEGITIMATE COMPETITORS WILL BE
ABLE TO RIDE ON PUBLIC LANDS.
SB TWO TWENTY SEVEN RESERVE
REPRESENTS A TRUE COMPROMISE
BETWEEN ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
THE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
COMMUNITY AND THE THREE
AGENCIES THAT WERE- DISCUSS DMV
PARKS AND CAR- WE ARE IN- IT'S
ALMOST AS IF THOSE THREE
AGENCIES HAVE AN OFFICE IN MY
OFFICE- PICTURES WERE. TALKING
TO THEM SO MUCH THIS IS A VERY
BIPARTISAN BILL IT'S CO
AUTHORED BY DOLLY HUESO HER
TADO. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRAZIER
GRAY AND SMITH. IT WAS FLOOR
JOCKEY IN THE ASSEMBLY LAST
YEAR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL- MOTION MADE TODAY
BY. A SENATE ARCH A LETTER
WHICH I APPRECIATE SO- I
APPRECIATE ALL THE POSITIVE
COMMENTS IN MAN I'M SURE AGAIN
COMMITTED. TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH SENIOR STAFF
AND OF COURSE NATURI SOURCES IF
IT PASSES OUT TODAY THANK YOU
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES WE APPRECIATED WE
LOOK FOR TO THE DISCUSSIONS- WE
HAVE IT AND- MOTION ENTERTAINED
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA. MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND WE TO THE COMMITTEE.
NOW RESOURCE AND WATER.
GONZALEZ NOW THE DALLAS NO
BATES AYE BATES OF BY ALAN.
SUCH A LETTER I MUCH LATER I
BAKER BY BAKER I PUT IT I.
TODAY'S THE DALY. HI KELLY I
DOT DODD AYE MCGUIRE RIGHT
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ AYE
BELINDA'S AYE MIN. NEWMAN HI
NEWMAN AYE RUBIO FIVE RUBIO HI
SKINNER YEAH SKINNER NO NUMBER
HI NUMBER HI BY KELSEY. WILK HI
WILK I. TWELVE TO TWELVE TO TWO
SENATOR JONES LEAVE THIS ON
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MAYBE ARKHAM OUR
CONVERSATIONS WILL BE
PRODUCTIVE ENOUGH THAT I MIGHT
BE ABLE TO ADD YOU AND MISS
SKINNER ON AS CO AUTHORS AT
SOME POINT TIME ALSO WE SHALL
SEE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK THINKTHINK THINK YOU
SENATOR JONES. ALL RIGHT OUR
NEXT BILL WILL MOVE ON IS TO-
SENATOR MCGUIRE. ARE YOU READY
TO PRESENT OKAY GREAT WE HAVE
SENATOR MCGUIRE. A WELCOME SB.
SIXTY NINE. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AT GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE A
PRESENT SB SIXTY NINE DID THE
NORTH COAST RAILROAD AUTHORITY
ALSO KNOWN AS IN SIERRA A.
RIGHT AWAY TRANSFER IN GREAT
REDWOOD TRAIL ACT. WE'RE GOING
TO TEST YOU HAD TO MAKE SURE
YOU GOT THAT TIME. JUST OR YOU
VERY QUICKLY THIS IS A FOLLOW
UP BILL TO OUR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN LEGISLATION WHICH WAS
SB TEN TWENTY NINE THAT WAS THE
INSECURITY CLOSURE IN
TRANSITION TO TRAIL ACT WHICH
WAS SIGNED BY THEN GOVERNOR
BROWN. SINCE THE LAST TIME THAT
WE ALL TALKED AND WE'RE IN
FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE THERE'S
BEEN SIGNIFICANT MOVEMENT
SIGNIFICANT MOVEMENT WITH THE
GREAT RIVER TRAIL WITH THE TWO
YEAR STATE AUDIT THAT HAS JUST
BEEN COMPLETED. THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT AGENCY DEBT PAID
ASSETS HAVE BEEN TRANSFERRED IN
THE FORMAL WINE DOWN THE FORMAL
WIND DOWN OF THE BANKRUPT HOT
MESS OF A PUBLIC AGENCY NORTH
COAST RAILROAD AUTHORITY IS NOW
UNDER WAY. LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORY ON THIS BILL SB TEN
TWENTY NINE SET UP A PROCESS TO
TRANSITION THE THREE HUNDRED
PLUS MILE MOSTLY DILAPIDATED IN
LARGER LARGELY INOPERATIVE RAIL
LINES INTO A WORLD CLASS TRAIL
SYSTEM THAT RUN THROUGH SOME OF
THE WILDEST AND MOST SCENIC
LANDSCAPES IN AMERICA. WITH THE
HIGH COST OF MAINTAINING THE
TRACKS IN THE SHORTAGE OF
NATURAL RESOURCES AND GOODS TO
TRANSPORT PRIVATELY OWNED
FREIGHT RAIL SERVICE ON THE
NORTH COAST DIED A SLOW DEATH.
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE THIS LEGISLATURE CREATED
THE IN CRA MORISCO THREE ONE TO
THIRTY IN A LAST DITCH EFFORT
THE SAFE FREIGHT RAIL TRAFFIC
ON THE NORTH COAST
UNFORTUNATELY THIS DIDN'T WORK.
BUT WHEN THE GOVERNOR AT THE
TIME VETO THE FUNDING MECHANISM
FOR THE AUTHORITY IT NEVER HAD
A CHANCE CANDIDLY AND IT'S NOW
MIRED IN MASSIVE DEBT IN THE
STATE IS OFFICIALLY WINDING IT
DOWN WHICH IS A REALLY GOOD
THING. WHEN HUGE LANDSLIDES
COVERED LARGE SWATHS OF THE
TRACK IN THE OVER CANYON DURING
THE REIGNS OF NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN THE LINE WAS THE ORDERED
CLOSED BY. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NO ONE I KNOW WHEN.
HAS FOR EVER. TO REACH FREIGHT.
SMART A PUBLIC RAIL AGENCY
CREATED BY VOTERS IN THE
SOUTHERN REGION THE LINE IN
CINEMA IN MARIN COUNTY'S IS
REBUILDING OR HAS REBUILT AT
THE RAIL LINE BETWEEN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AND THE NORTHERN
CINEMA COUNTY LINE BUT
EVERYTHING TO THE NORTH REMAINS
CLOSED AND IMPASSABLE TO A
FREIGHT TRAIN. THIS YEAR WE
HAVE INTRODUCED SB SIXTY NINE
TO FINISH THE JOB OF CLOSING
DOWN IN SIERRA EIGHT ONCE AND
FOR ALL IN OFFICIALLY
TRANSFERRING THEIR ASSETS IN
THE SOUTH AND- TOO SMART. WHO
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR CREATING
THEIR PORTION THE GREAT RIVER
TRAIL. THE VOTERS MANDATE. THE
BILL TRANSITION IS THE
INSPIRATION REDWOOD TRAIL
AGENCY WHO WILL ASSUME ALL
ASSETS OF NTRA ON THE NORTHERN
SECTION OF THE RIGHT AWAY.
ESSENTIALLY THE RAIL BED IT
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
CREATING THEIR PORTION OF THE
TRAIL THROUGH MENDOCINO AND
HUMBOLDT COUNTIES. THE TRAVEL
SOON BECOME THE LONGEST
CONTINUOUS RAIL TRAIL IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. IT
WILL BE A BOON TO RULE
COMMUNITIES WHO HISTORICALLY
HAVE BEEN BUILT ALONG THE LINE.
THE ONLY FOLKS THAT WE KNOW OF
A WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
ARE FOLKS WHO HAVE
UNSUCCESSFULLY LOBBIED FOR
FREIGHT RAIL. ON THE NORTH
COAST FOR THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS. AN INTERESTING FACT
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION THE
GREAT RIVER TRAIL. WE'LL RAIL
BANK MOST OF THE LINE SO WHAT
THE HECK ISRAEL BANKING. IT'S
ESSENTIALLY GUARANTEEING THAT
THE RAIL THAT WILL STAY IN
PLACE. AND ALLOW FOR FUTURE
RAIL IF AND WHEN IT IS EVER
POSSIBLE IN THAT IMAGINARY
INVESTOR STEPS UP. YOU SIMPLY
PUT DIRT OR GRAVEL OVER THE
RAIL TURNING INTO A TRAIL. AND
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT REAL
MAKING WAS DESIGNED FOR A WIN
UNITED STATES CONGRESS PASSED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE. SINCE
THEN ACROSS THE U. S. OVER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MILES OF
RAIL CORRIDORS. WANTS ACTIVE
AROUND THE US ARE PROTECTED FOR
FUTURE REAL USE AND ARE NOW
BEING ENJOYED BY MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE. WHO ARE USING TRAILS
THAT HAVE NOW BEEN PUT ON TOP
OF RAILS AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO. THE GREAT
BRITAIN TRAIL. WITHOUT RAIL
LINKING THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE
OF THIS RIGHT AWAY WILL BE
OFFICIALLY ABANDONED IN SPLIT
UP FOREVER WE NEED TO PROTECT
THAT RAIL BED. IN BE ABLE TO
USE IT AS A WORLD CLASS TRAIL
ASSET. THIS LANGUAGE IT'S A WIN
WIN FORTHE STATE IN THE NORTH
COAST COMMUNITIES FOR A
CONHECER DEPENDING AND OUTDOOR
RECREATIONAL KANEMI. IN NUMBERS
I WANT TO REMIND YOU CALIFORNIA
HAS A NINETY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OUTDOOR RECREATIONAL
KANEMI IN IT BENEFITS THE RURAL
AND- MANY TIMES IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE EXIST
ALONG THIS LINE. AND IT'S GOING
TO BE A BOON FOR LOCAL AN
OUTDOOR ENTHUSIASTS ALIKE. WILL
FLOCK TO THE TRAIL TO ENJOY A
WORLD CLASS HIKING AND BIKING
EXPERIENCE MEDICARE AT TODAY WE
HAVE CAROL HART. HE IS WITH THE
INTERIOR MORE DIRECTORS AND
GRATEFUL FOR WORK AND THE
LEGENDARY LAURA CALLING FOR THE
NATIONALS RAILS TO TRAILS
CONSERVANCY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE WILL START WITH MS
HART- MISTER. MODERATOR CAN YOU
GET HER ON THE LINE PLEASE. ONE
MOMENT. I BELIEVE I'M ON THE
LINE TO LINE IT WILL BE GOING
TO COME RIGHT AHEAD THANK YOU
GOOD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
INSURE GONZALEZ AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
FAVOR OF SB SIXTY NINE. I'M A
MEMBER OF THE NORTH COAST
RAILROAD AUTHORITY AND HAVE
BEEN WORKING OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WITH SENATOR
MCGUIRE IN WITH THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF OUR STATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY. TO TRANSFORM
AN ENTIRELY OBSOLETE AND FULLY
DYSFUNCTIONAL RAILROAD IGHT OF
WAY AND STATE AGENCY INTO AN
INSPIRATIONAL AND
TRANSFORMATIONAL ECONOMIC
ENGINES AND HUGE RECREATIONAL
DRAW. NOT JUST FOR THE NORTH
COAST BUT FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA
AND BEYOND. THE VISION OF THE
GREAT RIVER TRAIL IS SIMPLE
TAKE A RIGHT OF WAY THAT WOULD
PRESERVE FOR A CENTURY AND
WOULD ALL AGREE HAS NO HOPE OF
EVER CARRYING REAL AGAIN. AND
CREATE THE LONGEST RAIL TRAIL
IN THE COUNTRY AND I CAN SAY AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS WORKED IN THE
PARKS FIELD FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS THAT MUCH OF THE TRAIL
WILL BE CREATED INEXPENSIVELY
AND EFFICIENTLY BY GRADING THE
EXISTING RIGHT OF WAY. AND
ADDING A WALKABLE RIDEABLE
TRAIL SERVICE. SIMILAR TO WHAT
YOU HEAR TO MUCH OF THE PACIFIC
CREST OR APPALACHIAN TRAIL. IT
IS USUALLY SUPPORTED BY THE
CITIES AND TOWNS FROM SANTA
ROSA TO WILLITS TO EUREKA
THROUGH WHICH IT WILL RUN.
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
BUSINESSES TO TIE IN AND SERVE.
HIKERS AND RIDERS FROM AROUND
THE WORLD AS THEY MAKE THEIR
WAY FROM SAN FRANCISCO BAY. TO
HUMBOLDT BAY THROUGH THE EEL
RIVER CANYON AND THE GREAT
REDWOOD FORESTS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE AT A
THRESHOLD HERE AND WITH THE
VISION OF CENTER MCGUIRE IN ALL
OF YOU. AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION WE CAN FINALLY
SEE THE END OF DYSFUNCTION. IN
THE NEEDLESS EXPENSIVE TRYING
TO RESUSCITATE A FAILED
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. AND
INSTEAD EMBARK ON A TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY VISION. OF
SUSTAINABILITY. BY CREATING THE
GREAT BRITAIN WOULD TRAIL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS HART WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
WE HAVE. A MIS LARA COHEN-
PLEASE PROCEED YOU HAVE. TWO
MINUTES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING. THIS IS LAURA CALLING
ON THE WESTERN REGION DIRECTOR
OF RAILS TO TRAILS CONSERVANCY
AND NATIONAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WE WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR SB
SIXTY NINE. CENTER SENATOR
MCGUIRE'S LEADERSHIP IN
CARRYING OUT A VISION TO
TRANSFORM THIS DORMANT BUT
HIGHLY VALUABLE STATE ASSETS.
INTO A WORLD CLASS RAIL TRAIL
THAT WILL PROVIDE ENORMOUS
BENEFITS TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION RECREATION AND
AN ENGINE FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AND DOES IT THE
RAIL TRAIL WILL BE A PART OF
THE NATIONAL RAIL TRAIL
NETWORKS OR ORGANIZATIONS WORK
WITH HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND I LIVE
TWENTY TWENTY. THERE ARE TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED RAIL
TRAILS AND- TOTALING NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MILES OF
RAIL TRAILS. AND THEN SENATE
REQUIRE MENTIONED PART OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE GREAT RED
WOULD TRAIL THE NTRA IS RAIL
BANKING THE NOR HERE NORTHERN
PORTION OF THE CORRIDOR. AND
THE REAL BANKING STATUTES-
INACTIVE BY CONGRESS IS
BASICALLY ALLOWS A REAL ROAD TO
BANK A CORRIDOR FOR FUTURE
POTENTIAL REAL USED EACH
NEEDED. AND IN THE INTERIM PUT
IT TO USE AS A TRAIL. ONE REAL
BANKING HAS- EFFECTIVELY
PRESERVES THOUSANDS OF MILES OF
RAIL CORRIDORS THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN ABANDONED
AND CHOPPED INTO MANY PIECES
WHICH IS WHY WE OFTEN CALL IT
THE HUMPTY DUMPTY PRESERVATION
ACT. PRESERVES A VALUABLE ASSET.
AND IT JUST A BRIEF CALM ON THE
CALL. ESTIMATES THE RECENT
ASSESSMENT REPORT. CAME IN WITH
SOME HIGH ESTIMATES THAT IT
APPEARS TO ASSUME THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO OTHER BEING
CONSERVATIVE BUT THE FACT IS
THERE IS NO PROJECT DESIGNED TO
EVALUATE NOR WAS THERE
SUFFICIENT DETAILED INFORMATION
ON EXISTING CONDITIONS. AND YOU
KNOW FOR UNPAVED TRAILS WHICH
ILLEGAL YOU'VE LIKELY OPTION
FOR A GOOD PORTION OF THE
CORRIDOR FIVE WE TYPICALLY SEE
COST CLOSER TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND MILES. ON IT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MILE
IN THAT MISSION ET- WHILE IT
ASSESSMENT USES NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND PER MILE
SHE'S GOING TO YOU CAN READ
PLEASE WHAT WOULD BE A GREAT.
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY IF WE CAN
HAVE YOU JUST WRAP UP PLEASE MY
APOLOGIES EACH PERSON SHOULD BE
GETTING TWO MINUTES- PER
TESTIMONY. OKAY SURE SO IT WAS
BASICALLY ANY ACCURATE COST
ESTIMATES REALLY MUST AWAIT
COMPLETION OF THE MASTER PLAN
N. E. I. R. THANKS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APOLOGIES
FOR THAT WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE EVERYONE GETS THERE A LOT
OF TIME AND EVERYONE IS EQUAL-
SO WITH HAT WE'VE GOT THE KEY.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT FOR SB
SIXTY NINE SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX NINE IN THE GALLERY IF
THERE ARE ANY THERE ARE NONE.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE S. B. SIXTY
NINE. C. NINE THE MISTER
MODERATOR WILL GO BACK TO YOU
TO PLEASE PROMPTED INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY NINE.
EGGMAN CHAIR OF TO THE QUEUE UP
IN SUPPORT OF P. SIXTY NINE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING OUT A LINE NUMBER
FORTY TWO ONE FORTY TWO. A PLUS
HE ONE MOMENT. ONE SEVENTY SIX
WE HAVE SOME CUTE UP EARLY. ONE
MOMENT. BY MODEL FOR YOUR OPEN
GOING AT. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
NIELSEN MARKETING OR ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF MARIN IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. MIKE LIMA ONE ZERO SIX
ONE OH SIX GONNA. GOOD MORNING
DILLON JACK ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
TEXAS LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO
LINES OPEN. MORNING MY NAME IS
WARREN WELLS I'M CALLING FROM
THE MARIN COUNTY BICYCLE
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT. THERE
ARE NO MORE COMMON COMPUTER.
OKAY THANK YOU MR MODERATOR-
NOW WE WILL USE THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION AND I BELIEVE WE DO
HAVE ONE LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY NINE
THAT IS MISTER DAVID SEAN
BROWN- WITH TRAIN WRITERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
GET MISTER SHAWN BROWN ON THE
LINE. CERTAINLY ONE MOMENT.
BRING MADAM CHAIR SHERMAN YOU
OUR COLLECTION GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR OUR ORGANIZATION IS
SERIOUS ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE ON
TRAINS IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE
GHG EMISSIONS FROM
TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE CHANGE
MEANS PEOPLE NEED LOW CARBON
WAYS TO TRAVEL WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD THROW
AWAY A MAJOR STATE INVESTMENT
IN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TURNED IT
INTO A MERE RECREATION.
CALIFORNIA IS SPENDING BILLIONS
ON RAIL INVESTMENTS ELSEWHERE
IN THE STATE GIVEN THAT CONTEXT
HOW ON EARTH DOES IT MAKE SENSE
TO RIP OUT THE RAILS IN THE
NORTH COAST DEFENDER CLAIMS IT
WOULD SAVE MONEY IN BUILDING
HIS TRAIL IF YOU THEN HAD TO RE
LOCATE THE TRAIL IN ORDER TO
USE THE RAILS IN THE FUTURE THE
STATE WOULD PAY TO REBUILD THE
TRAIL WHAT THE MUCH HIGHER
AMOUNT THE LADY NEW RAIL.
THAT'S NOT A WAY TO SAVE MONEY.
THE BILL PROPOSES RAIL BANKING
AS A WAY TO PRESERVE THE LEGAL
RIGHT OF WAY WHEN TEARING UP
THE TRACKS UNFORTUNATELY IT'S
FAR MORE COMPLICATED LEGALLY
THEN THE BILL SUGGESTS. THE
SENATORS BILL ENDANGERS THE
INTEGRITY OF THE THREE HUNDRED
PLUS. BOB MILE RIGHT OF WAY.
HIGHWAY ONE OH ONE IN MENDOCINO
COUNTY HAS A LOT OF TRUCKS MANY
SHIPPERS THERE WANNA SEND THEIR
PRODUCTS BY RAIL SB SIXTY NINE
WOULD PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING. WE HAVE NO ISSUES
WITH RAILS WITH TRAILS BUT WE
VEHEMENTLY CRITICIZED THE FULL
HARDINESS OF TEARING OUT TRACKS
WHEN THE STATE NEEDS TO REDUCE
GHGS. FROM MOTOR VEHICLES WE
URGE YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR SEAN
BRENNAN ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM THE LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
GALLERY IF THERE ANY- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY NINE
THERE ARE NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE.
EIGHTY NINE NOW MR MODERATOR
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO YOU FOR
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY NINE ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
ONCE AGAIN TO OF SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE SIXTY NINE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE NO QUEUING UP FOR
THE OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
OKAY NO ONE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE LINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND TAKE IT BACK TO
MEMBERS. ANY MEMBERS WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU AND CHAIRED
MEMBERS- AS SOMEBODY WHO IS
CAME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
HAD MANY RAIL SYSTEMS IN MY
DISTRICT ARE IN MY COUNTY
ACTUALLY OF ONE OF THE K.
SUPERVISOR- WE'RE IN THE SAME
PREDICAMENT IT WOULDN'T HAVE A
REAL THIRTY THOUGH BUT THEY
WERE PRIVATELY OWNED. AND WE
DID BANKING WE BANK THOSE RAILS
AND WE MADE THEM TRAILS AND- A
LEGISLATOR FROM THIS THAT WAS
IN THIS BODY BZ JOHNSON WE
HAVE A BIT JOHNSON TRAIL WHICH
IS A RAIL TRAIL IT BANKS IT IT
ALLOWS IT TO STAY. THE
EASEMENTS IN PLACE- FOR WHEN
MAYBE WE'RE NOT HERE ON THIS
PLANET ANYMORE AND MAYBE THE
FUTURE THERE IS A NEED FOR.
THAT TYPE OF MOVEMENT OF GOODS
IT'S STILL IT KEEPS IT IN. THE
EASEMENTS IN PERPETUITY SO I
CAN IN THE- THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM- MILD SEATMATE FROM- WAS.
THE SECOND SENATE DISTRICT-
HILLS GLORIA FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN STOPPING THE
BLEEDING OF- TAXPAYERS MONEY
GOING OUT IN THIS STORY SO I'LL
BE. THE HORLEY SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY AND LOOKING FORWARD
TO MAYBE HOPEFULLY SOME DAY-
HIKING THAT TRAIL. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY ANYMORE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS SEE NINE SENATOR
MCGUIRE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH I JUST WANTED
TO MOMENT- I THINK CENTER DOLLY
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD WITH
THE FACTS ABOUT REAL MAKING AND
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU. TO THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM GERBER FOR HE'S
ARTICULATE RESPONSE. IN HIS
SUPPORT OUR DISTRICTS ARE VERY
SIMILAR AND AT GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT SIR FOR
POINTING IT OUT. MADAM CHAIR OF
THIS INDEED HERE AT SAY THAT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WE GOT A LOT OF WORK
IN FRONT OF US- IMMER MAKING
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS. IN WOULD
ASK ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
CONTINUE THE PROGRESS IN THE
YEARS TO COME THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE NO YOU'RE NO STRANGER
TO HARD WORK SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THAT- CAN WE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR SB SIXTY
NINE. SENATOR DOLLY A MOTIONS
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE DALLAS HI.
DOLLARS AYE BATES. ALL RIGHT.
BATES AYE ALLEN. BUDGET LETTER
BY LETTER HI BAKER BY BAKER HI
CORTESE ALL RIGHT COURTESY I
DALI HI KELLY HI DOT. BY DOT HI
MCGUIRE. WHERE I MELENDEZ AYE
FLINDERS AYE MIN FIVE MIN HI
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN HI RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. NUMBER HI
NUMBER OF I LIKE OWSKI. WILK HI
WILK I. FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN
ZERO WE WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR
MCGUIRE THANK YOU. OKAY NEXT WE
HAVE AND I APOLOGIZE I HAD
SKIPPED OVER SENATOR ME LATELY
MALL AND SHE IS IN THE REMOTE
PARTICIPATION WELCOME SATURDAY
MON- PLEASE GO AHEAD OF PERCENT
ON SB FIVE FORTY TWO AND MY
APOLOGIES ONCE AGAIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB FIVE
FOUR TWO WILL CREATE AN
IMPORTANT TAX. INCENTIVE TO ME
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OF 1100%
REMISSION MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
AND TO HELP MEET THE STATE'S
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
TARGETS. AND AIR QUALITY GOALS
SPECIFICALLY TO FILL ENSURE
THAT THE TAXES AND FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH PURCHASING ZERO
EMISSION MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS ARE EQUIVALENT TO THEIR
DIESEL AND GASOLINE. PARTS ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN CONVENTIONAL DIESEL TRUCKS
FOR EXAMPLE THE PURCHASER OF AN
ELECTRIC CLASS EIGHT TRUCK
COULD. SUCH AS EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE IN TAXES
AND FEES WHEN COMPARED TO ITS
DIESEL EQUIVALENT. EMISSIONS
FROM MHD VEHICLES MAKE UP
SIGNIFICANT PORTIONS OF OUR
HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA DESPITE MAKING UP
JUST 7% OF THE VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD. HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ABOUT 35% OF
TOTAL STATE WIDE KNOX
EMISSIONS. SB FIVE FOR TWO IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA NEEDS AS CLIMATE AIR
QUALITY AND DURING MISSION
VEHICLE GOALS I'M COMMITTED TO
INCLUDING A TEN YEAR SUNSET AND
WILL WORK WITH THE CHAIR TO
ENSURE THAT SB FIVE FOUR TWO
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION.
EXISTING AND SEVEN INCENTIVES
SUCH AS THE HYBRID AND ZERO
EMISSION TRUCK AND. BUS VOUCHER
INCENTIVE PROJECT. YOUR TODAY
ON THE TODAY AND IS CHRIS. WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION AND BILL MCGOVERN
WITH THE COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR LEE
MON FIRST WE'LL START WITH
MISTER SHIMODA FROM CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU GET HIM ON
THE LINE PLEASE. TO ONE MOMENT.
UHHUH I BELIEVE THE NAME AGAIN
PLEASE. YES MISTER CHRISTIAN
MODA. MY APOLOGIES HE'S RIGHT
HERE IN FRONT OF US SORRY ABOUT
THE SIMOTAS GO RIGHT AHEAD HERE
IN THE GALLERY THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING TURNS ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE A CHRISTIAN
MODE WITH CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD TO
JOIN A BROAD COALITION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AND BUSINESS
INTERESTS INCLUDING CALLIE TO
SEE AN COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
AND SUPPORTING SB FIVE FORTY
TWO. SB FIVE FORTY TWO
ADDRESSES THE SIGNIFICANT TAX
AND REGISTRATION FEE PENALTIES
TRUCKERS FACE WHEN PURCHASING
MORE EXPENSIVE ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS INSTEAD OF TRADITIONAL
THESE OR DIESEL OR GASOLINE
VEHICLES WILL STILL INSURANCE
STATE AND LOCAL FUNDS REMAIN
WHOLE AS YOU KNOW 96% OF
TRUCKING COMPANIES OPERATE
TWENTY OR FEWER TRUCKS AND OUR
DRIVER WORKFORCE WHO MAKE UP
THE BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
BLUE COLLAR MIDDLE CLASS IS
MAJORITY MINORITY. TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS WHILE ALSO SUPPORTING
ESSENTIAL BLUE COLLAR
INDUSTRIES AND WORKERS THE
STATE MUST USE EVERY TOOL AT
ITS DISPOSAL TO ENSURE ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS MAKES SENSE
ECONOMICALLY IN THE
PREDOMINATELY SMALL BUSINESS
TRUCKERS WHO PURCHASED THEM
CAN'T COMPETE SB FIVE FORTY TWO
IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE
STATE'S OVERALL CLIMATE
STRATEGY IN A STATEMENT OF
VALUES THAT SAYS WE WILL NOT
CREATE A REVENUE WINDFALL OF
THE WORKING CLASS CALIFORNIANS
STEPPING UP TO GO ZERO
EMISSIONS. WE THANK SENATOR
LIMóN FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SHIMODA FOR
BEING HERE AND WOOD NEXT WE
WILL GO TO ANOTHER KEY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FOUR TWO
WHICH IS MISTER BILL MCGOVERN
CALIFORNIA FOR CLEAN AIR AND HE
IS. ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR. YES MISTER
MCADAM. IT WAS OPEN WHEN IT
STARTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM CHAIR AND THANKS TO
CENTER WE MOUNT FOR AUTHORING
THIS BILL I'M BILL MCGAVIN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND
CALIFORNIA IS AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE TRANSITION THE QUEEN
TRUCKING. WE CAN MOVE OUR GOODS
WITHOUT INFLICTING DIESEL
EXHAUST ON OUR COMMUNITIES
THERE ARE MANY ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS THAT ARE IN THE
DEMONSTRATION PILOT OR EVEN
COMMERCIAL STAGES ALREADY AND
THEY WILL REALIZE DOLLAR
SAVINGS IN FUEL AND MAINTENANCE
COSTS. BUT THE STICKER PRICES
OF THESE QUEEN TRUCKS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN THEY
ARE FOR DIESEL TRUCKS AND THAT
MEANS THE TAXES ARE HIGHER AND
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY. DIESEL TRUCKS HAVE A
LOWER PRICE UP FRONT BUT MUCH
HIGHER COSTS WHEN IT COMES TO
FUEL USE AND EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY IN TERMS OF THE
COST THAT THEY INFLICT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES. IN THE FORM OF
TOXIC AIR POLLUTION AND WE KNOW
THAT THAT BURDEN FALLS
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SO
THIS BILL IS A SMART INVESTMENT
FOR THE STATE WHICH WILL BRING
FOR YEARS REDUCE COSTS DUE TO
ASTHMA PREMATURE DEATH.
WILDFIRES THE LEVEL RISE AND
ALL THE OTHER COSTS THAT WE
KNOW COME WITH AIR POLLUTION.
AND CLIMATE CHANGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MCGOVERN OKAY WE ARE
DONE WE THE- HE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SO WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
SEE IF THEY'RE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY. THE
NINE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND ROOM ONE TWELVE. THREE NINE
SO MR MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT
BACK TO YOU PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF S. B.
FIVE FORTY TWO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FORTY TWO PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
KEEPING UP. THERE WE GO FIRST
TO LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN GO
AHEAD YOU'RE ON. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS ORACLE THOMAS
WITH LINE ELECTRIC COMPANY
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FORTY TWO WOULD ASK YOU FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANKS IS
ONE NUMBER TWENTY NINE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TO LEAVE
NOW ASK YOU FALL ON THE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF THE S. B. BY FORTY
Q. AND ON BEHALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
VOCAL GROUP OF NORTH AMERICA
WHO ALSO ASKED ME TO- REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. EXCELLENT FIVE
BILLION YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SECONDS OUTSIDE THE CIGARETTE
AND WITH OUR IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMUNITY AT LINE
FIFTY THREE LINE FIFTY THREE US.
BUT MADAM CHAIR BOATBUILDER
WITH PLATINUM ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF BRUCE MACCREADY AND
U. P. S. IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT. LINE ONE OH NINE
GO HEAD. NOT INSURED MEMBER SO
HE HAD TO LEAVE SHOP ON BEHALF
OF ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE
NOT DONE YET SO ALREADY TO-
BUILT IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE ZERO
WE NOW GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE. LOCAL I. EUROPA. THIS IS
TIM BLUBAUGH WITH THE TRUCK AND
ENGINE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE FORTY TWO. MY LAST COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE NUMBER ONE OH
SIX YEAR OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
DILLON JACK ON BEHALF OF CAL
START IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS SHOULD KEEP THEIR OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE FORTY TWO
SO NOW WILL USE THE SAME
PROCESS TO HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY UP
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IS LOOKS LIKE THERE ARE NONE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME SO
LOOK AT TO THE GALLERY FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE FORTY
TWO. THERE ARE NONE IN THE
GALLERY C. NINE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SO WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB FIVE FOUR TO PLEASE.
CERTAINLY I'M SURE TO VOTE IN
OPPOSITION OR TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I WOULD THAT POSSIBLY
HAVE NO CALLERS QUEUEING UP.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO CORRECT MYSELF WE
HAD ONE THAT WAS JUST A LITTLE
BIT SLOW IF YOU LIKE OKAY. THE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE APOLOGIZE NO
PROBLEM. WE WANT ONE MORE
SECOND HOMES BACK. AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO LIE NUMBER ONE
NINETEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE JOIN
THE- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
APOLOGIES I AM ARE REGISTERING-
SUPPORT ON THAT YOUR NORRLAND
ASKED BREAK- ON BEHALF OF
SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC IN. THE FIVE
FOUR Q. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER MODERATE ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE NO OTHER- QUEUED UP
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OKAY
THANK YOU SO NOW WE'LL TAKE IT
BACK TO MEMBERS MEMBER
QUESTIONS WE SEE SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL- AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
PERFECT TIME IS AS THE AUTHOR
AND IN THE WITNESSES NOTED. THE
UP FRONT COSTS OF THESE
VEHICLES ARE OBVIOUSLY HIGHER
BECAUSE YOU'RE PHYSICALLY
BUYING THE ENERGY IN ADVANCE.
WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
IS SMART POLICY BY REDUCING THE
SALES TAX WE CREATE NECESSARY
INCENTIVES TO DO EXACTLY WHAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO DO AROUND.
ENCOURAGING MHD VEHICLE
ACQUISITION. AND SO COMMENDED
THE AUTHOR I SUPPORT THE BILL
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR OF POSSIBLE AS IT MOVES
FORWARD. GREAT THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
READING CHAIR FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR ALL OF HER WORK- AS
IS CUSTOMARY WHEN WE ARE
WORKING ON BILLS THAT ARE
COMING TOGETHER IN FIVE. AND A
TEMPORARILY AT PLAY OFF OF THIS
BILL UNTIL IT COMES TO SEVEN
FIVES WERE IN ACTIVE
DISCUSSIONS AND JUST WANT TO
SAY. HOW GRATEFUL I AM TO
CENTER MON FOR OFFER WORK ON
THE THROUGH THE CRITICAL
SUBJECT AND- KNOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE. ABLE TO GET THIS DONE
NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE VICE CHAIR BATES. YES I
WAS JUST CHECKING I'M SORRY MY
TO MR AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PRESENTATION BY SENATOR LAMONT
WHAT IS SHE TAKING THE OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
SUGGESTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU I BELIEVE
SHE DID BUT WILL CLARIFY AND I
WAS ABOUT EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CLOSE OUT OF MY
DISTRICT THE SHEET THAT-
SENATOR LEE MOM. YES I AM
TAKING THAT COMMITTEE AT
AMENDMENTS OF THE TEN YEAR AND
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR. AND THE
HYBRID AND ZERO EMISSION TRUCK
VOUCHER INITIATIVE. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR SENATOR DODD
FOR CALPERS SHEET THE AUTHOR
TAKEN THE AMENDMENTS I REALLY-
I REALLY LIKE THIS BOOK BILL
BECAUSE IT REALLY ALLOWS US TO
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH
IS AND GIVE INCENTIVES. AND I
ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS CO
AUTHOR THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD SEE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS I TOO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY- SUPPORT AND THANK
US SENATOR LIMóN FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. WE'VE GOT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE
THAT WORK FAST TRACKING-
EMISSION REDUCTIONS ESPECIALLY
IN OUR MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
SPACE SO WITH THAT SENATOR
LIMóN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE WORK-
ON YOUR BEHALF AND ON THE
COMMITTEES BEHALF I ABSOLUTELY
WELCOME THE INTEREST. IN
BECOMING A CO AUTHORS ON THIS
BILL AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR LEE MON
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A- MOTION
BY SENATOR NEWMAN SO MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. GONZALEZ HI WELL AS I
BATES. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR
HI THANK YOU. BATES AYE ALLEN.
SUCH A LETTER HI MUCH LATER HI
BAKER HI DEBRA HI CORTESE HI
PATAGIA DOLLY. DOT HI DODD AYE
MCGUIRE. HELLO THIS. I'M SORRY
MELENDEZ AYE MIN FIVE MIN HI
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN HI RUBIO.
SKINNER UMBERG FACT NUMBER GUY
BY CAL SKI WILK HI WILK AYE.
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO SENATOR
LIMON WE WILL KEEP THIS ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING NEXT TO
CENTER SENATOR MAN FOR SB FIVE
HUNDRED AREAS READY TO PRESENT
THANK YOU SENATOR MEN WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR GONZALEZ AND
THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE STAFF-
WHO BEEN WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL I JUST WANT TO. KNOW
TO YOU ALL THAT- WE HAVE
ACCEPTED SOME LATE AMENDMENTS
THAT- CHANGE THE BILL SLIGHTLY-
SO HI THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN THE TEXT YOU'RE
GIVEN BUT SB FIVE HUNDRED UNDER
THE AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE- WOULD MANDATE THAT
ALL THE TIME MISS LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES AND BY THOMAS WE'RE
TALKING AGAIN ABOUT LEVEL FOUR
LEVEL FIVE- LIGHT DUTY WERE
CLASSIFYING AS CLASS ONE AND
CLASS TWO- SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
MANDATES THAT. ALL TIME IS
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES BE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IS ABSENT BY
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN SO THAT'S A
SLIGHT CHANGE FROM THE TEXT YOU
HAVE- I KNOW THAT THIS MEASURE
IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR STATE'S
OTHER. CLEAN AIR GOALS- THE
THEY'RE VERY AMBITIOUS- BUT WE
ARE ON TRACK TO MEETING THEM
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER RETAINING FIVE
MILLION SAM'S ON THE ROAD BY
TWENTY THIRTY. NINE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM SUPPORTER TO COMPLETELY
PHASE OUT GAS POWERED
AUTOMOBILES BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. ARE THESE TARGETS MAY
SEEM AGGRESSIVE BUT THEY ARE
NECESSARY WE HAVE HEARD TIME
AND TIME AGAIN ABOUT THE PERILS
OF. CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE SEEING
THIS IN CALIFORNIA IN REAL
TIME. MY DISTRICT LIKE MANY OF
YOURS IS UNDER SIEGE FROM THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE- WE
HAVE OUR COASTLINE THAT IS-
THREATENED BY RISING SEA
LEVELS. AND OF COURSE WE HAVE-
LARGE PARTS ARE DISTRICT THAT
ARE ON THE VERGE OF- A EACH ON
THE PERIPHERY OF WILDFIRES
INCLUDING MY HOMETOWN IRVINE
WHICH- CAME VERY VERY CLOSE TO
BEING. HAVING PARTS OF IT
BURNED DOWN THIS PAST- WINTER
OUR CARS AND TRUCKS ACCOUNT FOR
APPROXIMATELY ONE FIFTH OF ALL
U. S. EMISSIONS AND OUR MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR CALIFORNIA'S-
GREENHOUSE GASES-
TRANSPORTATION IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR HALF OF ALL OF OUR STATES
CARBON POLLUTION. AND SO I'M
GRATEFUL TO SEE ALL OF THE
EXCITING AND DECISIVE EFFORTS
TO TRY TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE.
BUT I WOULD NOTE THAT THE RISE
OF THE TIME MISS VEHICLES PULL.
A C. RISK CITIES OF GOALS- I
THINK I WE SEE. WITH THE RISE
OF WISHES. OF RIDE SHARING. AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE INITIAL
ESTIMATES ADONIS VEHICLES ARE
ESTIMATED TO ADD AS MUCH AS SIX
TIMES- THE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED PER VEHICLE- AND SO IT
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
GET THIS RIGHT AT THE OUTSET
THAT WE SET STANDARDS- THAT
REQUIRE THAT. A THOMAS VEHICLES
B. HE SAYS- AND I DON'T THINK
THIS IS TOO FAR OF A STRETCH AS
WE KNOW. THERE ARE PLENTY OF
XAMPP OPTIONS AVAILABLE RIGHT
NOW- AND THEY'LL BE PLENTY MORE
AVAILABLE BY THE BEGINNING OF
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN- A TIMELESS
VEHICLES- CAN OF COURSE THIS
SOFTWARE FOR THESE CAN BE.
FITTED TO VARIOUS TYPES OF
HARDWARE VERY FEW OF THE TIME
TO BE CALLED SOFTWARE
DEVELOPERS. ARE DEVELOPING
THEIR OWN CARS- SO- WE KNOW
THAT. WHEN THERE'S ELECTRIC
VEHICLES HYDROGEN THERE'S
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES TO
HAVE. THEIR VEHICLES IN I THINK
THIS IS JUST. A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT THAT AGAIN WE GET
THIS RIGHT AT THE VERY
BEGINNING THIS IS NOT SCIENCE
FICTION IT'S SOMETHING WHERE WE
HAVE TO TECHNOLOGIES. THAT WILL
BE HERE THAT ARE ALREADY HERE.
AND THAT WILL BE WIDESPREAD
SOONER THAN WE THINK INSIDE I
THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
THAT WE PASS THIS BILL AND I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT URGE
YOU. TO VOTE HI- WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES ELIZABETH
URBAN. A SENIOR TRANSPORTATION
OUT OF ANALYST IN A CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. AT
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS.
AND PER SHANTI REMIND DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND
CRUISE- A SELF DRIVING CAR
SERVICE- TRANSFORMING
TRANSPORTATION. THANK YOU
CENTER MEN'S WE'LL START WITH A
MISTER. DIMITRI FROM.
TECHCONNECT MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE BRING KEVIN ON
THE LINE. MR DIMITRI YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO CLARA- BETTER SHARE
I'M ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION
WOULD YOU LIKE ME THAT WAY. MY
APOLOGIES YES- WE WILL START
WITH. MS ELIZABETH ERVIN FROM
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS.
RIVERVIEW LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING CAROLINE
GONZALEZ AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS A LITTLE BIT URBAN
I'M  SENIOR TRANSPORTATION
ANALYST THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS UCS IS THE NATION'S
LEADING SCIENCE BASED NONPROFIT
PUTTING RIGOROUS INDEPENDENT
SCIENCE TO WORK TO SOLVE OUR
PLANET'S MOST PRESSING PROBLEM.
ON BEHALF OF UPS'S MORE THAN
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND SUPPORTERS
IN CALIFORNIA I AM PLEASED TO
SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE HUNDRED- AND- WE SHOULD
REQUIRE AUTOMATED VEHICLES TO
BE DEPLOYED AS EUROVISION
VEHICLES. THERE IS EXPERT
CONSENSUS THAT ELECTRIFYING
ATVS IT'S ONE OF THE ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS TO ENSURING THEY ARE
SUSTAINABLE PART OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. FOR
EXAMPLE RESEARCH FROM UC DAVIS
FOUND THAT PERSONALLY OWNED
EIGHTIES ARE LIKELY TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED WITH A LARGE
PORTION OF THOSE MILES COMING
WITH NO PASSENGERS IN THE
VEHICLE. THEY ALSO FOUND EIGHT
EITHER LIKELY TO SHIFT PEOPLE
AWAY FROM LOWER EMISSION KNOWS.
YES YES RESEARCH SHOWS THE
POTENTIAL FOR EIGHTY TO
INCREASE- BOTH GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND AIR POLLUTION.
EVEN IN A SCENARIO WHERE
POLICIES ENCOURAGE PULLING IN
TRANSIT. OUR RESEARCH ALSO
FOUND THAT NEGATIVE IMPACTS
CONGESTION AIR POLLUTION WERE
LIKELY TO HAPPEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN
COMMUNITIES ALREADY
EXPERIENCING ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICES. WE CAN ALSO LEARN
FROM THE RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF
RIDE HAILING WHICH UCS AND
HARPER HAVE BOTH SOUNDS TO
INCREASE EMISSIONS COMPARED TO
PERSONAL CARS. ACCORDING TO UCS
ANALYSIS THE AVERAGE RIDE
HAILING TRIPS IS 69% MORE
POLLUTING THAN THE TRAINS THEY
REPLACE. REPORTS AND OTHERS
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED TO DEPLOY
EIGHTIES AT THAT IN ORDER TO
MITIGATE EMISSIONS IMPACT. PART
OF A BROADER STRATEGY TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS FROM TRANSPORTATION.
THE OVERALL OF CALIFORNIA
POLICY IT'S CLEAR WE ARE MOVING
TOWARDS A ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS AND
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
AUTOMATED VEHICLES SHOULD BE
LEADING THE WAY. THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
GOVERNMENT ACTIONS INCLUDING
THE ONES THAT- CENTER MAN NAMED
IN HIS OPENING REMARKS I WOULD
JUST ADD ALSO. ACCOUNTS THIS
DRAFT FRAMEWORK WHICH LISTS THE
PLAN IF YOU'RE MISSING A BEAT
AS PART OF ITS FIRST GUIDING
PRINCIPLE- AND THE GREEN MILE
STANDARD UNDER CONSIDERATION BY
CARD THAT WOULD REQUIRE RIDE.
HAILING PEOPLE TO TRANSITION TO
THAT. COMPANIES ARE ALREADY
DEPLOYING ELECTRIC EIGHTIES.
ACCORDING TO THE STATE. REPORTS
ABOUT 50% OF THE TESTING MILD
IN TWENTY TWENTY WERE ELECTRIC.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS FEASIBLE
NECESSARY AND CONSISTENT WITH
THE GOAL. GIVEN THE FACTORS
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE. DEPLOYING
EIGHTIES POWER BATTLEFIELD IN
CALIFORNIA IT WOULD BE LIKE
DEPLOYING A SMARTPHONE WITH A
ROTARY DIAL. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE
HUNDRED. THANK YOU MS IRVINE WE
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS PER SHANTI REMOND FROM
CRUISE. A PER SHANTI CAN YOU
PLEASE GO RIGHT AHEAD WITH A
SUPPORT. FOR SB. FIVE HUNDRED.
GOOD MORNING I HEARD IN BALLOTS
AND RESPECTED COMMITTED MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
HI MY NAME IS SHANTI RAMAN AND
I AM CONVINCED DIRECTOR OF
GLOBAL GOTTEN. CARE AND YES
THEY EXPRESSED OUR SUPPORT OF.
THE FIVE HUNDRED. ALL ELECTRIC
SELF DRIVING TECHNOLOGY COMPANY
WITH THE MISSION TO BUILD THE
WORLD'S MOST ADVANCED ON THE
VEHICLE. BASICALLY CONNECT
PEOPLE TO PLACES THINGS AND.
EXPERIENCES THEY CARE ABOUT.
UNDER THE PREMISE
TRANSPORTATION THE EXACT TODAY
FUNDS AND FLAWED AND CAR
POLLUTION IS ONE OF THE NAMES
WHY. TODAY TRêN- FOR A 40%
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. AS YEAR WE WENT THE
NET IMPACTS OF CLIMATE DAM THIS
AND HOME. EACH FIRED BECAUSE
MORE THAN LAST. ECONOMIC HIGH
COULD BE HAD THEIR BACK HEALTH
AND IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITY I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
CARBONITE TRANSPORTATION.
SIGNIFICANTLY MEDICATIONS NOT A
COMPREHENSIVE. I COULD BELIEVE
AND SHALL THE QUO. SEVEN FIVE
OUR VEHICLE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING.
DAY ONE AND IN CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN POWER BY 1100% RENEWABLE
ENERGY. BY IN OUR HOME STATE.
TWENTY IN TWENTY ARE A JOB
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
FOURTEEN CREATE HUNDRED MILE
HELLO. I NEED SHOWS THAT NOT
ONLY GOING ELECTRIC THE BOOK
TODAY BUT ALL OF OUR THING YOU
BRING IN. AT THE START OF A
PANDEMIC WE WITH TV AND FORTH
AND BAKER. ON THE VEHICLE
PROVIDE CURRENT WITH LIVERY THE
FAMILY THE OPPOSITE. TO DATE
ARE PROUD TO SAY THE COMPLETED.
THOUSAND OF DELIVER. ABOUT 80%
WHICH ABOUT HOW BELOW THE
TEMPERATURE COPY LINE. BEING
YOU ARE WOULD LIKELY DONE IN
GAP CARD CARD AND IT IS JUST
SERVING THOSE IN OUR- ON THE
ROAD A QUICK. THE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND TOTAL
POUND THE END YOU EMISSIONS
AVOIDED THANK MISTER.
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU CAN- WRAP UP
YOUR TEST OF IN THE WILL GO ON
TO OUR SUPPORTERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. COOLEY- BUT I THINK
HUNDRED POWER HAS BEEN OUT TO
TAKE ANOTHER STEP TOWARDS
MEETING AMBITIOUS I'M- AND A
TENDER WE BUILD IT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE- TRANSPORTATION. THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HEARD AND- SHE'D
ABOUT. THE FIVE HUNDRED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS MIRAMONTE
AND MS IRVINE SO WITH THAT
WE'VE CONCLUDED LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE HUNDRED
SO WE'LL GO TO THE GALLERY IF
THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS. WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WE
SEE NONE. ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN SUPPORT C. NINE
SEMESTER MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT
BACK TO YOU PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
HUNDRED PLEASE. THANK YOU
ESTATE IF YOU'D LIKE TO SUPPORT
SB FIVE HUNDRED ME PRESS ONE
MIN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S A ONE
FOLLOWED BY SEVERAL TO SUPPORT
SB FIVE HUNDRED. OUR FIRST
COMMENT IS FROM LINE ONE OH SIX
ONE ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HE. HI GOOD MORNING DILLON JACK
ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION
AND CAL START INTO PORT SB.
FIVE HUNDRED. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA AND SPORT THANK.
NINE ONE TWENTY NINE ONE TWO
NINE IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE KATHY LYNCH
REPRESENTING PLUG IN AMERICA IN
FRONT SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY NINE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS KATHY CHARACTER RESIDENTS OF
BENICIA I'M SPEAKING FOR THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
ON THREE ONE HUNDRED THREE YEAR
LEARNERS OFTEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS LIKE MONEY GONNA BE
HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES
POLICE TO SUPPORT SB FIVE
HUNDRED BY SENATOR MA'AM. NEXT
DEADLINE FORTY TWO FOUR TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FORTY
TWO ZERO IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE.
I THINK ANY MINUTES OF THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION- THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION SUPPORT SB.
FIVE HUNDRED. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR SO WE'VE CONCLUDED-
WITNESSES AND TESTIMONY- IN
SUPPORT. THE WILL MOVE ON AND
USE THE SAME PROCESS FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU DO HAVE ONE LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION ON THE
LINE MR CAMERON DIMITRI FROM
TECHCONNECT MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE- I ENSURE MR
DIMITRI IS ON THE LINE. IF THE
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BEGIN.
MONNING SHARE MEMBERS CAME TO
ME TREE AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TECHNOLOGY. THE
NATIONAL BIPARTISAN NETWORK OF
TECH CEOS AND SENIOR EXECUTIVES
THAT PROMOTES BECAUSE
INNOVATION ECONOMY. APRIL IT'S
LIKE WE OPPOSING. FIVE HUNDRED.
WE SHOULD BECAUSE WE ARE TO
REDUCE GAS AND IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED THE BILL
AND CRAFT. THE REPRESENTATIVE
ADDED THOMAS COMPANIES WITHIN
MULTITUDE OF DIFFERENT MODELS
FROM SWEET TO INDIVIDUAL
OWNERSHIP. AND VARYING LEVELS
OF TECHNOLOGY. WHAT WEBER
INDIVIDUAL COMPANIES MAY HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO COMPLY WITH
SOME OF THE PARAMETERS. AND
INITIALIZATION WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL IT'S PREMATURE. ALRIGHT
COVERAGE EFFECTIVE ORDER THE
QUESTIONS THAT FOR COMPLYING TO
HOLD DECADES IDEA VEHICLE. INTO
DEBT AHEAD ON THE HEAVY DUTY
SIDE. ADVOCATE FOR TEN.
APPROACH THAT WILL LEAD TO THE
EVENT X. INTO. BUT BOTTOM MADE
IT CALLS WHICH TO DATE ARE VERY
MUCH IN THE STATE CAL. IN DOING
SO WE BELIEVE THAT BILL THE
GREATEST OPPORTUNITY MABEL AND
SOLUTIONS WHICH ARE COMING
RECALLS COULD UNLOCK FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AB TEST COOPER AT
THE TO SAVE LIVES THE NEW
HAMPSHIRE ABILITY AND INCREASED
RATE HE- WE'RE CONCERNED THE
BILL WOULD DELAY THE ROLLOUT
OKAY FEES AND STATE BY DOING SO
SURE THEY DENY CALIFORNIANS WHO
SUBSTANTIAL SAFETY MOBILITY
ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS OFFERED BY EIGHTY. THE
TEXT MESSAGE. THESE ARE VERY
HELPFUL- EIGHTIES HELPING TO
LEAD THE WAY ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS. ALREADY USING
ELECTRIC. EIGHT I DO NOT HEAR
THAT YOU'RE AT YOUR MINUTES IF
YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD AND WRAP
UP WILL GO HEAD AND COMPLETE
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- WE UNDERSTAND THEIR
AMENDMENTS FORTHCOMING TO
CONSIDER AND WILL DO SO
ACCORDINGLY BUT OVERALL WE
STILL HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
STATUS. ARBITRARY DEADLINES
THAT COULD DELAY THE LIVE CD
INTEGRATED. SOLUTIONS IN THE
STATION SPACE WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITIES PRESS OUR
CONCERNS AND OPPOSITION SB FIVE
HUNDRED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR TO ME TRULY
APPRECIATE THAT- HAVING HEARD
FROM PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- TO SB FIVE HUNDRED
WILL NOW GO TO. GALLERY WE SEE
KNOWN. ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
FIVE HUNDRED. WE SEE NONE
MODERATOR FROM. THE WITNESS AND.
OKAY MISTER AERIAL WOLF.
APOLOGIES SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
GO TO MISTER WOLF WITH THE SELF
DRIVING COALITION ANOTHER LEAD
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES GO RIGHT AHEAD MY APOLOGIES
THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
READING CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ARGHA WALT
AND I SERVICE GENERALCOUNSEL
TO THE SELF DRIVING COALITION
FOR SAFER STREETS THANKYOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
SB FIVE HUNDRED REGRETFULLY WE
MUST OPPOSE THE BILL. THE SLF
DRIVING COALITION IS COMPRISED
OF FIFTEEN OF THE WORLD'S
LEADING AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPERS INCLUDING
COMPANIES ACROSS THE TECHNOLOGY
RIDE SHARING TRUCKING AND
AUTOMOTIVE SECTORS OUR MISSION
IS TO BRING THE BENEFITS OF
FULLY SELF DRIVING DRIVING
VEHICLE TO CONSIDER CONSUMERS
AND TO SUPPORT THE STATEMENTS
WITH THE PLUMBING OF THE
TECHNOLOGY WE SUPPORT THE
AMBITIOUS GOAL OF SB FIVE
HUNDRED AND WELCOME THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
AGREED TO BUT WE REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL WOULD
DELAY THE ROLLOUT OF BABIES IN
THE STATEAND BY DOING SO WOULD
DENY CALIFORNIA SUBSTANTIAL
BENEFITS OFFERED BY AB
TECHNOLOGY WHICH COULD INCLUDE
PREVENTING THOUSANDS OF ROADWAY
FATALITIES. WE WELCOME THE
AMENDMENTS THAT MEDIUM HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES REMOVED FROM
APPLICABILITY AND LIMIT
APPLICABLE TO ORIGINAL
REGISTRATION HOWEVER WE REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL APPLIES
LED YOU TO BE A COLD EVEN WITH
AN IMPLEMENTATION THAT DELAYED
THE TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
HINDER THE DEPLOYMENT OF AB
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED
FIRST. THE COMPLIANCE DEADLINE
WOULD REQUIRE AB TO BE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE NEARLY TEN
YEARS BEFORE THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER REDUCE OUT THIS
WOULD SEVERELY RESTRICT AN.
INDUSTRY THAT IS LARGELY IN THE
TESTING STAGE. SECOND FOR
REASOS ARE UNCLEAR BILL WOULD
LEAVE OTHER MODES TRANSFER.
SUBJECT THE LONGER TIMELINE THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN PURSUIT
IMPORTANT SUSTAINABILITY
OBJECTIVES EXCLUSIVELY FOR
REGULATION AB TRANSPORTATION A
NON TECHNOLOGICALLY NEUTRAL
APPROACH DOES NOT ACCORD WITH
THE STATE'S FULL TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS PICTURE. THERE ARE
MANY OF THE CURRENT AB FLEET
YOU THE MIXTURE OF BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND GASOLINE
ELECTRIC HYBRIDS FOR VARIOUS
TECHNOLOGICAL REASONS INCLUDING
RELATED COMPUTING POWER FULL
ELECTRIFICATION OF. OF ALL
LIGHT DUTY AB GERMAIN'S
PREMATURE PROMOTE THE
DEVELOPERS. FINALLY AT THIS
COMMITTEE ON THE ON THE AND THE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE RECOGNIZED
THE JOINT HEARING LAST WEEK
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES MUST BE
PAIRED WITH INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS TO ENABLE
WIDESPREAD ADOPTION. WE KNOW
THAT THE LEGISLATORS
COMMITMENTS THE FINDINGS HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE UNLIKELY TO
BE FOUR BUILDING ADVANCED
COMPLIANCE DATE. IN THIS BILL.
WELL THE GOAL IS REMAIN OPPOSED
TO SB FIVE HUNDRED WE
APPRECIATE THE REVISIONS AGREED
TO BY THE SPONSORING THE
COMMITTEE AND WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE WORKING
ALONGSIDE THE COMMITTEE. TO
ENSURE THAT AB'S CONTRIBUTED
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS IN A MANNER THAT CONTINUE
TO ALLOW. FOR THE SAFE AND
SWIFT DEPLOYMENT OF ALL AB
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
MISTER WOLF WE APPRECIATE THAT
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO NOW AGAIN
TWO KEY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE SEEN AND IN THE GALLERY AND
NINE AND ONE TWELVE ONCE AGAIN-
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY. BUDDY WHO'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
FIVE HUNDRED ON THE LINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU TO SHARE YOUR- OF SB
FIVE. NEW PRESS ONE BUTTONS. WE
HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN Q.
ALREADY WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR ONE TWO FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JUSTIN HIGHER FROM THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE BILL FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED IN OUR WATER THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. LINE
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WE ARE
STILL REQUIRE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THANK YOU REMAIN IN OPPOSITION
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
AND STAFF AS WELL AS THE
CREATURE AND HER STAFF ARE
WORKING SO HARD TO RESOLVE
ISSUES AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT. THANK
YOU. MY NINETY ONE NINE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE NINE
ONE OR IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE.
BERMAN BONTA LINE TWENTY THREE
TO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KATE FALLON THE OFFICER
STATION FOR UNMANNED VEHICLE
SYSTEMS INTERNATIONAL WE ALSO
REMAIN OPPOSED BUT APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE OFFICE OFFICE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY ONE
ONE TWO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFETT ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION IN
OPPOSITION. LINE ONE THIRTY TWO
ONE THREE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MDAM CHAIR
MEMBERS HAD A LITTLE BIT OF
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY PALA
JUDGMENTS OF WHAT MADRE GET
QUIETER ENGINE PARKS OF JUST
BEING IN THE WRONG LINE THANK
YOU. BLIND THIRTY THREE ONE
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MATT
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE RE REINSTATED
BY THE WITH. OUR FINAL LEARNING
QUEUES LINE EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TIM
BLUE BAR ON BEHALF OF THE TRUCK
AND ENGINE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION I APOLOGIZE WE HAVE
REGISTERED A NEUTRAL POSITION
WE THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR ANALYSIS
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT WILL
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. AND WITH
THAT TURNOVER MIND IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR SO WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK TO CHAMBERS HERE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. MISS
OKAY GREAT SENATOR NEWMAN. I
THANK ABOUT CHURCH OKAY
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR- I DO
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THE
BILL. AND AS YOU HEARD BEFORE I
AM A HUGE BELIEVER IN THE NEED
TO INCENTIVIZE THE ADOPTION OF.
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES. BUT
I DO TAKE SERIOUSLY THE POINT
MADE BY A COUPLE OF THE
WITNESSES ABOUT HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T IN ON
INTENTIONALLY RESTRICT THE
DEVELOPMENT CAPACITY OF THIS
INDUSTRY. BYE BYE MAKING- IS TO
OVERLY SPECIFIC SPECIFICATIONS
THAT MIGHT REALLY IN IN P.
THEIR ABILITY TO DO THE KINDS
OF RESEARCH AND TESTING MINUTES
THAT ARE NECESSARY. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AT THE PRESS
CANCE ABSOLUTELY I THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION CENTER I'D
APPRECIATE IT- SO WEIRD WITH I
JUST WANNA EMPHASIZE WE. AND
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THIS-
WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THOSE
SAME CONCERNS THE GOAL HERE IS
NOT IN P. THE ROLLOUT OF USEFUL
TECHNOLOGY- BUT RATHER TO SHARE
THIS WITH A ANOTHER EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY- WE ARE TO
CROSSROADS RIGHT NOW WHERE. THE
DEPLOYMENT OF AV'S IS GOING TO
LEAD EVENTUALLY TO A LOT MORE
MILES DRIVEN THAT'S THE
PREDICTION EVERYONE AND- IS TO
THE GOAL HERE IS A SORT OF
SEPARATE FROM THAT BUT AS TO
THE PARTICULAR IS CONCERNED- WE
HAVE CARVED OUT A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN DEPLOYMENT AND TESTING
SO ALL THESE COMPANIES ARE
ALLOWED TO TEST ON WHATEVER
TYPE OF VEHICLES THEY WANT
FOSSIL FUEL HYBRID. BY ANYTHING
THEY WANT- WE'RE JUST SIMPLY
REQUIRING THE DEPLOYMENT BE
LIMITED TO SAYS- IT THIS POINT
WHILE THERE ARE GENERALIZED
CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD ABOUT-
INCLUDING SOME OF THE COMMENTS
TODAY ABOUT HOW THIS MIGHT
HINDER. DEPLOYMENT WE'VE NOT
ACTUALLY HEARD ANY SPECIFIED
EXAMPLES- AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN SEEING AS HIS
DATE OF A I GUESS MY- HALFWAY
INFORMED BELIEVE THAT I'D LIKE
TO SORT OF LEARN MORE ABOUT-
EAST IS THAT THERE'S NO REASON
WE CAN'T DEPLOY. WITHOUT
IMPEDING ANY KIND LINES- THAT
RIGHT NOW HOLD UP ON THE
DEPLOYMENT OF AV'S ACROSS THE
STATE IS NOT BECAUSE OF THE
HARDWARE THAT IS TO SAY IT'S
NOT BECAUSE OF A LACK OF THEM.
IT'S RATHER BECAUSE THEY'RE
STILL WORKING WITH THE
SOFTWARE- IN SO AT THIS POINT
THERE'S ONLY BEEN ONE COMPANY
CREWS THAT'S BEEN APPROVED THE
DEPLOYMENT CITY CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S NOT WHICH IN EFFECT AT
THIS BILL HAS NOT YET PASSED
SO- THE DELAYS IN GETTING
BABIES ROLE THAT REALLY AYE I
THINK OR NOT. TIED TO ANY KIND
IS HAVE. AND I ARGUE THESE HAVE
ARE MUCH FURTHER ALONG AS FAR
AS BEING A NASCENT TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S REALLY HITTING THE
MARKET AND AV'S- SO AGAIN WHAT
OPEN THE CRITICISMS- BUT BUT
YOU KNOW WANT TO SEE MORE DATA.
HI IT WAS ONE OF THE REASON WE
DIDN'T GET BACK TO TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN IS JUST YOU KNOW
WE WANTED TO TAKE SERIOUSLY THE
CONCERNS THAT WE MIGHT BE
IMPEDING. THE DEPLOYMENT OF
AV'S. PRETTY SURE THAT IS OWED
TO THE CHAIR. IS THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSED MR WILL
STILL AVAILABLE RESPOND I THINK
HE'S- EQUIPPED. TO RESPOND
DIRECTLY TO A- YEAH AND IF I
MAY. SENATOR NEWMAN I DON'T FOR
WE WANT TO MAKE CLEAR IS WELL
THAT WE KEEP. SENATOR MEN AND I
WORKED VERY HARD IN THIS OVER
THE WE SEE. AT LENGTH- WITH MY
COMMITTEE AND MYSELF HE IS
TAKING AND I JUST WANT TO-
CLEAR UP THE AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU WILL BE TAKING. THE
EFFECTIVE DATE WILL BE PUSHED
BACK BY TWO YEARS FROM THE
ORIGINAL BILL LANGUAGE TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN- DOES NOT APPLY TO MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO IN THAT SPACE-
CERTAINLY KNOW THAT AND THEN
ONLY PLACE A LIGHT DUTY CLASS
ONE AND CLASS TWO VEHICLES. N.
ONLY APPLIES TO NEW
REGISTRATIONS- SO I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT CLEARS ANYTHING ELSE UP
FOR YOU BUT IF. YOU AND I THINK
IT DOES KIND OF WITHIN THE
CHAMBER BUT I WANT TO ASSURE
THAT. THE OPPOSITION IS WELL
APPRISED OF THESE AMENDMENTS
AND NOT CLEAR TO ME AT THE
MOMENT F THEY ARE- DAVE
RESPONDED TO THEM DIRECTLY AT
THIS POINT. CERTAINLY MR
MODERATOR TO HAVE MISTER WOLF
ON THE LINE. I DO MISTER WALKER
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
THE FOR THE QUESTION TO BE A
HAPPY TO RESPOND- THE AT THE
OTHER I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THE FUND. PREMISE OF AB
TECHNOLOGY IS TO- IS TO SAVE
LIVES TO PROVIDE SAFETY
TECHNOLOGY. PLAN SO WEIGHED
AGAINST ALL THIS IS THE BILL TO
DO THAT AND OUR- ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS- ENORMOUS SEGMENT OF
THE AV FULLY AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE. TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPERS-
WITH RESPECT TO SPECIFICS WE
ARE ADVISED THAT THE- THE
TIMELINE PROPOSED HERE EVEN
WITH THE AMENDMENTS- TO THE
QUESTION ASKED ABOUT THAT BEING
A PROBLEM BUT WE ARE PRIZED IN
THE AMENDMENTS. TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN DEADLINE CONTINUES TO
PRESENT- SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
AMONG THE DEVELOPERS- AND AS AS
A FUNDAMENTAL MATTER AS WELL-
THE COALITION VIEWS THE
TREATMENT OF ANY VIEWS. AS A
SEPARATE MATTER- AS BEING- APPS
THE WRONG WITH FIRST TO ALL
OTHER MOTOR TREND BEING
AFFECTED ON THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER TEN YEARS
LATER- AND THEN ONE FINAL
COMMENT IF I MAY- WITH RESPECT
TO YOU AGAIN AND UNDERLYING
PREMISE OF THE OF THE OF THE
BILL WHICH WE APPRECIATE OF
COURSE THE INTENT AND THE
OBJECTIVE. IS ON V. M. T. SOME
OF THE STUDY THAT WERE CITED
WERE ARE SEVERAL YEARS OLD-
AND- I PRESUME PRIVATE
OWNERSHIP BUT AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER IN A STATEMENT IN
SUPPORT AND SO- WE WOULD JUST
CAUTION THAT WITH RESPECT TO
THE IMPACT ON THE EMPTY IT'S
NOT CERTAINLY AT THAT MOST IS
NOT CLEAR AND IT IT'S PAST MAY
ACTUALLY LEAD TO A REDUCTION.
AND SO THAT SERVE THE THAN THE
IMPETUS LEGISLATION WE JUST
CAUTION- THERE MAY BE A GOOD
REASON TO WAIT AND HAVE THE
BILL ALIGNED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S. EXECUTIVE ORDER
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND SO I AM
HAVE ONE LAST THAT'S RIGHT THE
QUESTION OTHER TWO IS WHY NOT
WHY NOT ALLOW. AT THE END OF.
DEADLINE WE THE GOVERNOR
SUGGESTED ORDER DEADLINE. IS
THAT A QUESTION FOR ME YES
THAT'S CORRECT I FOR. THAT I
THINK THAT THE ANSWER IS THE A
TON OF ARE SUBS OF VARIOUS
SUBSET AT THIS POINT OF OVER
VEHICLE RIGHT. IF YOU LOOK AT
GM FOR AND TOYOTA NEW WITH
THEIR BUILDING- THERE ON TO PER.
YOU KNOW A HUNDRED. OF THEIR
FOR TO BE ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR-
I SOME POINT ON THE CALL. IN
NEXT TEN TO FIFTEEN. APART THAT
RESPONSE CALIFORNIA. PART
THAT'S RESPONSE MARKET- BUT AS
FAR AS A VIS- YOU KNOW I DON'T
SEE I GUESS I FOR FLIP THAT
WHAT'S THE ARGUMENT FOR NOT
HAVING A VIS. WHICH MAY OR MAY
NOT AYE AYE AGAIN THE STUDY
THAT HAVE BEEN OUT THERE
STRONGLY. THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE. IN
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED PASSING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED- AND SO
THIS IS A NEW TECHNOLOGY AND I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS. IT'S A
IT'S IN THE WAY I LOOK AT IS
IT'S DIFFERENT THAN THE
EXISTING CARS THAT ARE BEING
MANUFACTURED IN PLACES LIKE
DETROIT. AND SOUTH CAROLINA IN
JAPAN. WHY NOT REQUIRE THIS TO
HAVE THE TO BE SEVENTH OUTSIDE
BECAUSE IT'S A BRAND NEW
TECHNOLOGY IT'S BEING ROLLED
OUT VERY SLOWLY WE'RE BEING
CAUTIOUS AND THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
HOW WE'RE DEPLOYING THIS. AND I
THINK THIS IS FULLY CONSISTENT
WITH THE SAME REASONING. BEHIND
OUR OTHER AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS AND SO I GUESS I JUST
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
PREMISE THAT QUESTION I JUST
THINK THAT. YEAH THIS IS A NEW
TECHNOLOGY I AS I SAID EARLIER
I THINK IT'S A GOOD ARGUMENT TO
BE MADE. IT'S ACTUALLY TRAILING
BEHIND XSAN SO WHY NOT HAVE
ALL THE TIME IN THIS VEHICLES.
BE REQUIRED TO ALSO BE IS AS I
THINK IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE AS
POLICY AND WE CAN MANDATE BY
THE WAY THAT ALL CARS. TODAY
WHAT IF WE- BOTTOM OF THE WAS A
BRAND NEW TO. I THINK WE ARE.
GOOD ARE. THAT I. SHOULD ALSO A
GRASS. FOR TO BE. POSITIVE
SINCE REMOVING THAT DIRECTION
OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT OF
COURSE. WE HAVE A
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND PUMP GAS.
ON WILL BE. WE MANY. LINE AND
SO YOU KNOW IT IT'S TO TRAIN.
BACK OVER BUT- A VISA TO BRAND
NEW. ON MANY TO COME. ARE ARE
DOING. I BELIEVE ALL OF THEM
ARE LIKE A- IF IN SOME OF
ANOTHER. OF THEM ARE. PREPARED
EXTREMELY ONE FOR OR ANOTHER T.
V. SO I THINK IT'S MY OF A
STRETCH- I THINK THE THREE
LEADING COMPANIES ALREADY ARE
USING SAM'S. FOR THEIR PLATFORM
SO- YOU KNOW AGAIN WE WANNA BE
MINDFUL OF THAT WE'RE NOT
IMPEDING ROLLOUT BUT- WE ALSO I
THINK HAVE IMPORTANT CLINICAL
SO WE'RE TRYING TO MEET AS
WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR MAN
SENATOR NEWMAN. HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS AND THEN WE KNOW I'M
NOT GOING TO SIT THERE ARE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
SENATOR BAKER. I WANT TO THANK
THE- AUTHORED SOME. AS SAID
WITH THE INCREASING MILES.
EXPECTED WITH A VIS. THAT WE
THEY BE LEFT FOR POLICE SHARED
A- AS WE- APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
YOU'RE A JUST. TO HAVE ONE
QUESTION- THE THIRD IS OUR R.
B. THREE. KALRA NOW I GOT SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT CHINA LINE WITH.
WITH THE TWENTY ARMS SHOWED
THAT JUST UNDERSTAND TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN VERSUS TWENTY
THIRTY YEAH AND ACTUALLY I
WACHED IT OVER FOR THE LAST
QUESTION OVER TO MY WITNESSES
WELL- MEANS- IRVINE- AND I ALSO
SHOULD MENTION THAT. WE ARE
ACTUALLY PLANNING TO HAVE THIS
BILL RUN FOR THE DMV SO WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN HERE IS THAT THE
DMV UNDER THE AUSPICES OF THIS
BILL- WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
APPROVE A VIS. UNLESS THEY WERE
ALSO EXAMS- BUT AS FAR AS THEIR
BE QUESTION I WOULD. THAT TO MS
IRVINE AND ALSO IF SHE HAS ANY
RESPONSES TO- SENTIMENT AS
WELL. ABSOLUTELY MISS IRVINE
MISTER MODERATOR. TO HAVE
MISSED IRVINE ON THE LINE. I DO
AND HER LINE OF OVER. THANK
THANK YOU SENATOR- YOU KNOW I
THINK YOU'VE COME THIS WELL- I
WISHED AFTER. THE POINT THAT
ALREADY MADE- AROUND- THE
LEADING COMPANIES WHO ARE
ALREADY. DOING A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF THEIR TESTING ON
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
STANDARDIZED AGAIN THAT WE'RE
WE'RE FOCUSED ON DEPLOYMENTS-
RATHER THAN TESTING TO GIVE
COMPANIES THE OPPORTUNITY- TO
DEVELOP THEIR TECHNOLOGIES- AND
GRACES. DATE CARBON TWENTY
THIRTY- REGULATION THAT IS
SPECIFIC TO RIDE HAILING- SO
THAT'S. A COOPER AND REST ON
THAT DAY- REGULATION AND THAT
UNDER CONSIDERATION NOW- AND
YOU KNOW ONE OF KEY CAN. IN
THAT REGULATION HAS. RELATED
TO- THE CONCERN OF PUTTING- THE
HI OF TRANSITIONING TO EITHER
ON CUBA INCOME DRAW WHO DRIVE
FOR THIS BY- WHICH IS NOT A
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE- WE'RE THE
AT AUTOMATED VEHICLES. OKAY
THANK YOU MAY IRVINE AND I HOPE
THAT DOES THAT SATISFY YOUR
MISTER MAKER YES IT LOOK FOR TO
AUTHOR ABOUT. THAT WHICH WOULD
RIGHT DATE IS GOING FOR BUT I
SUPPORT OF THE SLUDGE. THANK
YOU SO STREET. OKAY SEE NO
OTHER OR CALL FROM AT TIME WANT
TO JUST YOU SENATE MAN I KNOW
WE TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT THE
AB EV'S. AND YOUR PICKING IT UP
CERTAINLY AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR LEAD WITNESSES BOTH IN
SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION AND I
KNOW YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS BILL WITH THAT SAID WHAT
CAN WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
SB. FIVE HUNDRED. SENATOR BAKER
OKAY GREAT SENATOR BECKER-
MOVES THE BILL SB FIVE HUNDRED.
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE DALLAS HI
BILLS AYE BATES. HELLO
ARCHULETA HI BARTLETT HIGH
BAKER BY HI CORTESE ALL RIGHT
CORTESE I TELL. DOT ALL RIGHT
DONNA HI MCGUIRE MELENDEZ. HI
MAN I NEWMAN. RUBIO SKINNER
NUMBER HI NUMBER GUY CASKEY
BOOK. SEVEN ZERO. SEVEN ZERO
SENATOR MEN WILL LEAVE THE BILL
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
JUST TO REMIND MEMBERS PLEASE
RETURN TO THE HEARING AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE WILL BE LIFTING THE
CALLS AND FINISH- WE HAVE TWO
MORE BILLS TO END UP WITH THE-
THANK YOU SENATOR MEANT. ALL
RIGHT NEXT WE WILL GO TO
SENATOR NEWMAN FOR SB SIX
TWENTY THREE WELCOME SATURDAY
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB SIX TO THREE. WHICH
CLARIFIES EXISTING CALIFORNIA
LAW TO ENSURE THAT TOLL
OPERATORS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
ABLE TO PROMPTLY NOTIFY DRIVERS
ABOUT ROAD CLOSURES AND OTHER
CHANGES AS WELL AS TO GENERALLY
CONDUCT THEIR OPERATIONS
WITHOUT FEAR. OF COSTLY
LITIGATION ARISING OUT OF
AMBIGUITY SURROUNDING THE USE
OF DRIVERS INFORMATION OVER THE
COURSE OF THEIR NORMAL BUSINESS
OPERATIONS THIS BILL WOULD
ENSURE THE TOLL AGENCIES ARE
ABLE TO PROPERLY NOTIFY ACCOUNT
HOLDERS ABOUT EMERGENCY ALERTS
AND ROAD CLOSURES. TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO OBTAIN
CONTACT INFORMATION TO PROCESS
TOLL VIOLATIONS AND TOLL
INVOICES AND COMMUNICATE WITH
EACH OTHER TO PROPERLY BILL
CUSTOMERS WHO HOLD AN ACCOUNT.
WITH A DIFFERENT WHOLE AGENCY
BUT USE THE ROADS IN ANOTHER IN
SO DOING THIS BILL ALSO
ENDEAVORS TO ENHANCE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE FOR
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS TO PREVENT
THE USE OF PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION. BY
CLARIFYING AND TIGHTENING
EXISTING REGULATIONS
PROHIBITING THE MARKETING AND
SALE OF PERSONAL DATA CURRENT
STATE LAW GOVERNING THE USE OF
CONSUMER DATA BY OLL AGENCIES
WAS ORIGINALLY PUT IN PLACE TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE FOR THE MANNER
IN WHICH HALL FACILITY
OPERATORS. CAN PROCESS TOLL
VIOLATIONS AND COMMUNICATE
INFORMATION WITH CUSTOMERS AND
OTHER TOLL OPERATORS IN TWENTY
TEN STATE SENATOR JOSEPH
COMMITTEE AND AUTHORED SB
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT. WHICH
ENDEAVOR TO ENSURE THE PRIVACY
PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS WERE CODIFIED IN
STATUTE AND APPLIED TO ALL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES THAT
EITHER DID AT THAT TIME- MIGHT
AT SOME POINT THE FUTURE.
DEPLOY ELECTRONIC DATA
COLLECTION TECHNOLOGIES FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ADMINISTERING THE
TOLL AND VEHICLE TRACKING
SYSTEMS THAT BILL WHICH PASSED
AND WAS SUBSEQUENTLY PATCH
AFTER IT WENT INTO EFFECT IN
TWENTY ELEVEN EXPRESSLY
PROHIBITED TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES FROM SELLING. OR
OTHERWISE PROVIDING PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION TO
WHICH THEY MIGHT HAVE ACCESS
SUCH AS DRIVERS ADDRESSES
TELEPHONE NUMBERS BANK ACCOUNT
INFORMATION CREDIT CARD DATA OR
TRAVEL PATTERNS UNDER THAT
LEGISLATION NO TIME WAS THE
INTENT TO PROHIBIT ANY
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY FROM USING DRIVER DATA.
TO PERFORM FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING
FUNCTIONS SUCH AS BILLING
ACCOUNT SETTLEMENT ENFORCEMENT
OTHER FINANCIAL. ACTIVITIES
REQUIRED TO OPERATE MANAGE TOLD
FACILITIES NOR WAS THE INTENT
TO BE. AN TRANSFER H. FROM COME.
WITH AND ROLLED. ABOUT PRO
SERVICES OR IMPENDING CHANGES.
WOULD PROHIBIT A TRANSFER.
AGENCY FROM PROVIDING
AGGREGATED TRAVEL INFORMATION
DERIVED FROM COLLECTED DATA
FROM WHICH THE PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION
VINTAGE DRIVERS HAD ALREADY
BEEN REMOVED. OR FURTHER TO
PROHIBIT ONE TRANSPORTATION AS
YOU FROM SHARING DATA WITH
ANOTHER IN ORDER TO
STANDARDIZED PLATFORMS SO AS TO
FACILITATE INTER OPERABILITY
ELECTRONIC TOLL COLLECTION
DEVICES AND TECHNOLOGIES. TO
THE DRIVERS CAN FREELY MOVE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S VARIOUS
TOLD THAT WORKS WELL USING THE
SAME TRANSPONDERS. INDEED IN
PUTTING FOR THE ORIGINAL EDGES
SOLUTION CENTERS MILLION
EXPRESSLY ACKNOWLEDGED IN HIS
AUTHOR STATEMENT. THAT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS DUE OUT
TO OUR BRAVE TO SHARE DATA THE
WAY THEY DO CURRENTLY. SO THAT
SUBSCRIBERS WITH AN ACCOUNT ONE
JURISDICTION CAN USE A TOLL
FACILITY OPERATED BY DIFFERENT
AGENCY. WHILE ENSURING THAT THE
SAME PRIVACY PROTECTIONS APPLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WHEN YOU
CONSIDER HOW TOLL ROAD
MONITORING BILLINGS BILLING
SYSTEMS WORK THIS OF COURSE
MAKES EMINENTLY GOOD SENSE TOLL
AGENCIES NEED TO SHARE LICENSE
PLATE AND OR TOOL. TRANSACTION
INFORMATION IN A WIDE RANGE OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. INCLUDING THE
FOLLOWING. COMMUNICATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES TO FIND APPROPRIATE
CONTACT INFORMATION TO NOTIFY
DRIVERS IN PROCESS TOLL
VIOLATIONS. THE SENDING OF TOLL
NOTICES TO DRIVERS THROUGHOUT
THE THROUGH THE UNITED STATES
POSTAL SERVICE. COMMUNICATION
WITH OTHER TOLL AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE THE
DRIVERS WHO TRAVEL TO DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS USING THEIR FASTRACK
ACCOUNTS. ARE PROPERLY BUILDING
THEIR COUNTS PROPERLY DEBIT.
UNFORTUNATELY RECENT LEGAL
INTERPRETATIONS WITH RESPECT TO
PRIVACY IN THIS LEGISLATION
HAVE LEFT TRANSPORTATION
QUARTER AGENCIES EXPOSED TO
LITIGATION. ASSEMBLY PURSUING
THE NORMAL OPERATION OF THEIR
BUSINESSES EVEN THOUGH TOTAL
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE OF IN
MAKING GOOD FAITH EFFORTS TO
PROTECT DRIVERS PRIVACY WHILE
COLLECTING TOLLS. THESE PUBLIC
AGENCIES TOO OFTEN FIND
THEMSELVES BEING SUED FOR
SIMPLY DOING THEIR JOBS IN THE
PROCESS INCURRING TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LEGAL
FEES. THAT COULD MUCH BETTER BE
SPENT ON ROAD PROJECTS OR
SERVICING THEIR DEBT. USING THE
TOLL ROADS ORANGE COUNTY AS
EXAMPLE DURING LAST YEAR'S
SPATE OF DANGEROUS AND
UNPREDICTABLE WILDFIRES IN OUR
REGION. OUR LOCAL TO LAZY WAS
SO CAN ABOUT THE VERY REAL
PROSPECT OF BEING SO. THAT THEY
ULTIMATELY DECIDED AGAINST
SENDING ROAD ALERT TO THEIR OWN
ACCOUNT HOLDERS CURRENTLY THERE
SIX LAWSUIT IN PROGRESS AGAINST
VARIOUS TOLL AGENCIES FOR
PRIVACY CONCERNS. SB SIX TO
THREE MAINTAINS PRIVACY
PROTECTION WHILE CLARIFYING THE
LAW. TO THAT OUR STATE'S PUBLIC
TOLL AGENCIES CAN CONDUCT
OPERATIONS WITHOUT FEAR OF
MERITLESS BUT NONE THE LESS
COSTLY CONTINUOUS LITIGATION.
SB SIXTY THREE STRIKES THE
RIGHT BALANCE OF MAINTAINING
STRONG PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
WHILE CLARIFYING THE LAWS OR
STATE PUBLIC TOLL AGENCIES
CONCERNED ROAD CLOSURE ALERT.
TO ACCOUNT HOLDERS COMMUNICATE
WITH THE DMV AND PROVIDE
INTEROPERABLE DO SO FAST TRACK
USERS CAN DRIVE ANYWHERE IN THE
STATE. AND COUNTY AND COUNTY
SEAMLESSLY. THE BILL LEAVES
INTACT THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR PER VIOLATION PENALTY
AGAINST HOLY JEEZ IF THEY BY
THE LAW. AND IT IS DECLARATIVE
OF EXISTING LIGHT IS NOT
RETROACTIVE THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT LEGAL DISTINCTION AND
ONE THAT YOU'RE LIKELY TO HEAR
MISREPRESENTED AS YOU CONSIDER
THE BILL. BEFORE YOU TODAY.
THIS BILL HAS SUPPORT FROM BOTH
LABOR AND TRANSPORTATION
STAKEHOLDERS AND I WANT TO
THANK BOTH THE CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE STAFFER PARTICIPATE
IN NUMEROUS MEETINGS WITH ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED
WITH THIS IMPORTANT BILL. I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DIALOGUE WITH STAFF SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY VIRTUALLY. I SAMUEL
JOHNSON THE CEO OF THE
TRANSCRIPTION QUARTER AGENCIES
AND REBEKAH LONG FROM THE BAY
AREA TOLL AUTHORITY TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN WILL GO TO
MISTER MODERATOR. AND WE'LL
START WITH MR JOHNSON PLEASE.
THANK YOU A LINE OF OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING ON DOLLAR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SAMUEL AND I
SAID HE TO TRANSFER CORPORATION
WHICH OPERATES FOR TOLL ROADS
IN ORANGE COUNTY THAT REPRESENT
20% OF THE COUNTY STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM I VERY MUCH LIKE TO
THANK CENTER NEWMAN FOR
DRESSING THIS CRITICAL MATTER
BY OFFERING SB SIX TWENTY THREE
OF WHICH AS HE NOTED IS MEANT
TO CLARIF THAT TOLL FACILITIES
ARE MADE EACH YEAR NECESSARY
INFORMATION WITH OTHER AGENCIES
IN THE DMV FOR TOLL COLLECTION
ENFORCEMENT. A STATE LAW
MANDATES THAT TOLL FACILITIES
ARE INTRACTABLE MEETING A
CUSTOMER ONLY NEEDS ONE ACCOUNT
TO BE ABLE TO USE ANY FACILITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN ORDER
TO DO SO TOLD AGENCIES NEEDED
BILLION SHARE INFORMATION WITH
OTHER TOLL OPERATORS AS WAS
NOTED HELLO LADIES OF THE STATE
ARE THE TARGET OF NEWMAN CLASS
LAW. BY CONSUMER JOURNEY SPORTS-
THAT FORMER CENTER MEDIA PUT
ALLEGING SHARING OF IDENTIFY-
IN. I HAVE THE NOTE- CENTERS IN
INTENSE AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT WAS VERY
CLEAR IT WAS NOT INTO TO BRING
OUR DAILY OP. ANY CALL FOR. TO
THE BILL OUR- AT A LOSS THAT WE
ARE FOR AREN'T OUR TO WITH
CUSTOMERS EMERGING SAID- THAT
THE CENTER AND IS VERY FOR T.
IMMUNITY WE WE'RE TRYING TO
HELP MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
DURING CHALLENGE. TIMES WE-
DURING THE FALL OF TWENTY TWO
IN DEALING WITH Y. AND NOT
BEING ABLE INFORM OUR CUSTOMER
AND MEMBERS THE ABOUT ROAD
CLOSURES AND EVACUATION DUE TO
CONCERNS REGARDING LITIGATION
RISK SO SB TWENTY SIXTY THREE
THANK YOU WOULD REALLY HELP US
IN THIS REGARD- AS NOTED IT
MAINTAINS EXISTING PRIVACY LAWS
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IN
ASSOCIATED. PENALTIES WHILE
ALSO IN A DANCING INTERNET
RESEARCH. WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
OF BANKING AND I RISK BUT YOUR-
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TEST. WHERE MOVE ON MS LAW. A
RELATIONS MANAGER MUCH OF CHIU.
COMMISSION AS LONG. AS
GOVERNMENT REALLY FOR THE BAY
AREA TOLL AUTHORITY ABOUT IT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR TOLL COLLECTION
ON THE BAY AREA SEVEN STATE
OWNED TOLL BRIDGES AND PROVIDES
CUSTOMER SERVICE FOR THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE AND GROWING NETWORK
AND EXPRESSLY. THAT IS PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB SIX TWENTY THREE
WHICH CLARIFIES THAT EXISTING
LAW PERMITS TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES TO SHARE BASIC
PLATE NUMBERS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF IDENTIFYING REGISTERED
OWNERS SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
NOTICES TOLD AND COLLECT UNPAID
TOLLS AND PENALTIES. WHEN I TRY
TO USE AS A TOLL FACILITY
WITHOUT PAYING THE TOLL TOLL
AGENCIES THE CONTENT TO RECOUP
THE TOLD BY SENDING MOTORISTS
TO NOTICE. TO LOCATE THE NAME
AND CURRENT ADDRESS OF THE
REGISTERED OWNER TOLD AGENCIES
ARE AUTHORIZED TO REQUEST
ACCESS TO THE DMV'S
REGISTRATION DATABASE. SHARING
THE LICENSE PLATE WITH THE DMV
IS A KEY STEP IN THAT PROCESS.
THE CLAIM THAT THIS IS A
PRIVACY VIOLATION FLIES IN THE
FACE OF COMMONSENSE AS WELL AS
THE TWENTY TEN BILL. WHICH
STATED ITS RESTRICTIONS WOULD
NOT PROHIBIT ACTIONS NECESSARY
TO OPERATE AND MANAGE THE TOLL
COLLECTION SYSTEM.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT PROVISION
WHICH WAS INTENDED TO ENSURE
THE CONTINUITY OF OUR
OPERATIONS HAS NOT PREVENTED
LAWSUIT AS YOU JUST HEARD FROM
DIVERTING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FROM THE TREE STATE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
INCLUDING SB SIX TWENTY THREE
WILL PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY CLARITY ABOUT THE
LAWFUL WAYS IN WHICH TOLD
AGENCIES MAY USE INFORMATION
WHILE ALSO PERFECT PRESERVING
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS THAT
PROHIBIT THE SALE OR IMPROPER
DISCLOSURE. IS PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION AND
STRENGTHENING PRIVACY POLICY
REQUIREMENTS BY REQUIRING THAT
THEY DISCLOSE HOW THE CUSTOMER
MAY OPT IN AND REVOKE CONSENT
TO RECEIVING INFORMATION. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY THREE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY. THANK YOU
MISS LONG THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY SO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY THREE
IN THE GALLERY. WE SEE NINE
ROOM ONE TWELVE. C. NONE MISTER
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
YOU PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WISHING. TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWO THREE
PLEASE. THANK YOU TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT IN FOR SB SIX TWO THREE
PRESS ONE ZERO YOUR TO KEYPAD
AGAIN THAT'S ONE BY ZERO
WELCOME ONE THIRTY ONE THREE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
MOIRA TALK ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE ONE FORTY ONE FOUR
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL MAP THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSITION. START IT BY NOTING-
THAT TO BE CLEAR WE ASSOCIATION
AB EIGHT POSITION ON SB SIX
TWENTY THREE HOWEVER THE
ASSOCIATION DID SUPPORT.
EARLIER BILL SB SIX SIX FOUR
ALLEN FROM TWENTY NINETEEN
WHICH SOUGHT TO ADDRESS MANY OF
THE SAME CHALLENGES HAPPENED BY
SB SIX TWENTY THREE WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE AT THIS COMMITTEE TO
KEEP THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD.
HELLO THANK YOU AND IF I CAN
JUST REMIND- FOLKS ARE GOING TO
JUST TAKE THE NAME WE ARE
AFFILIATED WITH AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
NO OTHER LINE THEN Q. IT THIS
TIME. GREAT THANK YOU MODERATOR
SO WE USE THE SAME PER FOR
OPPOSITION- AND RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A BELIEVE ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION I'M DOUBLE CHECKING
THAT IS MISTER BLAKE. LINDEMANN
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU GET MISTER LEAD MAN ON THE
LINE PLEASE. THANK YOU KNOW
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BLAKE WHEN THE
MAN COUNCIL BEHALF OF CONSUMER
CLASS SUITABLE ACT UNDER STE
HIGHER CODE. THIRTY ONE NINETY.
SB SIXTY THREE UNDO IMPORT
CLUES PRICE PER. THE STAB BY.
SUPPORT- OVER DECK AGO IN THE
WAKE OF THE SHARING DRIVERS
SENSITIVE PERSONAL. SOME SENSE
TWELVE SIX EIGHT MILLION PASSED
INTO THE TEN THE USE OF SHARING
MOTORIST PERSONAL. CALVET WERE
THE IMPORTANCE OF PRIDE DOORS I
THE CALIBER COULD PRICE ACT IN
TWO EIGHT. WHICH WOULD OVER
VOTED TO STRENGTHEN NOVEMBER.
RIGHT TO PRIVACY IS EVEN A
CONSTITUTION RIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA. TO BE RECOGNIZED BY
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IN
RECENT DECISIONS HI SB SIXTY
THREE MOVES US IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION BY WEAKENING
PROTECTIONS AND DOES SO
RETROACTIVELY TO AUTHORIZE THE
TOLL AGENCIES AND THE PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS. HAVE. VIOLATIONS
OF THE LAW. IT'S AGENCIES THE
NEED S. B. SIXTEEN BECAUSE
PERSONAL FROM FOR MEN AND MANY
REASONS ALL. HOWEVER INSTEAD
THEY BELIEVE DR DATA CONDUCT
TARGET MARK. IMPORTING OF
CREDIT THEY- DATA MINING WELL
TO. TRACKING AND ALSO TO IS IN
THE- ABSORB PANEL AGAINST.
DRIVERS WITHOUT PROCESS. SB
SIXTY THREE PROBLEM IN THAT IT
WOULD A REAL COUPLE OVER OVER
HOW. COMPANIES USE PERSONAL
DATA COLLECTED ON PUBLIC
HIGHWAYS. PRIVATE COMPANIES TO
CONTRACT WITH THE TOLL ROADS
WOULD HAVE NO RESTRICTIONS AS
TO HOW THEY ACCESS OR USE THAT
DATA CALIFORNIA DRIVERS. SB
SIXTY THREE WOULD ALSO
UNDERMINE PENDING LITIGATION TO
ADDRESS VIOLATIONS. CALIFORNIA
COURT WHAT TO THE TEXT OF THE
BILL AND LEGISLATIVE MATERIAL
TO DETERMINE THE BILL'S
APPLICATION. IF THE BILL
REPRESENTS A CLARIFICATION
EXISTING LAW THEN THE BILL IS
APPLIED TO ALL INSTANCES BOTH
RETROACTIVELY AND PROSPECTIVELY
IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA. LIMITED
HELD WRAP UP PLEASE THANK YOU
GO AHEAD WILL KELLY THANK YOU
CALIFORNIA VOTERS SHOULD NOT BE
DEPRIVED OF HOLDING THE TOLL
AGENCIES AND THE PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS. FOR I'M JUST
PRACTICES UNDER EXISTING LAW
YOUR THESE PROPOSED CHANGES
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC POLICY GOING
FORWARD I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND WE OPPOSE SB
SIXTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER LEAD MAN
OKAY THAT CONCLUDES OUR KEY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX TWO THREE. ALSO NOW WILL
TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY SEE NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION ROOM ONE TWELVE. WE
SEE NO WHEN THEY'RE IN
OPPOSITION MR MODERATOR TAKING
IT BACK TO YOU PLEASE PROMPT
ANY INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO
PART DISSIPATE AND IN
OPPOSITION. SB SIX TWO THREE
PLEASE. THANK YOU COLLECTED
YOU'RE UP. OF S. B. SIX THREE
PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR TO
KEYPAD BEGIN THE COMMAND ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE'RE
SPEAKING ENOUGH. OF SP SIX TWO
THREE. WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. AND
TO BE JUST AMONG PLEASE. OUR
COMMON COMES FROM LINE ONE
THREE EIGHT ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL
REPAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU KNOW AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
KNOWN FOR THEIR LINES AND CUES
OKAY THANK YOU MR MODERATOR SO
WE'VE CONCLUDED BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WE SEE COMMENTS
FROM SENATOR UMBERG GO RIGHT
AHEAD. OF THE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- THREE QUICK THINGS- ITEM
NUMBER ONE MY APOLOGIES TO
SENATOR NEWMAN I SENT HIM FOR
QUESTIONS AT EIGHT FORTY NINE
LAST NIGHT AND HE RESPONDED
WITH A FIVE PAGE SINGLE. SINGLE
SPACED DOCUMENT THIS MORNING SO
WHOEVER WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT I APOLOGIZE SECOND POINT
IS I UNDERSTAND IS BILLS COMING
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON I HAS
COME CONCERNS CONCERNING THE
PROLIFERATION OF THE
INFORMATION THAT IS COLLECTED
IN IN THE SAFEGUARDING THAT
INFORMATION. THIRD IS THE-
POLICY OF THE LEGISLATURE.
BASICALLY INTERJECTING ITSELF
IN CURRENTLY- ONGOING
LITIGATION. THAT DOES THREE
CONCERNS AT LEAST TWO OF THOSE
CONCERNS AND ONE APOLOGY OF ALL
ADDRESS WHEN WE GET TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE OF THE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT I
WANT TO ALERT YOU TO- THOSE
CONCERNS THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU M. SENATOR NEWMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND NOW OR YOU CAN
WAIT UNTIL I- I. I'VE BEEN
URGED TO INTO MY CLOTHES BY MY
COLLEAGUE CLOSEST TO ME OUT OF
THE OUR RIGHTS. NO PROBLEM ALL
AND YOU MAY HAVE TO CLOSE NOW
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF I SEE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS SO IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE I DO SO GO RIGHT AHEAD
MISTER SENATOR NEWMAN I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU MEASURE DAYS MEMBERS
DIED THANK YOU RICK IT'S YOUR
CONSIDERATION LIKE TO THANK.
BOTH OF MY WITNESSES FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS. AS BOTH OF THEM
MADE CLEAR. THAT THE INTENT
HERE IS USED TO PROVIDE THAT
CLARITY. RIGHT NOT TO READ
DIRECTLY INCLUDES ANY LAWSUIT-
BUT SIMPLY TO CLARIFY- THE TWO
MILLION BILL BUT ALSO TO BUILD
ON. CENTER ALLAN'S SIXTY FOUR
FROM THE STATION. TO THAT THESE
TOLL ROAD CAN WITHOUT. UNDUE
FEAR. LITIGATION AND- OPERATION
IN WAYS THAT ARE NOW. IN
PRUDENT. TO MIKE. HERE IN
BERGEN WELL I'M GLAD TO
CONTINUE THE COVERAGE. ABOUT
PROTECTING NOW AND OTHER
CLARIFYING USE OF DATA AND WILL
CAN. TO THE IS MOVED YOUR COME.
RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR NEW C.
OTHER CAR FROM. SO MISTER
CONSULT IF YOU CAN- CALL THE
ROLL BUT I THINK WE HAVE- WE
NEED TO MOVE FIRST WHO WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL FOR SB
SIXTY THREE SENATOR DODD THANK
YOU. MISTER SHE CONSULTANT
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY. GONZALEZ HI WELL
AS I BATES. ELLEN ELLEN I
ARCHULETA HI BUT I BAKER RIGHT
BAKER PUT A I'VE FORTY Z. I
DALI. DOT DAUGHTER MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ HI LINDA I MEAN.
NEWMAN I NEWMAN AYE RUBIO SAID
HI RUBIO I SKINNER. UMBERG HI
NUMBER I LIKE OWSKI WILK. ZERO
OKAY TEN ZERO SO WE WILL LIVE
THE CALLS AND I WONDERING
MEMBERS OF HAVE ONE MORE BILL
WILL WAITING FOR WE BELIEVE
HE'S BEEN UP IN NOT RESOURCES
SO WHILE WE WAIT I JUST WANT
REMIND MY TO COME TO CHECK WE
NEED TO LIFT THE CALLS YOU CAN.
ALL APPS MEMBERS PLAY. YEAH WHY
DON'T GO AHEAD AND LET THE CALL
NOW UNLESS HOLD ON ONE MOMENT
UNLESS HE'S ON HIS WAY ONE
MOMENT. ALRIGHT SO FOR THE SAKE
OF TIME SO WE CAN BE EFFICIENT
HERE MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
CAN WE LIVE THE CALL PLEASE
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR SENATOR
WIENER. THE FIRST CALL IS OF
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND THIS
IS THE NAMING RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CENTER
ALAN. HI HELEN I. MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE I. RUBIO HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. BY CAL SKI WILK.
FOURTEEN ZERO A FOURTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT OF.
NO CALL POLL IT'S ON FOR SORRY.
NEXT IS THE SECOND CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTING OF SB FIVE
TWELVE SB TWO FOURTEEN SB SIX
FORTY S. B. THREE THREE THREE
S. B. TWENTY ONE SB SIX THIRTY
FIVE S. B. TWO EIGHTY SEVEN SB
SEVEN NINETY SB THREE SIX SIX.
SB THREE NINE NINE. SENATE
ALLEN ELLEN HI CINNABAR.
MCGUIRE HI THE RUBIO I RUBIO HI
CENTER SKINNER. THE NEW AYE
CASKEY CENTER WILK. FOURTEEN
ZERO OKAY THAT ONE REMAINS CALL
AS WELL. SB FIVE FOUR EIGHT BY
SENATOR EGGMAN- THE CHAIRS AND
I BOTH FIGHTERS AND I BOTH.
SENATE ALLEN. BAKER. FIVE BAKER
I. MCGUIRE RIGHT. SO I'M AWARE
WHERE WHERE HI THANK YOU FOR.
BLENDED I WANT TO DIE. WHITE
HOUSE COULD. THAT'S A. FIFTEEN
ZERO. OKAY THAT ONE REMAINS ON
AS WELL SB SIX SEVEN. PERSON
GONZALEZ THE CHAIRMAN CHAIR OF
BY THE FEDERAL. WHERE I MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ. I LINDA'S AYE BY
CASKEY WILK. WELCOME BACK TO.
FOURTEEN ZERO OKAY THAT'S ON SB
SIX OF ONE THAT'S OKAY YOU.
NEXT IS SB FIVE A SENATE HUESO
CHIU BY CHAIR OF THE I. MCGUIRE
RIGHT MCGUIRE BLENDED. MELENDEZ
I. WHAT KASKY. THE VOTER
SIXTEEN ZERO OKAY SIXTEEN ZERO
THE GETS OUT INCOMING READ THE
MOST AS WELL PLEASE MR CHEAP
FOR SUBSEQUENT- AND WAS FOR SB
FIVE EIGHTY DOMINIC SURE S. B.
FIVE EIGHT IN THAT MOVIE WAS
THOUSAND BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
ON A- WONDER THANK YOU. S. TWO
SEVEN. BY SENATOR AMONG TO PAY
A ROOF TO THE CA ON THAT WE-
AD WHAT. THE CHAIRS A NO VOTE
THE BY CHAIRS I'VE- SENATE
ALLEN. MAN MY COUNTY. TWELVE TO
K. TWELVE TO REMAINS ON CALL.
NEXT IS SB FIVE FOUR TWO
SENATOR LIMON TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR BOTH AYE VOTES CENTER
ALAN. DOLLY MCGUIRE. RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SKINNER MY CASKET.
YEAH OKAY TWELVE ZERO SB FIVE
FORTY TWO REMAINS ON CALL. SB
SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS ME
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR OF ALL FIVE VOTES.
CENTER ALAN. SKINNER BY CASKEY.
FOURTEEN ZERO K. FOURTEEN ZERO
ALSO REMAINING ARTICLE IT'S SB
SIXTY NINE. SB FIVE HUNDRED BY
SENATOR MEN THE CHAIRS AND I
BOTH THE VICE CHAIRS NOT VOTED.
BATES HELEN. DALY DOLLY NO
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ NEWMAN NEWMAN
AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SKINNER BY
CAL SKI WILK WELL NOW. TWO NINE
TWO. OKAY NINETY WILL REMAIN ON
CALL. SB SIX TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY CHAIRS
AND I VOTE VICE CHAIRS NOT
VOTED. BATES. DOLLY HI KELLY
AYE MCGUIRE. IN SKINNER BY
KELSEY WELCOME. WELL I. TWELVE
ZERO OKAY. AND THAT WILL REMAIN
ON CALL THE NEXT BILL WE ARE
STILL WAITING FOR SENATOR
WIENER AND I BELIEVE HE'S STILL
PRESENTING AND NATURAL
RESOURCES BUT I THINK SENATOR
MCGUIRE MAY BE THE PINCH HITTER
FOR TODAY SO WE'RE WAITING ON
THAT IF WE CAN. TAKE A MOMENT
ARE YOU READY OKAY WONDERFUL.
SENATOR REQUIRE WINS THE DAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WELCOME AGAIN
SENATOR MCGUIRE YOU'RE GOING TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
WIENER VEHICLES ROAD USAGE
CHARGE PILOT PROGRAM SB THREE
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND-
CENTER WINNERS INSINCERE
APOLOGIES IN NOT BEING ABLE TO
BE WITH US TODAY BUT DUE TO THE
COMMITTEE SCHEDULE HE'S STILL
PRESENTING AND NOT RESOURCES
AND WOULD WANT TO BE HERE WITH
EACH OF THE MEMBERS. AS WELL AS
MEDICARE MEDICARE HE SAYS THANK
YOU AND YOU'RE A VERY CAPABLE
STAFF TEAM FOR ALL THE WORK. SB
THREE THREE NINE IS THE GAS TAX
ALTERNATIVE PILOT THAT WILL
EXTEND THE ROAD CHARGE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FROM TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. THE PILOT
IT WAS CREATED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN IT WAS
ADMINISTERED BY THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY IN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
ALLOW FOR THE STUDY OF AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE GAS TAX. A
ROAD USER CHARGE HER CHARGE FOR
DRIVERS BASED ON THE MILES THEY
TRAVEL CURRENTLY AS YOU ALL
KNOW THE GAS TAX- WE HAVE IN
PLACE FUNDS ARE HIGHWAYS. OR
LOCAL ROADS STREETS PUBLIC
TRANSIT IS WELL HOWEVER THIS
TAX IS NOT A LONGER TERM VIABLE
SOLUTION FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING. PUT THE REVENUE BASED
SOLELY ON GASOLINE CONSUMPTION
ANY POLICIES WE IMPLEMENT THE
LOWER VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED OR
INCREASE OVERALL FUEL
EFFICIENCY OF VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA ALL GOOD THINGS BY
THE WAY IN OUR FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE. WILL THEN
REDUCE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING FOR ROADS HIGHWAYS
BRIDGES AND PUBLIC TRANSIT. OF
COURSE THEY NEED TO FIND OUR
ROADS HIGHWAYS AND TRANSIT
SYSTEMS WON'T CHANGE. ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES PUT WEAR AND
TEAR ON OUR ROADS AND HIGHWAYS
JUST LIKE GAS BURNING VEHICLES
DO AS WELL. YET INCREASE FUEL
EFFICIENCY- DESIRABLE AS IT IS
WILL ALTERNATELY AT
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE AVAILABLE
FUNDS TO INVEST IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM IN
FINER TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE WE MUST
TRANSITION FROM A GAS TAX
REFORM OF A ROAD USER CHARGE SB
THREE THREE NINE ALLOWS FOR THE
FURTHER STUDY. AT THIS CRUCIAL
POLICY. ALL I WANT TO STRESS
VIOLENT PRO. WHERE PARTICIPANTS
PAY ROAD CHOI. AS OPPOSED TO
THE RESPECT. GAS TAX. CRUCIALLY
SB THIRTY NINE ALTERS A IN A
WAYS. NUMBER ONE IT ALLOWS FOR
THE PARTY TO BEGIN COLLECTING
FROM. NUMBER TWO THE BILL
SPLITS PROTEST ENDED GROUPS.
ONE WITH THE CHAU BASE SOLELY
WHILE. WITH THE OTHER GROUP
BASE ON A EQUATION THAT TAKES
INTO A THE FOR. OF THE
PARTICIPANTS VEHICLE. THIS
SECOND GROUP WELL IT WAS
DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT EVEN
WHEN TRANSITIONING TO ROAD
USERS USER CHARGE. THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO PURCHASE
A MORE FUEL EFFICIENT VEHICLE
AS CURRENTLY SEEN WITH THE GAS
TAX WOULD REMAIN IN PLACE.
MEMBERS THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
INITIATIVE. TO COMPARE THESE
TWO PARTICIPANTS THE CDC IS
TASKED WITH REPORTING BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE COMPARING AND
CONTRASTING THE TWO RATES AND
THEIR IMPACT ON THE STATE'S
CLIMATE. AIR QUALITY THERE HAVE
BEEN EQUITY GOALS. AT THIS
PROVIDES. WITH HER INFORMATION
REGARDING A ROAD USER CHARGE
AND ONE SURE THAT WE ARE FULLY
PREPARED. ON HOW TO BEST.
TRANSITION OF FROM THE GUEST. A
IT SAID THIS BILL IS BY
CALIFORNIA TERMS COMMISSION.%
THE TRANSIT SILICON ANSWERS SO
SHE- IN OUR DC IN MANY OTHER.
AND WE HAVE WITH US PAGO SKI-
E. HE IS WITH A COW. TO
COMMISSION MADAM CHAIR AS OUR
ONE WITNESS. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE WE APPRECIATE YOU-
FILLING IN FOR SENATOR WIENER
SO WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
MISTER MODERATOR TO MISTER
PAUL. BILL BUCKLEW BECAUSE I'M
SORRY I APOLOGIZE GOAL IS TO
SKI- CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION COMMISSION MR GOAL
IS KEY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING CHECK AND BALANCE AND
SENATORS THIS IS A POSSIBILITY
KEEP DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
LEGISLATION AND FINANCE AT THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON SB
THREE THIRTY NINE TODAY. THIS
LEGISLATION ADDRESSES THE
CRITICAL ISSUE WHICH IS THE
FIFTEEN ABILITY OF STATE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE GAS TAX WHICH HAD LONG
SERVED AT THE TIME FOR RAISING
REVENUE NEEDED PAY FOR MORE
TIME TRANSFER. FOR IS EXPECT TO
YOUR A LOT MONTH'S RECORD AT
THREE BECOME MORE EFFICIENT
DRIVER SHOULD. YOUR EMISSION
VEHICLE. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
MARKED TYPICALLY FOR THE
REVENUE AND SINCE TWENTY. WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE CREATE THE
RIGHT CHARGED AT COMMITTEE TO
EXPLORE A NEW CAR. SYSTEM WHERE
DRIVER WOULD PAY BY THE MY
RATHER THAN BY THE GALLON. SB
THREE NINE WHAT ALLOW THE TECH
IT TO AND THE- AGENCY BUILT
UPON PREVIOUS EFFORTS BY OTHER.
A NEW HIGH PROGRAM TO TELL
WHETHER COLLECTION. IT'S WHAT
INSURANCE THE STATE HAS THE
RIGHT PROFIT AND FRIEDMAN
RETURN PAYMENT ONE OF COMES FOR
ACTUAL. RIGHT TESTING REVENUE
COLLECTION ON VOLUNTEER
PARTICIPATE OR STATE OWNED
VEHICLES. THE STATE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR STAFFING THE
VERY CHARGE TECHNICALLY
COMMITTEE THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
EXCEPT FOR INSURING THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING I THANK
SENATOR WIENER FOR INTRODUCING
THIS LEGISLATION WHICH WOULD
IMPLEMENT ONE OF THE COMMISSION
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR GOAL IS TO SKI
AND WE HAVE YOU AS THE ONLY
LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT SO NOW
WE'LL GO TO THE GALLERY FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE NINETY NINE. ROOM
ONE TWELVE. KNOW WHETHER I
WITNESSES AND THERE MISTER
MODERATOR TAKING IT BACK TO YOU
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THREE NINE PLEASE. THANK YOU TO
STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
THREE NINETEEN OR PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WELL FIRST IN
LINE ONE THIRTY. THREE ONE
THREE THREE FOUR HAD. ANY
MEASURE AGAIN NOT ROBINSON WE
SHOW TO SHELTER WEARING.
BUCKLING SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE CEMETERY WITH CITY COUNTY
ASSOCIATION GOVERNMENTS
SACRAMENTO COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT AS WELL AS CALTRAIN.
AND. ENCOURAGING THE USE OF
FORWARD TODAY. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY ONE FOR ZERO ONE OF
THE- I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND THE DIRECTOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AND
CORE OR DRIVE. NINE SEVENTY
WOMAN SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA AND
UNITED CONTRACTORS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE THREE SEVEN ONE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MACKLER WITH THE INTENT VISORS
ON BEHALF OF VULCAN MATERIALS
COMPANY AND PART. LINE ONE
FORTY NINE ONE FOUR NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MANCHURIAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NORRLAND ASPECT WITH
CARPENTERS FEVERS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASPHALT PAVEMENT
ASSOCIATION AND TRIPLE A AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THREE NINE THANK
YOU. NINE ONE FORTY EIGHT ONE
FOUR EIGHT. ON TIMES WITH CLIMB
FORTY ONE FOUR FIVE ONE OPEN.
MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
KIM CHANG WITH THE AUTO CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA A MEMBER OF
THE- TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE URGING YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. NEXT IS LINE ONE
TWENTY ONE ONE TWO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFETT ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. OUR
FINAL LINING KEY WAS LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR ONE FIVE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHEN NUMBER TICKET CREDIT WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL CALLING IN SUPPORT AND
ALSO REGISTRY SUPPORT ON BEHALF
AT YOUR CLUB CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
OF THE COMPLAINT THANKS MUCH.
THAT ARE NO OTHER INTO A TEST.
A THANK YOU MISTER MOM. US AND
I'LL USE THE SAME PROCESS FOR
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION A PERSON IDENTIFIED
BUT THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO THE
GALLERY ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE THREE NINE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY YOU SEE NINE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. GOING BACK TO
YOU MISTER MODERATOR FOR ANY
LET WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OF
TO SB THREE THREE NINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MODERATOR ALRIGHT SINCE
WE CONCLUDED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION DO WERE TAKEN ABACK
HERE TO MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I AM
PLEASED TO SEE THE WIDE RANGE
OF SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IS A
VERY GOOD BILL. I THINK IT'S
PEOPLE HERE MAY RECALL WHEN
THIS LET'S SAY RAISE THE GAS
TAX IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO MAKE
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA TURNED OUT TO BE A
PRETTY BIG DEAL- AND SO I'M
GLAD TO SEE THAT WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD IF IT WAS IF THAT MONEY
WAS WORTH. RAISING THAT IT'S
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE NEEDED IN
THE FUTURE AND THIS IS A VERY
SOUND AND WHERE THE APPROACH OF
FINDING ALTERNATE MEANS OF
DOING SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL AND I WOULD ASK. THAT
MY COLLEAGUE TO PINCH HITTER
RELATED THE AUTHOR I'D LOVE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR- WHEN
OPPORTUNITY ARISES THANK YOU
GREAT. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
SENATOR BECKER. OKAY NO. ANY
OTHER. ARE FROM. ALL RIGHT SEEN
NONE SO MISTER CHIEF CONCERN-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
SENATOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
ON BEHALF. INNER WIENER WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS CRITICAL PROJECT
AND- WE- WILL TAKE NOTICE
CENTER NEWMAN AND- VERY
GRATEFUL HEADED FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR MCGUIRE MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANTS CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AFTER WE
GET A MOTION. FROM MOTIONS THE
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATE
ARCHULETA. MOVED BY SENATOR TO
LET SB THREE THREE NINE. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. GONZALEZ I.
GOALS I BATES. ALLEN ARCHULETA
HI AGILITY BECKER. HI BAKER AYE
CORTESE AYE PATAGIA DOLLY. DOT
DOT I THINK YOU. MCGUIRE GARAI
BELINDA'S. NO MAN NO HUMAN ALL
RIGHT NEWMAN HI RUBIO. BYE BYE.
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE HUMBERT
BY CASKEY WILK. NINE ONE NINE
ONE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
LIFT THE CALL ONCE AGAIN FOR
MEMBERS WHO ARE ABSENCE WILL
START FROM THE TOP AND THINK
AGAIN SENATOR MCGUIRE. THIS IS
CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER ONE.
WHICH ARE THE HIGHWAY NAMING
RESOLUTIONS. SKINNER WHAT BY
CAL SKI. WILK. FOURTEEN ZERO.
OKAY. THANK YOU IN THAT- ARE WE
MISSING ANY MEMBERS ON THAT ONE.
BECAUSE SENATOR OF SENATOR WILK
OKAY AND SENATOR WELLS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. CONSENT
CALENDAR TO. SB. 512-214-6403.
332-163-5280. SEVEN SEVEN
NINETY THREE SIX SIX THREE NINE
NINE. SKINNER. SKINNER AYE WHAT
KASKY. WILK. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL RIGHT GREAT THANK
YOU SENATOR RUSHING THIS THIS
CAPABILITY OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE.
WE'VE CALLED THE WE'VE ASKED
MEMBERS TO COME TO THE CHAMBERS
NOW THIS IS THE THIRD TIME I
BELIEVE RIGHT UNDER WILK SAID I
WANT TO REMIND YOU WE'VE- ASKED.
SIXTEEN ZERO OKAY SIXTEEN ZERO
CONSENT CALENDAR IS COMPLETED
THANK YOU. SB FIVE FORTY EIGHT
BY SENATE EGGMAN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED. CENTER ALAN. YEAH.
THANK. YES SENATOR OF SB FIVE
FORTY EIGHT BY CENTER EGGMAN.
SO THAT WAS THAT AND I CENTER
ALAN HUNT I'M SORRY SENATE
ALLEN I. LAKE COUNTY. SIXTEEN
ZERO SIXTEEN ZERO THAT BILL
MOVES FORWARD SB FIVE FORTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. SB SIX SEVENTY
ONE GONZALEZ MOTIONS TO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY OF
CHAIRED BY SCHERBEL VOTING I'D-
ALLEN. HI ELLEN HI DALY.
MICHALSKI. FIFTEEN ZERO. GREAT
THANK YOU THE BILL MOVES OUT
THANK YOU. SB FIVE EIGHTY BY
SENATOR HUESO TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SO I THINK
THERE WAS THAT ONE IS OUT
SIXTEEN SIR OKAY THAT BILL IS
OUT SB FIVE EIGHTY THANK YOU.
S. B. TWO TWO SEVEN BY SENATOR
JONES TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. THE CHAIRS
A NO VOTE THE VICE CHAIRS AND I
BOUGHT CENTER ALLEN. MAN WHAT
ELSE COULD. TWELVE TO TWELVE TO
THE BILL MOVES OUT AS WELL
THANK YOU. SB FIVE FORTY TWO
LIMON TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR BILL
VOTING AYE. ALLEN HI ELLEN HI.
DALY MCGUIRE. SKINNER HI
SKINNER HI MY CASKET. THE.
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT BILL MOVES OUT AS WELL. SB
SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR BOTH
VOTING AYE. ALAN HI ALAN HI.
SKINNER FIVE SKINNER HI KELSEY.
SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN ZERO SB
SIX TO NINE MONTHS OUT. SB FIVE
HUNDRED BY SENATOR MEN TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIRS AND I VICE YOU'RE NOT
VOTING. BATES ALLEN HI ELLEN HI.
MCGUIRE HI BELINDA'S. SKINNER
HI SKINNER HI WHAT KASKY.
TWELVE TO TWELVE TO THAT BILL
MOVES OUT AS WELL AS P. FIVE
HUNDRED. SB SIX TWENTY THREE
NEWMAN TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. THE
CHILDREN AYE VOTE VICE HAS NOT
VOTED. BATES HI BATES HI WHERE
WHERE HI. MAN. SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE WHY CASKET. FIFTEEN
ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO SB SIXTY
THREE MOVES OUT OF COMMITTEE
THANK YOU PLACERVILLE IS SB
THREE THREE NINE. SB THREE
THREE NINE BY SENATOR WINNER DO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIRS AND I BOTH THE VICE
CHAIR IS NOT BUILT. BATES NO
BATES NO ELLEN. HI ELLEN FIVE.
THE ONLY. DALI NO. MELENDEZ
NUMBER. CASKEY WILK YEAH WELL
NOW. TEN FOUR ALL IGHT TEN FOR
THAT BILL MOVES OUT THAT'S SB
THREE THREE NINE AND I THINK
WE'LL LIVE THE CALL ONCE MORE
THINK SENATOR WILK IS NOW HERE
FOR THE VERY FIRST AND THAT
WILL BE THE FINAL A CALL THE
LIFT ON THE HIGHWAY RENAMING.
THESE ARE THE HIGHWAY NAMING
RESOLUTIONS S. C. R. TWELVE
THAT'S YOUR FIFTEEN S. C. R.
FOURTEEN S. C. R. SEVEN S. C.
R. TWENTY FOUR. I CASKEY WILK.
WELCOME HI. FIFTEEN ZERO
FIFTEEN ZERO K. WE'VE-
SOLIDIFIED KILEY RENAMING THANK
YOU SENATORS THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED THIS
CONCLUDES SENATE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION WE ARE DURING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.